Sam Bankman-Fried, der heißt Bankman, im Sinne von Bankman hat irgendwas mit Geld gemacht.
Ja.
Also er hat 10 Milliarden veruntreut mit Bitcoin-Kram.
Hat den Leuten irgendwie gesagt, ich weiß nicht genau, gebt eure Kohle zu mir
und dann verwalte ich die für euch.
Und er wurde jetzt für 10 Milliarden Schaden 25 Jahre ins Gefängnis verurteilt.
Ja.
Jetzt hast du ja gerade gesagt, du hast ihm keine Kohle gegeben,
gut für dich, damit ist sie noch bei dir.
Hättest du ihm jetzt 200 Euro gegeben? Damit er dir ein paar kleine Bitcoin-Tokens kauft.
Und man rechnet das jetzt hoch, würde er jetzt für dich rechnerisch wahrscheinlich
so drei Sekunden im Gefängnis sitzen. Wäre das gerecht?
Eine schwierige Frage. Die Frage der Gerechtigkeit stellt sich ja heute mehrmals.
Eine ganz ökonomische Frage.
Es ist schwer zu sagen, inwieweit man Gerechtigkeit in dieser Form ableisten
kann durch Einsitzen, also durch Freiheitsentzug.
Wie Schwarzfahren im Grunde.
Ja.
Eine Tour, eine halbe Stunde durch Berlin, Schwarzfahren, drei Tage Gefängnis.
Soll ja eigentlich liberalisiert werden. Ja, das ist ja auch so eine schöne
Debatte, die jetzt wohl in Berlin dran ist.
Was ist mit diesem 29-Euro-Ticket? Hat es eine Zukunft, ja oder nein?
Die Grünen sagen, nein, bitte schafft das 29.
29 oder 49?
Nein, die haben ja eine kleine Subvention da von Berlin aus,
also du bekommst dann das 49-Euro-Ticket günstiger.
Und jetzt ist natürlich die Argumentation, uns fehlt doch überall Geld und da
sagen jetzt die Grünen, nein, wir brauchen dieses 29-Euro-Ticket nicht.
Und dann ist man etwas verwundert, dass die grüne Partei plötzlich eine solche
Maßnahme nicht gut findet und dann argumentiert, ja…,
Geht ja auch an die, die das eigentlich gar nicht brauchen und es wäre besser,
man würde mehr mit Sozialtickets arbeiten, würde also vielleicht noch sehr viel
günstiger sein für die, die dann wenig haben,
die kaum Geld verdienen und dann sollen aber die anderen, die Normalverdiener
sind, auch bitte einen höheren Preis zahlen.
Und dann geht das ja wieder los in einen Bereich, wo man sagt,
ja baut ein bürokratisches Monstrum.
Und es ist eine ganz eigenartige Debatte, die auch sofort dann im Journalismus
stattfindet, dass man sagt, ja ist das denn gerecht?
Ist das dann gerecht, dass du jetzt auch vielleicht 20 Euro Subvention von einer
Stadt bekämpfst, wo man sagen könnte, der Stefan kann sich aber auch das Ticket
für 20 Euro mehr im Monat leisten.
Wir können so anfangen zu argumentieren.
Das ist sehr gut. Das triggert mich direkt.
Ja, es triggert mich auch deshalb so, weil wir permanent die Rede davon haben,
dass die Bürokratie abgebaut gehört.
Nur Bürokratie entsteht dann, wenn man Ausnahmen macht.
Wenn man einfach sagen würde, alle zahlen 50 Prozent Steuern oder so,
dann hat man kaum Bürokratie.
Wenn man anfängt Ausnahmswahn, wenn man anfängt Einzelunternehmen besonders
zu subventionieren, dann entsteht Bürokratie.
Zum Teil ist das sehr richtig, also im Bezug zum Beispiel auf Menschen mit Behinderung,
die brauchen eine andere Art der Betreuung, der Pflege und müssen deshalb eine
Extra-Regel oder müssen viele Extra-Regeln bekommen und das ist ein bürokratischer Aufwand.
Wenn ich jetzt aber mir in den Kopf setze, egal was vom Staate kommt,
es muss progressiv gestaltet sein.
Also das Ticket, wir können auch, ja wir gehen heute Abend in die Oper auch sagen,
warum ist das Opernticket, das ja auch gefördert wird mit vom Staat,
warum machen wir das nicht auch noch gestaffelt, ja so ab 3000 Nettoeinkunft
im Monat muss man dann nochmal 30 Euro mehr zahlen, was auch immer.
Das kann man gerne machen, nur schafft man dann nur noch Bürokratie-Monster.
Man sollte doch vielleicht eher darüber nachdenken, wie könnte man generell
unser großes System, nämlich der Einkommenssteuer und der Kapitalerträge,
du hast es angesprochen im Presseclub, wie könnte man das in einer anderen Weise
gestalten und wirklich progressiv machen. Also wo gehen wir jetzt ran?
Wollen wir jetzt bei jedem Parkticket, bei jedem Ticket für eine U-Bahn nachdenken,
ob man da nochmal eine Staffelung einführt für die verschiedenen Einkommensschichten
und wie sollen die das dann offenlegen und zählen dann geerbtes Geld auch noch dazu?
Oder sagen wir jetzt, nee, es muss schon ganz ordentlich besteuert werden und
das bedeutet Erbschaftssteuer, das bedeutet Kapitalertragssteuer muss progressiv gestaltet sein.
Alles als Einkommenssteuer.
Das muss als Einkommenssteuer geschehen und dann hat man am ganz großen Hebel
mal gezogen und dann muss man sich auf diese Kleinigkeiten nicht mehr konzentrieren,
weil man dann sagen kann, ja,
natürlich profitieren Leute dann auch davon, die das nicht brauchen. Das ist aber ständig so.
Also das ist ja die ganze Zeit so.
Dann kann man auch sagen, ja reiche Leute könnten sich eine Nanny für die Kinder
leisten, die zu Hause die Kinder betreut.
Ja die gehen trotzdem in den kostenlosen Kindergarten. Da sagt man, oh das ist aber schlimm.
Sollen die jetzt da auch nochmal 500 Euro mehr zahlen? Nein,
wenn wir alles progressiv gestalten, dann sind wir ein reiner Verwaltungsstaat
geworden, dann können wir nichts mehr anderes machen, wir sind total genervt.
Man sieht es ja gerade so schön bei den Corona-Hilfen, die Steuerberater sind
bis heute überlastet deshalb,
weil man jetzt gerade prüft, ob im April 2020 irgendjemand 3000 Euro Corona-Hilfe
in Anspruch genommen hat und vielleicht nur 1800 Euro aber gebraucht hat.
Und irgendein PDF, das dazu gehört, ordentlich weggespeichert hat,
sodass man es heute wiederfindet. Ganz richtig.
Und da ist schon die Frage, wäre es nicht besser gewesen, man hätte einfach
ein Helikoptergeld gemacht, hätte das einfach mal wundverstreut und geguckt,
was passiert und hätte nicht mehr weiter nachgefragt.
Ich systematisiere mal, weil da steckt ja so ein kleines Paradox drin.
Wenn man die soziale Frage beantworten will, innerhalb unseres gängigen Systems
müsste man ganz viele Detailfragen klären und käme zu einer Bürokratie.
Gleichzeitig könnte man Bürokratie abbauen, indem man sagt, alle Einkommen werden
als Einkommen behandelt, egal woher und es gibt keine Freibeträge nach oben,
keine Bemessungsgrenze nach oben, sodass einfach alles verbucht wird.
Also wenn Frau Klatten 500 Millionen BMW-Dividende bekommt, dann ist ihr Einkommenssteuersatz,
der Höchststeuersatz 43 Prozent und dann wird einfach die Hälfte davon abgezogen.
Würde vieles vereinfachen.
45 Prozent sind das dann.
Oder 45 Prozent, indem man das so ein bisschen gerade macht.
Und jetzt haben wir das Paradox, dass die soziale Frage aufgeworfen wird,
die aber zu mehr Bürokratie führt, genau von der Partei, die ansonsten immer
dagegen wettert, und zwar gegen beides, die FDP.
Wir haben uns ja, beziehungsweise ich weiß noch, du hast diesen Tweet dazu geschrieben,
der Ernährungsrat hat getagt, das erste von uns ja nicht so befürwortete Gremium
des Bürgerrats, weil was soll der Bürgerrat schon, klar kommen da die einfachsten
und auch sinnvollsten Entscheidungen raus, wie zum Beispiel kostenloses Essen in der Schule.
Kostenloses Essen in der Schule ist so eine simple Idee, dass es jeder machen müsste.
Die Schule als Apparat kostet eh viel, dann kann man auch die eine Million pro
Jahr für tausend Schüler noch oben drauflegen, also es fiele gar nicht auf.
Man hätte ganz viel weniger Bürokratie.
Und hätte dieses Problem einfach gelöst.
Muss man denen dann wieder extra 15 Euro beweisen. Also diese kleine Denkweise,
sorgt dafür, dass sich wirtschaftlich nichts vorankommt.
Es ist wirklich grauenhaft, diese Debatten und genauso auch jetzt mit diesem
29-Euro-Ticket. Ja, das mag sein, dass viele Leute davon...
Ja, lass uns mal bei diesem Essensheber bleiben. Also wir haben jetzt festgestellt,
das Essen einfach zu bezahlen, würde ganz viele Probleme lösen.
Jede Art von können wir es nicht nach jedem Mal verrechnen, da nochmal anmerken,
da nochmal einen Haken im Formular machen. Das wäre wäre alles blöd.
So, jetzt kommt die FDP und will das alles und zwar aufgrund der sozialen Frage.
Also wir hören kurz rein in die von uns natürlich nicht weiter beachtete das
wird auch nochmal im Bundestag besprochen, was der Bürgerrat besprochen hat
und es gab Fragen der FDP.
Der Ausschuss für Ernährung und Landwirtschaft wird sich nun ausführlicher mit
den Inhalten beschäftigen, doch verbindlich sind die Empfehlungen eben nicht.
Was FDP-Politiker Ingo Botge zu der Frage veranlasste, Macht es Sinn,
ein solches unverbindliches Gutachten zu erarbeiten, wenn sich der Bundestag
letztendlich nicht an den Empfehlungen bindet? Was ist das Gegenteil von gut?
Nicht schlecht, sondern gut gemeint.
Sein Parteikollege Gero Hocker zeigte sich ebenfalls skeptisch,
auch bei der Bewertung der Vorschläge.
Beispiel kostenloses gesundes Mittagessen für alle.
Das würde bedeuten, dass diejenigen, die kinderlos sind mit ihren Steuergeldern,
die Mittagessen der Kinder bezahlen, die vielleicht Rechtsanwält sind,
die vielleicht Ärztin sind oder Bundestagsabgeordnete, ich sage ganz ausdrücklich,
das hielte ich für unfair.
Ja, wie wollte man das jetzt operationalisieren, würde der FDP-Mann das ernst
meinen, dass man sagt, okay, die Idee ist eigentlich gut, aber bitte alle Ärzte,
Anwälte und was auch immer, gebt euch zu erkennen, eure Kinder kriegen nichts.
Ja, oder die geerbt haben.
Oder die müssen sich an die Schlange stellen, wo sie nochmal piep,
piep, vorher ihren Token drauflegen, der von den Eltern finanziell aufgeladen wurde.
Also das ist wirklich, manchmal weiß man nicht so genau, was die FDP da macht.
Ja, man kann es nicht aussagen, vor allem ist es ja ein Irrsinnsargument,
Kinderlose zahlen ja die ganze Zeit auch Steuern, damit zum Beispiel Kindergärten
da sind, also das ist ja völliger Unsinn, Kindergeld kommt ja auch irgendwo her,
wir zahlen einander die ganze Zeit, wenn man so möchte, Steuern,
von denen der eine da was hat, der andere dort nichts hat.
Also Leute, das ist ja auch immer dieses Argument, dass gegen die Oper oder
gegen das Theater gemacht wird.
Ja, das ist nur für eine kleine Gruppe, die sich dafür interessiert und wird gefördert.
Ja, das mag so sein, aber Deutschland gibt auch sehr viel für Sportförderung aus.
Da sage ich mal, da habe ich in meinem Leben auch noch nicht von profitiert.
Das ist, so funktioniert das nun mal und wenn man mit diesen Kleinigkeiten anfängt,
dann blendet man ja auch vollkommen aus, welche Effekte was sonst hat.
Es geht ja nicht immer nur darum, ob Leute sich etwas tatsächlich leisten könnten oder nicht.
Wir wissen ja selbst beim 9-Euro-Ticket, dass dieses dafür gesorgt hat,
dass viele Leute sich in Bewegung setzen und das Auto auch zum Teil stehen gelassen haben.
Dann wurde gesagt, ja die haben mehr Fahrten gemacht, ja warum auch nicht,
warum sollte man dann das auch nicht tun.
Und ja es wird Leute geben die brauchen dieses 29 Euro Ticket nicht die haben
sich aber dann doch nochmal durchkalkuliert gesagt haben okay jetzt ist es aber
so viel günstiger mit der U-Bahn zu fahren statt mit dem Auto und lassen das
Auto stehen und das ist doch ein wahnsinnig positiver Effekt.
Diese Kleinteiligkeit in den gesamten Debatten ist so ermüdend und ich bin auch
immer wieder erstaunt darüber, dass Journalisten sich darauf einlassen,
also wie man sich immer so verhaken kann in solchen Kleinigkeiten und nochmal
guckt, für wen wäre das profitabel.
Also man kann ja auch dem Herrn da von der FDP mal vor Augen führen,
wie viele Anwälte, Ärzte und Bundestagsabgeordnete es so in Deutschland gibt,
die entsprechend viel verdienen und dann kann man mal schauen,
wie viel so andere alle verdienen.
Also wie ist es, ich glaube Nettoeinkommen 4700 Euro, dann zählt man zu den
oberen 5% in Deutschland.
Also mit knapp 4.000 bist du Top 10% und mit 8.000 netto bist du schon Top 1% in Deutschland.
Ja.
Was bedeutet 8.000 Euro, sagen wir es mal so, wer 8.000 Euro netto verdient,
müsste also brutto irgendwo, keine Ahnung, 12, 13, 14, so in der Höhe.
Ja.
Man ist, also das korreliert ein bisschen damit, dass man keine Zeit hat,
sich mittags um die Kinder zu kümmern.
Ja. Also gerade sehr gut Verdiente, nämlich vielbeschäftigte Menschen,
die also dann wahrscheinlich auch mehr als 40 Stunden am Tag arbeiten,
immer auf Abruf, was auch immer, die haben ein eigentlich besonderes Interesse
daran, dass sie sich nicht darum kümmern müssen, 15 Jahre lang,
wie das Kind in der Schule ernährt wird.
Sondern wenn man da den Schalter einfach mal umlegt und sagt,
ist geregelt und ist gesund, wäre das wirklich ein netter Benefit für alle.
Das ist eh eine große Diskussion, das wird im Familienbuch auch eine Rolle spielen. Ja.
Investition in Kinder. Also wir können ja nicht aus der Familie ausweichen.
Da gibt es viele Beispiele, wie das historisch versucht wurde.
Kindererziehung und Kinderproduktion, also von Erzeugung bis zur Sozialisation,
wie man sie sich selber vorstellt als Gesellschaft. Jenseits der Familie.
Hat noch nie funktioniert. Also wir sind immer auf die Familie angewiesen und
jetzt ist die Frage, wie abstrahieren wir trotzdem ein gesellschaftliches Interesse
daran, ohne die Familien zu sehr überlasten.
Also, so wie du es eben in dieser Formulierung hattest, Menschen ohne Kinder
bezahlen ja für die mit Kindern.
Dieses Denken könnte man eben mal eine Stufe höher legen und sagen,
ich bin ein Mensch und ich bin jetzt, keine Ahnung, 40, 50 oder vielleicht 60 Jahre.
Das heißt, ich brauche, irgendwann rutsche ich in die Versorgungsklasse rein.
Ich werde versorgt. Von wem werde ich eigentlich versorgt?
Naja, wir haben es soweit geschafft zu sagen, die Alterssicherung ist entkoppelt
von der eigenen Familie.
Ich werde versorgt von den Kindern der anderen.
Von den Kindern der anderen, genau. Und das muss man auch vorher schon einpreisen. Ja.
Also wenn man irgendwen sieht mit einem Kind am Arm, der irgendwas gesellschaftlich
unternehmen möchte, damit es dem Kind gut geht, muss man immer selber gleich
rein abstrahieren, ah ja, das ist ja mein Rentenzahler und so.
Und wenn man das drin hat, kommt man sowieso nicht in solche Diskussionen, wie die FDP das da führt.
Also dass man es wieder so rein individualisiert und partikularisiert,
dass man sagt, ah ja, das ist ja ein Anwaltskind.
Ja. Der wird ja gesellschaftlich rausgenommen, weil der hat ja einen Anwaltsvater
oder so, der das machen kann. Das ist ja eigentlich völlig bescheuert,
so zu denken. Aber gut, das ist unsere FDP.
Wir sind in einer alten Republik und wir möchten über den Krieg reden und wir
haben das letzte Mal über Boris Pistorius geredet, unseren Bürgerkanzler, kann man das so sagen?
Ja, es ist der Lieblingskanzler. Ja, ich sehe immer bei Twitter irgendwelche
Jusos, denen auch zur sozialen Frage nichts einfällt und die posten aber täglich,
wie wunderbar Pistorius das wieder gemacht hat.
Hat dieser Auftritt, dieser Schmiss, dieser Elan in der Rede und man denkt dann
immer so, ja, der hat jetzt wieder so was gesagt, aber ändert sich jetzt dadurch viel?
Also wir können ja mal uns die Frage stellen, wenn Boris Pistorius das jetzt
gerade nicht machen würde, verändert sich tatsächlich politisch etwas oder hat
sich die Performance geändert?
Und da würde ich sagen, die Performance ist etwas besser geworden.
Das ist ein wichtiger Punkt. Wir haben ja schon darauf hingewiesen,
feministische Außenpolitik,
okay Außenpolitik, man müsste eh mal dieses feministische Politik etwas mehr
beschreiben, kultivieren, sodass man die Essenz von dem, was da gemeint war, eigentlich mal fasst.
Jetzt haben wir Boris Pistorius eingewechselt und Christine Lambrecht ausgewechselt.
Lambrecht ist mit dem Tenor gegangen, hat nichts gebracht und so weiter.
Wir haben jetzt beim letzten Mal darüber gesprochen, dass Pistorius nicht nur
bisher wenig gebracht hat, sondern auch wenig plant.
Also er bereitet sich gar nicht auf eine Trump-Präsidentschaft vor, was auch immer.
Frankreich müssen wir uns nicht mit befassen, es soll mal alles bleiben, wie es ist.
Der einzige Unterschied ist, dass er mit so einer entsprechenden tiefen Bauchatmung
eine Ansage macht, die dann auch mal so einfach performativ im Fernsehen gut funktioniert.
Wenn das der einzige Unterschied ist und wir aber so eine krass unterschiedliche
Bewertung in unserer Gesellschaft haben, wie drängend und dringend ist dann
eigentlich wirklich noch so dieses feministische Ding mal rauszuarbeiten?
Und mit feministisch meinen wir ja nicht, klar da steckt jetzt die Frau als
Begrifflichkeit drin, aber da geht es dann wirklich mal um die Differenz Mann
und Frau, alle Werte, die man da dem zuschreibt und so weiter,
wie man das dann rezipiert als politisches Publikum.
Die Rezeption ist hier ein starker Mann mit tiefer Stimme.
Genau. Und gleichzeitig beruhigt er uns damit, dass ja die armen Männer in der
Ukraine für uns sterben.
Also dieses Konglomerat finde ich wirklich crazy, weshalb ich umso mehr daran
arbeiten möchte, Boris Pistorius wirklich zu entzaubern.
Er ist ja noch nicht Kanzler, sondern er ist Verteidigungsminister,
hat damit einige Aufgaben, von denen wir sagen, die sind in der Zukunft relevant. Wand.
So, und jetzt im Alltag schlägt er sich rum mit dieser komischen Abhöraffäre,
wo man ja einfach sagen muss,
okay, sein oberster Militär in der Angelegenheit Taurus hat sich per Telefon
in so eine Webschalte eingewählt, in Singapur, lacht noch darüber und freut
sich, in was für einem geilen Hotel da da ist, weil er irgendwie,
keine Ahnung und so, also es ist wirklich auf allen Ebenen total daneben.
Nur mit halbem Ohr zugehört, aber im Logbuch Netzpolitik habe ich noch so verstanden,
dass er selber mal Informatik studiert hat, also eigentlich so wüsste, wo so die,
Grenzen der Fähigkeiten von Computern sind und was man so nicht tun sollte und
das gerade verbunden mit seinem Verantwortungsbereich und so weiter,
das hätte eigentlich irgendwie, keine Ahnung, es ist, dass die da abgehört wurden,
ist wirklich einfach dumm.
Also wirklich richtig einfach dummes Verhalten.
So, Boris Pistorius muss das jetzt entschuldigen, weil er kann ja nicht seine
Leute dem, was auch immer, wie Putin da asymmetrische Kriege führt, opfern.
Und er erklärt uns das mit folgendem Wortlaut.
Und das wiederum führt dann zu der Erkenntnis, dass es hier nur darum geht,
diesen Mitschnitt zu benutzen, nämlich um zu destabilisieren und zu verunsichern.
Und das liegt an uns, ob wir über dieses Stöckchen springen,
was Putin uns hinhält, oder ob wir besonnen weiter unsere Bahn ziehen,
konsequent arbeiten, entschlossen bleiben und da nacharbeiten,
wo sich die Notwendigkeit ergibt.
Also Putin ist schuld.
Besonnen die Bahn ziehen.
Besonnen die Bahn ziehen, ja.
Fokus halten.
Wie kann er denn, wo kommt das Ansehen her, frage ich mich. Das ist wirklich auf so vielen Ebenen.
Ja, es ist rein performativ. Man sieht ihn und denkt, ja, so stelle ich mir
einen Verteidigungsminister vor.
Und bei Christine Lambrecht hat man sich das angesehen und gesagt,
nee, so stelle ich es mir nicht vor.
Ja, irgendwie so. Aber die Kriterien, nach denen man so stellt,
er ist für mich Inbegriff der alten Republik.
Das ist wirklich der Möchtegern-Kanzler für die Alten. Die Heinz Bude nochmal.
Heinz Bude hat im Hörsaal, also im Hörsaal, im Deutschlandfunk-Hörsaal haben
sie so einen Vortrag von ihm jetzt zu den Boomern.
Boomer zeichnen sich vor allem auch dadurch aus, dass sie, wie er es genannt,
so eine Katastrophe nie erlebt haben.
Es drohte immer. Die Tschernobyl-Wolke ist aber doch nicht gekommen.
Der Russe ist doch nicht gekommen. Es ist alles nochmal gut gegangen.
Und das hat sich jetzt so richtig dich eingeschärft in die, nee,
am Ende geht's schon gut.
Und Boris Pistorius vermittelt denen das. Am Ende wird's schon gut.
Da wird nicht gewählt, der Trump.
Ich möchte den Boomern zur Seite springen und du hast gesehen,
in unserem Live-Salon in Frankfurt waren auch viele Boomer da.
Es kommen immer mehr Boomer zu uns, was mich freut. Und ich würde auch sagen,
ich sehe genau das Phänomen Boris Pistorius ja bei den Jungen, die den toll finden.
Das auch.
Müssen wir dann nicht nur die Boomer in die Kritik nehmen, sondern die Jungen
oder wir sagen, Boomer sein ist ein Gemütszustand, der sich ausgebreitet hat, auch auf die Jungen.
Es geht um den Gemütszustand in den Köpfen, der ist auch bei den Jungen zu finden
und wenn ich die Boomer sage und du sagst, aber Einzelne sitzen ja bei uns,
genau, die Ausnahmen bestätigen die Regeln und zu den,
Boomen gehört ja nun die Eigenschaft, dass ich immer sagen kann,
ich meine ja die 750 Millionen anderen, die es auch noch gibt.
Sie sind einfach immer noch genug da, die man meint, wenn wir sie ansprechen.
Weisen wir doch ganz schnell darauf hin, dass wir ein Live-Salon aufgenommen haben.
Wir sprechen dort nicht über KI, sondern wir sprechen dann über Dating.
Du hast hier die Sendung First Dates angesehen. Ich habe mir angesehen,
was tut sich im Reality-TV vom Bachelor bis hin zu dem, was bei TikTok zu sehen
ist mit Veronica is cool,
ein doch medial hochinteressantes Phänomen.
Das kann man also nachhören, wenn man den Salon abonniert hat oder ihn abonnieren will.
Und wir wollen an dieser Stelle auch darauf hinweisen, was wir im nächsten Salon lesen.
Warte, ich will zwei Nachträge machen zum Salon, den wir auf der Bühne hatten.
Zum einen Olivia Jones, ich habe nochmal nachgelesen in meinem eigenen Text.
Stimmt, sie ist mit der Maske geblieben und ich habe dann die Pointe draus gestrickt
und ich habe mich dann auch daran erinnert, als ich es nochmal las,
dass sie natürlich als Kunstfigur da reinging,
optisch auch Kunstfigur blieb,
aber selten war jemand so menschlich wie dieser Oliver Knöbel da drin.
Vielleicht kann man nur durch die Maske menschlich sprechen.
Ja, es war natürlich auch diese Ausgabe, in der auch Helmut Berger für drei
Tage oder so mit drin war.
Ich habe dann nochmal reingeschrieben, dass neben allen und so weiter auch der
Hauptdarsteller Helmut Berger nochmal kurz da war.
Und zweitens diese Idle Games.
Roman hat mich darauf hingewiesen, dass wir diese Idle Games falsch beschrieben
hätten, weil wir ja nur die Optik und so.
Ich habe es mir dann mal runtergeladen und habe es zwei Tage lang jetzt gespielt.
Dieses Spielprinzip ist wirklich so wahnsinnig bescheuert, man kann es sich kaum vorstellen.
Wir alle wissen, was ein Fußballmanager ist, auch wenn wir nicht selber Computer spielen.
So, jetzt hat man in diesem Spiel Minen, also Minenarbeiter.
Die könnte man selber immer anklicken, damit sie graben. Oder man stellt einen
Manager ein, der für einen die immer antippt.
Dann braucht man einen Schachtfahrer, den kann man selber antippen.
Oder man stellt einen Manager ein, der den immer antreibt.
Dann braucht man jemanden, der das über der Erde nochmal transportiert.
Also es gibt so, sagen wir mal, drei, vier verschiedene Gewerke und dann Manager,
die die antreiben. Und dein einziges Ziel ist,
Diese Mine läuft relativ zügig automatisch, weil du stellst Manager ein.
Man lässt Leute für sich arbeiten.
Und dann musst du als Overlord gottgleich die Management-Entscheidung treffen,
wo du welchen Manager und wie hoch du den levelst, damit alles ungefähr im ökonomischen
Gleichgewicht ist und möglichst zügig, nicht unten in der Grube sich was ansammelt
oder im Fahrstuhl zu wenig transportiert werden kann, sondern dass alles zügig oben mündet.
Und der Clou ist, dass du dann, wenn dir das zu kompliziert ist,
das genau zu beobachten, wo du die Stellschrauben hast, dann kannst du einfach
echte Euros ausgeben, um so super Top-Manager einzustellen.
Genau, dann fängt die Monetarisierung an, also man investiert dann darin,
dass man nicht mehr so selbst spielen muss, also man,
entledigt sich dann auch irgendwann noch des Spielenmüssens und ich finde es
ja, das haben wir ja schon herausgearbeitet, so interessant,
dass Leute so ein Spiel spielen,
in dem sie Leute delegieren können Oder dann nochmal so weit delegieren,
dass sie Manager haben, die delegieren und sie selbst befinden sich aber gerade
in der U-Bahn, spielen dieses Spiel und werden dann auf ihrer Arbeitsstelle delegiert.
Dann ist der Manager da, der sagt, machen sie mal das hier, aber warum? Ja, Ansage von oben.
Genau, du fährst zur Arbeit und weißt, du bist hier eigentlich so ein Angestellter
für das passive Einkommen eines anderen.
Ja.
Und in dem Spiel bist du mal derjenige, der das passive Einkommen bekommt.
Du gibst aber am Ende noch Geld aus, damit du das mal da dann zumindest spielerisch bekommst.
Aber du hast es so drei Stunden in der Hosentasche gehabt, guckst mal wieder,
wie deine automatisiert laufende Mine, ob sie gut justiert ist.
Also es ist echt nochmal ein eigenes Phänomen, sollte man vielleicht,
sollten wir irgendwann nochmal so aufgreifen. Ich glaube, da verbirgen sich noch ein paar Pointen.
Ja.
Dann weisen wir kurz darauf hin, wir wollen im nächsten Salon uns mit dem Thema
Religion beschäftigen und zwar ist man vielleicht doch darauf angewiesen zu
glauben und kommt man dann ohne Religion aus.
Das sagt der Philosoph Martin Hegglund.
Martin Hegglund hat ein Buch geschrieben, das heißt Dieses eine Leben,
Glaube jenseits der Religion, Freiheit jenseits des Kapitalismus.
Es ist bei CH Beck erschienen, es wird von vielen berühmten Leuten gelobt.
Wir werden sehen, ob das hält, was es verspricht.
Es ist glaube ich ein Thema, das deshalb wichtig ist, weil wir sehen,
wie die Komponente des Glaubens sehr stark in der Popkultur vorhanden ist.
Wir haben eine Rückkehr von Religion auch tatsächlich institutioneller Natur,
wie auch in Form von irgendwelchen Sekten oder man kann natürlich auch solche
Gemeinden beschreiben, die sich da sammeln um Kryptowährungen oder um alternative
Wissenschaften, um es einmal neutral auszudrücken.
Und es gibt offenbar ein Bedürfnis danach zu glauben.
Und es gibt auch ein Bedürfnis danach, unsere neue, moderne,
angeblich säkularisierte Welt zu verstehen.
Ja.
Ja, wenn wir rückblickend auf Religion zurückschauen und dann immer feststellen,
okay, das haben wir so wenig erlebt wie die Weltkriege.
Wir lesen also in Büchern, man ist gepilgert, man hatte Rituale,
man hatte Lebensform und so weiter.
Jetzt haben wir die Kirche soweit aussortiert, nur wir stellen ja fest,
es wird ja trotzdem noch ganz schön krass gepilgert.
Und es gibt auch noch ganz schön viele Rituale, die so stattfinden.
Und sie werden auch medial vermittelt, so wie die Kirche ja auch relativ früh
auf die medialen, also die ersten Bücher, die gedruckt worden waren, halt Bibeln und so.
In der Hinsicht, wir hatten das ja in der Nullnummer dieses Podcasts schon angesprochen.
Je nachdem, was der Autor imstande ist, uns aufzuschreiben, ist das nochmal
Wespennest, würde ich sagen.
Ja, könnte so sein. Sag noch schnell, wie man in den Salon kommt.
Man geht auf neue20er.de. Mir ist aufgefallen, es gibt ganz viele Podcasts.
Wir für die Clips versuchen ja immer die Audio-Version der Podcasts runterzuladen.
Und es ist manchmal gar nicht so einfach, weil man einfach so einen Player hat.
Manche Podcasts verweisen gar nicht mehr auf ihren RSS-Feed,
sondern sagen einfach, hör doch bei Spotify oder Apple, da kriegt man auch nichts runtergeladen.
Mir ist aufgefallen, dass relativ wenig Podcasts noch richtige Webseiten haben.
Wir haben also eine richtige Webseite und die heißt neue20er.de und da kann
man übrigens auch einfach so die Dateien runterladen, falls man selber mal einen Clip machen will.
Und da prangt ein goldener Button, Salon, klickt man einfach drauf.
Der Rest ist, glaube ich, selbst erklären.
Dann kommt man zu Steady und kann dort für 2,50 Euro im Monat den Salon hören
und wenn man jetzt sein Abo abschließt, kann man natürlich auch alle vorherigen
Salons hören und das sind sehr, sehr viele. Wir machen das ja seit 2020.
Und dann gibt es noch die Möglichkeit, das über Apple zu buchen.
Das ist da ein bisschen teurer, weil Apple, darüber werden wir heute auch noch
reden, ein bisschen mehr verlangt, wenn sie ihren Marktplatz anbieten.
Und für diejenigen, die bei Patreon sind, können das auch gleich über Patreon machen.
Aber wir empfehlen Steady. Und damit gehen wir hinein in die Debatte um die
Taurus-Lieferung und hören uns an, was sich dazu getragen hat im Bundestag.
Scholz und Norbert Röttgen geraten aneinander. Wir hören rein.
Sehr geehrter Herr Bundeskanzler, ich möchte bei dem deutsch-französischen Verhältnis
bleiben und auf eine konkrete Aussage von Ihnen vor der Presse am 26.
Februar zu sprechen kommen. Ich darf Sie zitieren in dem Zusammenhang mit der
Lieferung von Marschflugkörpern.
Ich zitiere Sie, das, was an Zielsteuerung vonseiten der Briten und Franzosen
gemacht wird, kann in Deutschland nicht gemacht werden. werden.
Das wäre aus meiner Sicht etwas, das nicht zu verantworten wäre,
wenn wir uns auf gleiche Weise beteiligen würden.
Weiter heißt es, stellt sich die Frage, ob es zu einer Kriegsbeteiligung kommen
kann durch das, was wir tun.
Diese Ausführungen werfen die Frage auf, ob sie der Auffassung sind,
der völkerrechtlichen Auffassung, dass Frankreich und Großbritannien durch die
Lieferung der der Marsch für Körper, Kriegsbeteiligte geworden sind.
Wenn Sie diese Frage verneinen, stellt sich die Anschlussfrage,
warum Sie die Gefahr sehen, dass Deutschland Kriegsbeteiligter würde,
wenn Deutschland sich, wie Sie sagen, auf gleiche Weise verhalten würde,
wie es Frankreich und Großbritannien tun.
Worüber wird hier eigentlich geredet? Also es gibt da so eine Äußerung,
wohl von Scholz, er teilt mit, dass wir das nicht so machen können wie die Franzosen
oder Engländer und Norbert Röttgen will das nicht verstehen.
Und ich sage bewusst, will das nicht verstehen, denn ich glaube schon,
dass er es an sich versteht.
Aber wir sind hier im Wahlkampfmodus, wie man eigentlich immer in der Politik im Wahlkampfmodus ist.
Aber ich finde es hier in gewisser Weise fahrlässig, dass man das mit einem
solchen Thema derart spielt.
Die Sache ist doch eigentlich gar nicht so widersprüchlich, wenn man sich mal
darüber nachdenkt, wo Deutschland liegt,
welche Macht Deutschland innerhalb Europas hat, wie die sehr gute Beziehung
gerade zu den USA aussieht, dass man sagt,
ja, es ist möglich, dass die anderen etwas tun, was wir nicht tun können,
weil dies als ein Kriegseintritt bewertet werden könnte.
Was aber nicht bedeutet, dass wenn die anderen das tun, dass das auch ein Kriegseintritt ist.
Und dann geht es ja nicht allgemein um irgendwelche Marschflugkörper nur,
sondern es geht ja jetzt hier auch nochmal ganz konkret um die Taurus-Lieferungen,
zu denen Scholz eine ganz klare Meinung hat.
Und er sagt, die können wir nicht liefern, denn diese Waffe funktioniert nur
so, dass wir deutsche Soldaten da hinschicken.
Außerdem hat die gewisse Möglichkeiten, die in einer Situation,
in der sich die Ukraine befindet, nämlich in einer, wo Eskalationsspiralen natürlich
laufend in Gang gesetzt werden,
ein angegriffenes Land, man kann es sich vorstellen, Dass da nicht gewährleistet
ist, dass also man quasi über das einmal vereinbarte Ziel hinausschießt.
Also wir blenden ja hier noch aus, was wir schon wissen, nämlich dass es da
irgendwelche komischen Super-Hardware-Dinger gibt und so.
Das ist ja dann auch in der Kontroverse für den Clip, den du bestimmt nachher noch spielst.
Diese Taurus, also nach dem, was man öffentlich über die Taurus weiß,
wenn man sich so YouTube-Videos anguckt oder so, würde ich sagen,
das ist eine Waffe, die braucht man, um einen Krieg zu gewinnen.
Also wenn man das Kriegsziel formuliert, Putin erledigen, dann kann man sie liefern.
Wenn es aber nur, und so heißt es ja bislang aus dem Bundeskanzleramt,
die Ukraine darf den Krieg nicht verlieren, dann kann man sie eigentlich nicht
liefern, weil sie einfach für diese Aufgabe nicht gemacht ist.
Dann müsste man jetzt sagen, okay, mehr Flugabwehr oder wie auch immer,
dass die Russen einfach, wenn sie wieder 60 Raketen losschicken,
auch wirklich zuverlässig alle 60 abgeschossen werden.
Da hat Deutschland übrigens auch tolle Munition, die dann so in der Luft explodiert
und dann ist so ein Umkreis von 500 Metern, also man muss gar nicht so genau zielen.
Man könnte dann diese Angriffe einfach abwehren.
Wenn Röttgen sich da so breitbeinig hinstellt und sagt, Taurus muss geliefert
werden und dann kommen so drei grammatikalisch richtige Konjunktivsätze,
um ihn dann irgendwie in die Ecke zu treiben,
Dann sollte Röttgen auch sozusagen den politischen Überbau mitliefern und sagen,
die CDU-Fraktion ist jetzt der Meinung, Putin muss weg.
Also es einfach strapazieren, so wie wir bei Corona auch irrerweise gesagt haben, Zero Covid. Covid.
War ja, wie wir heute wissen, ein nicht erreichbares Ziel, aber man hat es politisch formuliert.
Deshalb sind ja auch einige Lockdown-Maßnahmen bis hin zu, ja dann gehen wir
jetzt auch invasiv, machen eine Impfpflicht und so, so radikal ausgefallen.
Dass sie das heute nicht aufarbeiten wollen, schön und gut. Aber so auf der
politischen Verhandlungsebene sehe ich das jetzt hier auch.
Sich da hinzustellen und zu sagen, Taurus muss geliefert werden.
Also ich glaube, die Russen interessieren zwei Sachen gar nichts.
Zum einen, was ist jetzt völkerrechtlich noch richtig oder falsch?
Also im Sinne von, wenn sich Deutschland so und so verhält, dann ist da eine
juristische rote Linie überschritten.
Also sieht Putin dann, ah ja, jetzt kann ich so und so eskalieren.
Das halte ich für totalen Quatsch. Also das ist eine ganz innerdeutsche Diskussion.
Und Taurus ist halt ein Waffensystem, das irgendwie anders funktioniert als andere.
Und da kann Herr Masala weil er noch so viel in irgendwelchen Podcasts mir erklären,
es gibt keinen Unterschied zwischen Offensiv- und Defensivwaffen.
Also eine Waffe, die in ein Gebäude reinfliegt und nach siebeneinhalb Metern,
nachdem sie zwei Mauern durchbrochen hat, erst explodieren soll,
ist keine Verteidigungswaffe.
Die hat einfach ein anderes Einsatzszenario. So, und wenn man die da einsetzen
will, dann ist das auch nur verbindbar, finde ich, mit der Formulierung,
wir verlagern den Krieg jetzt nach Russland und wollen dort,
Die Ministerien, die den mitorganisieren, irgendwelche, keine Ahnung,
800 Kilometer von der Grenze liegenden Einrichtungen und so weiter gezielt zerstören.
Ja, also dann kann man sagen, wir erklären mal vorläufig den dritten Weltkrieg und gucken mal weiter.
Genau. Und solange die CDU sich da nicht durchringt, sondern die Diskussion
einfach ausspart und Scholz eben nicht weiter fordert, wenn er einfach sagt,
ja die Ukraine darf den Krieg nicht verlieren.
Weil das ist ja eigentlich, finde ich, immer noch das, was im Hintergrund so
schwelt, dass die Amerikaner einfach jetzt einen Status Quo des Krieges etablieren.
Also lieber Krieg statt Chaos, weil Frieden bedeutet kein Chaos.
Russland würde sich wieder neu aufbauen, Putin könnte seine Macht wieder,
konsolidieren, wie man so schön sagt, also sich wieder rein etablieren ins System
und sagen, wir haben in der Ukraine nicht verloren und jetzt haben wir Zeit,
jetzt haben wir Lernerfolge, die wir umsetzen können, in zwei Jahren greifen
wir wieder an, wie auch immer, solche Sachen.
Und so hält man Putin permanent beschäftigt.
Meine Vermutung ist, der Westen hat sich jetzt dafür entschieden,
dass das der neue Status Quo ist, so wie man sich auch 2014 schon mal dafür
entschied, dass diese Region da einfach umkämpft ist und alle Diskussionen darum
finden aber nicht statt. Auf Kosten von Männern.
Also das muss man sich ganz klar vor Augen bringen, dass man sagt,
okay, beide Seiten geben da jeweils ihre Leute rein.
Als würden die so ein Idle War spielen, indem sie einfach immer mal nachgucken,
wie es gerade so läuft und dann nachjustieren.
Ja, das ist ein ganz gruseliges Bild, aber ich glaube, darauf kann sich der
Westen gerade einigen. und da läuft die Taurus-Diskussion so ein bisschen...
Kreuz und quer dazu.
Und deshalb ist ja die Frustration auch bei den Ukrainern, auch gerade bei jenen,
die schon gekämpft haben, so groß, weil sie merken, ach so, ich werde hier verschlissen
im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Wir hören jetzt mal weiter, was Scholz darauf antwortet und wir denken jetzt
mal darüber nach, wir hatten diese großen Debatten über Demokratie und Transparenz.
Du hast bei der FAZ damals gearbeitet, als die Piratenpartei sagten,
wir brauchen eine Transparenzgesellschaft.
Große Debatten, dann hat jemand wie Bion Schulhan gesagt, nein,
Regieren braucht das Geheimnis.
Dann hat man versucht mal zu zeigen, wie kriegt man eine Transparenzgesellschaft hin.
Bei Stuttgart 21, Heiner Geisler hat 100 Stunden lang bei Phoenix solche Schlichtungsrunden
moderiert und da wurde mal alles auf den Tisch gelegt und jetzt sehen wir gerade
bei diesen RKI-Files ja,
da muss also irgendein kleines Medium die erstmal freikämpfen juristisch.
Wie skandalös jetzt das, was drinsteht, ist, wissen wir jetzt nicht.
Also wir zwei nicht aus direkter Anschauung, wir sind jetzt da nicht durchgegangen.
Es gibt ja auch einige Passagen, die geschwärzt sind. Also wir merken schon,
aha, das Geheimnis spielt eine Rolle, auch in einer Demokratie,
in einer offenen Gesellschaft etc.
Ich glaube, die RKI-Files sind derzeit nur so interessant, weil man einfach
die Idee hat, ah, da kann ich doch mal mit GPT nachfragen, weißt du?
Ach so, ja.
Dass es der erste Fall ist, in dem man sagt, okay, die schicken mir jetzt 1000 PDF-Seiten.
Ich bin ja auch verwundert, dass manche Journalisten offenbar nach drei Minuten
schon alle Files durchhaben und sagen, nee, nee, es ist also gar nichts drin.
Also das finde ich auch interessant.
Ich würde sagen, vielleicht braucht man gar nicht so sehr diese Files.
Also ich bin nicht jemand, der, also ich traue auch vielen vieles dazu innerhalb
dieses ganzen Umkreises Jens Spahn, Lauterbach und so, das will ich hier gar nicht verhehlen,
würde aber jetzt auch nicht das alles so im Bausch und Bogen verurteilen wollen,
aber ich sag mal so, braucht man,
So viel Einblicke in Akten oder würde es nicht manchmal reichen,
einfach nur mal Clips sich nochmal anzusehen von damals, also einfach nochmal Talkshows von 2020,
21, 22 und solche Debatten um AstraZeneca ist ein sehr guter Impfstoff,
Schnelltests sind keine Lösung, das ist nicht die Lösung und dann drittens noch
nur ein harter Lockdown kann jetzt noch helfen.
Also wenn man mal diese drei Punkte so nachverfolgt und Debatten noch sieht
oder vielleicht noch Impfpflicht, ja, nein, was sagt der Ethikrat gerade?
Ist schon Montag oder Donnerstag? Lass uns das mit einer Pointe abschließen.
Dann würde ich sagen, dann kommt man, man braucht vielleicht gar nicht so sehr
die Files, sondern man sichte eigentlich da schon sehr viel,
was sich da, naja, so semi gut entwickelt hat.
Matthias hat die Tage in unsere Chatgruppe geschrieben, die RKI-Files zeigen nichts Neues.
Man hätte einfach damals konsequent schon für alle Kekulés Podcast hören sollen,
weil es gute und sehr gute Impfstoffe gibt und so weiter. Das hat ja Kekulé
damals alles schon, dass die PCR-Tests viel zu teuer abgerechnet wurden.
Ja, das hat auch Kekulé damals alles schon betont. Also eigentlich steckt da
alles schon im Kekulé-Podcast beim MDR drin, würde ich auch sagen.
Also es ist auch meine These und ich finde es eine sehr gute Pointe auch.
Okay, weil du den Namen Kekulé jetzt angesprochen hast, müssen wir springen.
Tut mir leid, das ist jetzt eine ganz andere Dramaturgie.
Wir müssen jetzt und zwar zu einem meiner letzten Clips springen,
denn Böhmermann hören wir jetzt nochmal.
Wir hören uns den ersten Clip an, wie er damals mit Markus Lanz diskutierte
und Giovanni Di Lorenzo zum Thema Kekulé-Streik.
Und bei dir in der Sendung, das Einladen von so Leuten wie Hendrik Streeck und
Alexander Kekulé, wo man fachlich wirklich sagt, das ist keine gute Idee.
Und die Leute, die Ahnung haben davon, also wenn du mit Wissenschaftlern sprichst,
die seit Jahren an diesem Thema forschen und auf einmal taucht da irgendwie
ein Hallenser Mikrobiologe auf, der nichts publiziert hat.
Lass mich mal selbst formulieren. Ich finde es schwierig,
wenn man Leuten eine Bühne gibt, die eine Meinung vertreten,
die man nur deswegen veröffentlicht, weil man sagt, man muss auch die andere Seite sehen.
Und es gibt Meinungen, die sind so durchtränkt von Menschenfeindlichkeit oder
so motiviert von Dingen, die nichts damit zu tun haben.
Und zwar ersichtlich, dass ich mich manchmal frage, warum einige Leute bei dir sitzen.
Menschenfeindlichkeit, was du meinst? Naja, also es gibt Positionen,
die im Kern menschenfeindlich sind.
Und dann geht das so weiter und so weiter. Mir ging es jetzt aber nicht darum,
einfach nur nochmal das alte Süppchen aufzukochen, sondern Böhmermann war jetzt
in einem Podcast zu Gast, nämlich bei Jagoda Marinic in dem Podcast Freiheit
Deluxe und wird genau darauf angesprochen.
Es ist jetzt ein sehr langer Clip, aber wir hören uns den mal komplett an.
Wir sind jetzt also im Frühjahr 2024.
Es ist viel Wasser den Rhein hinuntergelaufen und wir könnten jetzt sagen,
naja, damals waren das so erhitzte Gemüter und man wusste ja auch selbst nicht,
tappte etwas im Dunkeln. Vielleicht sollte man dann aber auch nicht solche Äußerungen treffen.
Naja, man könnte also jetzt seine eigene Position relativieren.
Und wir hören uns jetzt mal an, was Böhmermann sagt und da schicke ich schon die Pointe voraus.
Dass solange so die Aufarbeitung nicht stattfindet bei so meinungsführenden Leuten,
ist das wichtig, dass man jetzt eine Enquete-Kommission, Untersuchungsausschuss,
was auch immer hat, der sich auch mit den RKI-Falls und all dem beschäftigt.
Nicht, weil ich auf Rache oder so sinne, aber ich würde sagen,
wer sich so der Aufklärung versperrt und auch der Selbsterklärung,
der macht definitiv etwas falsch. wir hören uns jetzt immer diesen ganzen Clip an.
Ich drücke für dich.
Während Corona, wo du dann gesagt hast, die Leute, die er da draufsetzt,
die sind menschenfeindlich.
Also warum positionierst du dich da? Also auch gerade in so einer Zeit,
wo eigentlich viele mit auch ein Unwissen und Unsicherheit gestraft waren, in so einer Klarheit.
Und sagst dann halt, nee, das geht gar nicht.
Und das ist die Position, also Bühne geben für Menschenfeinde,
wie, ich glaube, Strick und Kekulé hast du damals gemacht. Naja,
also ich bin mit dem Messer zum Gunfight gekommen da im Michel.
Aber die grundsätzliche Haltung ist... Warum?
Er glaubt, er hätte nur das Messer gehabt und die anderen wären aber mit Schießwaffen
ausgerüstet gewesen in diesem Gespräch.
Offenbar.
Ich glaube, er ist mit einer Atombombe in einen Kaffeeklatsch reingerannt.
Ja, würde ich auch sagen.
Hätte ich schon so erwartet, dass er dich killen würde. Nein,
ich dachte, es ist ein Pistolen-Duell, aber nicht, dass es ein Messer-Duell
ist, aber es wurde geschossen.
Ich habe eben diese Unsicherheit gerade in der Corona-Zeit, da ist mir vor allem
aufgestoßen, dass diese Unsicherheit missbraucht, politisch missbraucht wurde
von Leuten, die eine persönliche Agenda oder politische Agenda hatten und das
geknüpft haben an so Geschichten.
Wie Gesundheitsvorsorge beziehungsweise die Diskussion zum Thema Impfen oder
wie man mit so einer Ausnahmesituation wie der Pandemie umzugehen hat.
Und dass da immer nur das Gesundheitsargument oder der Wille,
die Pandemie einzudämmen und möglichst auch schwache Teile der Bevölkerung,
verletzliche Teile der Bevölkerung zu schützen, so ein Sekundäragument war.
Und da dann gerne auch, also die Freiheit als Kampfbegriff war in der Corona-Zeit,
das ist ganz interessant,
das ist jetzt wirklich sehr on the fly oder sehr roh dieser Gedanke,
aber da war das natürlich ein täglicher Kampf um Freiheit und auch um die Definition von Freiheit.
Was ist wichtiger, die Freiheit des Einzelnen machen zu können,
was er möchte oder die Freiheit desjenigen, der gesundheitlich mehr Risiken
eingeht, weiter leben zu dürfen?
Und wie weit muss derjenige, der gerne wieder ohne Mundschutz durch den Edeka
laufen möchte, sich einschränken für diejenigen, die, keine Ahnung,
immungeschwächt sind und deswegen ohne Maske gar nirgendwo mehr hingehen sollten?
Und gerade was Hendrik Streeck anging, der nun wirklich sicherlich Verdienste
hat in der HIV-Forschung, aber ansonsten vom Thema Coronavirus ungefähr genauso
viel verstanden hat wie Markus Lanz.
Dem ich natürlich kein Unwissen unterstellen möchte,
auf gar keinen Fall, wer bin ich, das zu tun als dummer Clown,
aber der dann eben seine Argumente vorher immer durch so eine politische Mühle
gedrückt hat und das war leider bei Hendrik Streeck sehr deutlich sichtbar und
die, ähm, die, ähm, Ich sag mal, die persönliche Motivation von Alexander Kekuli,
auch die blubberte zwischen den Zeilen raus und das ist mir einfach aufgestoßen
und ich finde das, klar, das war vielleicht ein bisschen mit einem dicken Filzstift
auf einer weißen Wand gemalt, aber.
Was für ein Gestammel.
Ja, es ist immer erstaunlich, wenn Leute keinen Teleprompter haben,
von dem sie ihre Pointen ablesen, dann müssen sie nämlich selbst formulieren.
Er leitet doch die Redaktion, die sich nun wirklich nur darum kümmert,
dass irgendwer so eine kleine Privatmeinung, die man als Anlass für so eine
Sendung mal hat, dann hochjetzt zu irgendwas.
Jetzt kann er doch nicht den anderen unterstellen, Kekulé und so,
dass sie während Corona ja vor allem ihre eigene Meinung zu irgendetwas durchgibt.
Ja, und dass sie sich profilieren wollten. Ja, alle wollen sich profilieren,
die in den Medien auftreten mit irgendetwas.
Aber dafür ist er doch der Typ dafür.
Ja, er profiliert sich, alle profilieren sich.
Lauterbach ist durch Talkshow-Auftritte und Tweets zum Gesundheitsminister geworden.
Christian Trosten ist jemand, der sich nicht in der Weise profiliert,
wie jetzt ein strekter Start mit Sachbuch und Auftritte mit Frauke Ludewig.
Aber natürlich ist für Drosten diese Art zu sprechen, als der Berater aufzutreten,
einen wöchentlichen Podcast zu machen, auch einen Wunsch nach Profilierung grundiert.
Also die machen das ja nicht alles nur Gott zu Ehre, womit ich den nicht unterstellen
will, die machen das einfach nur um in den Medien zu kommen.
Trosten würde ich da ein bisschen rausnehmen.
Dass wir jetzt hier das Jahre später hören und wir auch jetzt gerade auch erkennen,
wo Maßnahmen zu weit gegangen sind oder wo auch das einfach nicht haltbar war mit,
ja es geht hier einfach nur darum, dass da Leute ihre absurden Freiheitsideale
austoben wollen, Sondern wo es tatsächlich auch darum ging, dass Leute in ihrer
Freiheit so eingeschritten waren, dass sie depressiv geworden sind etc.
Dass sie in der Schule total versagt haben, weil sie dann nicht mitkamen bei
einem Unterricht, der nur über Bildschirme stattfindet.
All das hätte man jetzt mal ansprechen können und nein, eigentlich ist man sich
keiner Schuld bewusst und stammelt darum und erzählt nochmal,
dass eigentlich alles korrekt war.
Drosten würde ich jetzt dadurch, dass wir immer mal in Clips gehört haben,
nochmal als wirklich besonderen Fall, weil selten hat sich jemand qua eigener
Entscheidung so gegen Prominenz entschieden wie Drosten.
Das schon.
Pandemie war vorbei und er einfach, ich bin weg, ihr müsst mich vorladen.
Und jetzt hat er ja die ein oder andere Vorladung bekommen, weil irgend so ein
Freak irgendwelche Anklagen hat.
Also sitzt Drosten nochmal vor Gericht und muss dann sagen, ja,
ich bin wirklich ein Doktor, ich habe promoviert.
Mit so einem Kiki-Fax sich da rumschlagen. In der Hinsicht würde ich ihn da rausnehmen.
Aber das Böhmermann, Böhmermann, es ist so ein bisschen, es gibt diesen niederländischen
Spruch, ich wollte den schon immer nochmal nachfragen, ich muss Chibiti nochmal fragen, wie der heißt.
Was du über andere sagst, bist du vor allem selber.
Das gilt hier für Böhmermann insbesondere.
Er kritisiert an anderen das, was er selbst, worunter er wahrscheinlich selbst
leidet, weil das diese Art von Defiziten sind, von sich selber,
die er hochchesseln musste, um seinen Lebenstraum großer Showmaster beim CDF zu werden.
So, da kommt diese Geltungssucht dazu, über die Stränge zu schlagen,
also jenseits des Zauns zu grasen oder wie das heißt, zu irgendwelchen Themen
sich zu äußern, von denen man keine Ahnung hat.
Mein Böhmermann macht jede Sendung zu irgendwelchen Themen, zu denen er keine
Ahnung hat, nach seinen eigenen Kriterien.
Was weiß ich, was er ist.
So, in der Hinsicht, na gut, also Böhmermann, Böhmermann, da wir es jetzt kurz
angesprochen haben, Böhmermann ist gerade im Rechtsstreit mit so einem komischen
Inker, Das würde ich nachlesen für alle, die sich dafür interessieren.
Ich glaube, da wird wirklich deutlich, was Böhmermann wirklich für ein Mensch ist.
Okay, das habe ich gar nicht verfolgt.
In dieser Geschichte. Also nur kurz zusammengefasst. Böhmermann hat sich lustig
gemacht über irgendwelche Leute und da war unter anderem ein Inka dabei.
Er hat sein, also das Gesicht des Inkas genutzt, um sich darüber lustig zu machen,
dass da irgendwie, keine Ahnung, ich weiß jetzt nicht genau.
Worum es geht. Wie Honig, ob der ökologisch ist oder sowas.
Er hat wieder so eine Pointe gemacht, die sind ja alle blöd,
hier an diesem Imker sieht man es.
Also hat der Imker sich gedacht, naja, wenn der mich in seiner Sendung benutzt,
als Bild, benutze ich einfach ihn.
Und dann hat der Böhmermann als Gesichtswerbeplattform benutzt und Böhmermann
hat sich dagegen gewehrt. hat dann vor Gericht verloren, damit war es eigentlich
klar, nur Böhmermann hatte halt die juristische Kriegskasse und sagt,
dann gehe ich halt in die nächste Runde.
Was für den Imker bedeutet, ja gut, dann wird eben jetzt noch nicht aufgelöst,
wer wem welches Geld bezahlen muss, ich bin weiter in den Miesen,
das kostet mich weiterhin Geld und Böhmermann versucht ihn jetzt wirklich einfach,
und das ist wirklich wie bei Steffen Mau auf der bewusst falschen Arena fertig zu machen.
Er nutzt die juristische Arena um ihn ökonomisch fertig zu machen.
So, und wenn er selbst Widerstand von Stefan Niggemeier da nochmal einen Text
darüber schreibt und dass er das überhaupt nicht versteht und dass es wirklich
daneben ist und es trotzdem durchzuziehen, das zeigt, was, glaube ich,
wirklich für elementar ist.
Ein Mensch hinter der öffentlichen Figur Böhmermann steckt.
Geht es da etwa um Profilierung?
Es ist ganz gruselig, womit wir es hier zu tun haben, ehrlich gesagt.
Wir gehen zurück zu Taurus und der Debatte.
Also wir haben jetzt Norbert Röttgen gehört mit seinen Anschuldigungen. Jetzt müssen wir,
vernehmen, dass Olaf Scholz jetzt nicht einfach sagt, ja Norbert,
richtig, sondern wir hören jetzt nochmal, Scholz versucht seine Position zu erklären.
Das gehört zu dem, worauf ich vorhin schon angespielt habe. Mit Halbwahrheiten
wird öffentliche Kommunikation betrieben. Ich habe Sie ja zitiert.
Und deshalb will ich sehr konkret sein. Nein, durch die Lieferung der Waffen
wird man nicht kriegsbeteiligter.
Niemand hat das gesagt, ich nicht und auch sonst keiner, den ich im verantwortlichen
Umfeld der Bundesregierung kenne.
Aber Sie haben einen Satz von mir zitiert und darauf will ich gern noch einmal rekurrieren.
Und so wie das in Frankreich und Großbritannien gemacht wird,
geht das für uns nicht. Und den wiederhole ich nochmal.
Also das geht nicht. Warum geht das nicht?
Naja, wir wissen, dass Biden und Scholz in einem sehr engen Austausch stehen.
Die sind sehr stark bei der Orchestrierung des Ganzen involviert.
Das scheint wohl auch zwischenmenschlich, was man so vernehmen kann,
gut zu funktionieren. Glauben wir das einmal?
Hoffen wir es einfach mal.
Dass Biden noch Freunde hat. Und ich könnte mir aber vorstellen,
dass man sich ja in einer Sache sehr einig ist und das hat auch Biden ja immer wieder bekräftigt.
Man will eine Eskalation dieses Krieges auf jeden Fall verhindern und das sehen beide so.
Wir sind aber bei diesen Telefonaten nicht dabei.
Wenn man jetzt sagen würde, ja, aber Demokratie muss transparent sein,
dann könnte man sagen, ja, warum sind wir dann eigentlich nicht dabei?
Na, wir können nicht dabei sein, weil dann Putin auch dabei wäre.
Und wir sehen ja gerade, wenn sich da ein paar Generäle treffen bei Zoom,
dann ist auch schon Halligalli, die sich da ein bisschen locker austauschen.
Also man kann sich gar nicht ausdenken, was wäre, wenn man jetzt so ein Telefonat
zwischen Biden und Scholz gelegt hätte.
Scholz kann aber jetzt, obwohl er da öffentlich zur Schnecke gemacht wird von
Röttgen, sich natürlich nicht dahingehend äußern, dass er sagt,
ja also weißt du, ich habe jetzt mit Joe Biden gestern nochmal telefoniert.
Folgendes.
Das kann er nicht sagen und er versucht ihm das jetzt nochmal zu erklären,
soweit er es überhaupt kann in seiner Rolle als Bundeskanzler und als derjenige,
der auch Träger von Geheimnissen ist.
Also man muss sich das klar machen, wir werden in Deutschland regiert und wissen
nicht alles, wie man uns regiert.
Also das muss man einfach akzeptieren, das ist so.
Man kann dann sagen, wir brauchen Demokratie und Transparenz und kann das versuchen,
so wie die Piratenpartei sich das gedacht hat.
Ich würde sagen, bei kleinen Dingen kann man das machen, also wenn es jetzt
um Bürgergelderhöhungen geht und man würde da alles filmen, was an Gesprächen
stattfindet, möglicherweise,
aber gerade da, wo es um die Souveränität von Ländern geht, wo es um Krieg und
Frieden geht, wird man um das Geheimnis nicht herumkommen.
Wer das gerne mal ganz anschaulich sehen will, James Bond, Skyfall, da erklärt M.
Judi Dench das nochmal ganz genau, dass man das Geheimnis braucht.
Und hier können wir auch sagen, wir sind hier in einem Ausnahmezustand.
Wir wissen von Carl Schmitt, die Regel besagt nichts, die Ausnahme sagt alles.
Ja, und souverän bedeutet hier, Träger des Geheimnisses zu sein und aufgrund
dessen eine Entscheidung zu treffen, die man nicht öffentlich kommunizieren
kann. Und jetzt geht das ja sogar noch weiter.
Und was mich aber ärgert ist, sehr geehrter Abgeordneter, lieber Norbert.
Dass du alles weißt und eine öffentliche Kommunikation betreibst,
die darauf baut, dass dein Wissen kein öffentliches Wissen ist.
Ich glaube, das sollte in der Demokratie nicht der Fall sein.
Lieber Herr Abgeordneter, lieber Norbert, wie auch immer. Das sind ja die eigentlich
in der Schriftverkehr deutlichen Markierungen. Hier geht es zu weit oder so.
Dass man das in der Sprache, in der gesprochenen Sprache mal verwendet.
Fast so amüsanten Charakter, finde ich.
Ja, und der Vorwurf ist hier, Norbert Röttgen, weil er im Verteidigungsausschuss
sitzt und weil er sicherlich am dichtesten von der Opposition her dran ist an
dem, was da verhandelt wird,
Krieg und Frieden, weiß natürlich Dinge,
die er auch nicht mitteilen kann der Öffentlichkeit.
Weiß aber, dass er Scholz vorführen kann, weil Scholz ja nicht sagen kann,
aber ich habe doch gestern mit beiden telefoniert, wir können Taurus nicht liefern.
Und das ist tatsächlich ein sehr falsches Spiel und dass man dann als Opposition.
Man muss aber sagen, der Satz ist irgendwie so kompliziert. Also man versteht ihn nicht.
Wir hören nochmal weiter, es wird jetzt vielleicht nochmal klar,
wenn Scholz nachher nochmal so eine Replik gibt, denn was ich wirklich schlimm
finde ist, es geht hier ja tatsächlich um etwas ganz Existenzielles,
also schlittern wir in den dritten Weltkrieg oder nicht und dass die Union so
fahrlässig ist und zum Teil dann auch Leute aus der eigenen Partei beziehungsweise
von den Grünen oder der FDP ist für mich kaum auszuhalten,
weil ich denke, wie verantwortungslos kann man sein.
Und jetzt gibt es hier eine Ausnahme im Bundestag.
Also, da muss ich auch jetzt mal zu sagen können. Also, was ich weiß und nicht wissen kann.
Ich erlaube jetzt ausnahmsweise, das darf ich, weil ich hier die Sitzungsleitung habe.
Ganz kurz dürfen Sie reagieren.
Bärbel Bass hat gesprochen, ganz kurz soll er reagieren, wird dann ein bisschen länger.
Kurz. Ja, ich weise diese Unterstellung, ich würde irgendetwas wissen,
ich weiß gar nicht, wer mir dieses Wissen geben sollte und würde das der Öffentlichkeit vorenthalten.
Ich habe den gleichen Vorwurf gegen Sie, Herr Bundeskanzler.
Wer soll ihm das Wissen geben? Nun, er ist in diesen Ausschüssen drin.
Dass Sie Ihre wahren Motive für Ihre Politik nicht erläutern,
dass Sie immer neue Ausreden finden, die sich zum Teil wechselseitig widersprechen und ausschließen.
Und schon daraus, nachdem Sie ein Dreivierteljahr in dieser Frage geschwiegen
haben, an der Parlamentsdebatte zu dieser Frage nicht teilgenommen und sich nicht erklärt haben.
Und nun heute schon wieder in
ihrer Antwort wirklich widersprüchlich sich geäußert haben. Herr Röttgen.
Letzte Bemerkung. Sie haben klar erklärt, dass es wegen der deutschen Beteiligung
an diesem Waffensystem zu einer Kriegsbeteiligung kommen würde und dass Sie es darum ablehnen.
Und Frankreich und Großbritannien machen das Gleiche und Sie bestreiten,
das ist ein erheblicher Unterschied.
Darum sagen Sie hier nicht, ich muss diesen Vorwurf erheben,
Sie spielen nicht mit klaren Karten und sie zielen darauf ab,
die Öffentlichkeit in dieser Frage zu täuschen.
In einer Frage der europäischen und nationalen Sicherheit.
Sie haben das Wort. Es ist nicht richtig und deshalb wiederhole ich nochmal.
Das ist ja interessant, wo kommen denn die klaren Karten her?
Das ist ja semantisch total bescheuert. Man spielt ja Karten, um sie nicht zu zeigen.
Ja.
Das ist ja, wieso macht denn das? Ich finde außerdem, diese Entscheidung,
ob wir Taurus liefern oder nicht, sind wie so viele Entscheidungen nicht nur
nicht für uns transparent, sondern sie sind auch mit Absicht nicht demokratisch.
Der Bundestag entscheidet nicht darüber, dass die CDU überhaupt auf den Gedanken
kommt, hier so eine Art Schauprozess im Sinne einer Abstimmung zu machen.
Eine namentliche Abstimmung zu diesem Thema ist eigentlich, wie ich finde, auch nochmal,
ich will jetzt nicht sagen, das ist irgendwie verfassungswidrig,
aber das Verfassungsgefüge sieht es mit Absicht und mit Argumentation anders
vor. Und das wird hier unterlaufen.
Und da finde ich es völlig zu Recht, dass man einfach, und so verstehe ich jetzt,
nachdem ich ein paar Wochen ja jetzt auch diesen O-Ton immer mal wieder,
ich habe ihn auch mit Mick besprochen und so, Scholz macht Röttgen den Vorwurf,
du nimmst eine Position ein,
die du nur dir erlauben kannst, weil du in der Verantwortungslosigkeit der Opposition bist.
Wenn Agnes Strack-Zimmermann Verteidigungsministerin wäre, würde sie auch anders
entscheiden und so weiter.
Und du machst es noch wieder besser aus Wissen.
Und du weißt, warum die Regierung ihrer Verantwortung nachkommt.
Und vielleicht hätte man das als Ausschau noch deutlicher sagen sollen.
Ja, ich glaube, das sind schon Grenzen, wo das Geheimnis zu enthüllen geht auch nicht.
Nur wir sind ja jetzt auch keine großen Propheten, um das sagen zu können,
sondern man denkt einfach zweimal drüber nach und versteht es dann.
Warum haben wir im Journalismus eine völlig andere Debatte?
Also ich finde es ja doch so interessant, dass man sich so sehr von den Strackzimmermanns
und Röttgens die Themen diktieren lässt,
nicht nur, sondern die Denkweise übernimmt und nicht mal fragt,
ja aber wer hat welche Interessen und man kann doch mal ganz kurz Demokratie
theoretisch nachdenken.
Was kann man sagen, wo endet die Transparenz? Wo ist man besser als Bürger nicht dabei?
Im Sinne von, naja, das Geheimnis muss gewahrt sein, weil wir sonst auch weder
Diplomatie noch Strategie haben können.
Meine Hoffnung ist ja, dass wir, wenn wir im Mai das Geopolitikbuch von Brecht
bekommen, dort diese...
Abstrahierte Ebene stattfindet in der Erörterung.
So wäre ja mit Wälzer auch. Dass wir also nicht nur über Geopolitik auf dem
Boden, und dann kriegen wir nochmal so eine Scholaturaufarbeitung,
was im Zusammenhang steht, sondern dass wir nochmal die Geopolitik in den Köpfen,
auch angefangen, warum ist sie überhaupt so attraktiv, darüber nachzudenken.
Geopolitik lädt ja richtig ein zur Fanfiction, weil keiner irgendwas konkretisieren muss.
Man redet einfach von dem Öl, dem Nahen Osten, den Russen und dann hat man so
fünf Variablen und spielt sozusagen Eidel in meiner Dingsda-Bums, ja und.
Das ist wie bei den Anhängern von Alexander Dugin in Russland,
die haben ja auch den Begriff Geopolitik in jeder zweiten Zeile und die versuchen,
ergehen sich auch ständig in Fanfiction mit dem Westen und was wird er tun und
machen. Also ich hoffe, er hat recht.
Liefert.
Ich hoffe auch und ich will mal hier eine Umfrage noch zitieren vom 7.
März Lieferung von Taurus Marsch Flugkörpern ja oder nein, werden die Deutschen gefragt.
Und wir haben jetzt medial einen unglaublichen Shitstorm erlebt gegen Scholz.
Also auch wer so in den Talkshows eingeladen war, es ist ja immer das Prinzip,
einer darf die Scholz-Mützenlicht-Position vertreten und alle anderen kloppen drauf.
Und trotzdem sind nur 29% dafür und 61% dagegen. Gegen.
Womit hängt das zusammen? Vermutlich zum einen, dass die Menschen Olaf Scholz
sehen im Fernsehen, im Radio hören und sagen, das ist unser Mann.
Ich glaube aber auch, es hängt sehr stark damit zusammen,
dass die sozialen Medien nicht, wie einige Journalisten jetzt behaupten,
tot sind, sondern dass die Leute sich über die sozialen Medien dann doch nochmal
anders informieren und nicht nur an der Wille gucken. Ja.
Wir bräuchten auch wirklich nochmal eine Aufarbeitung der medialen Geopolitik.
Wie funktioniert dieses mediale Geschäft eigentlich?
Mein Buch ist jetzt auch schon wieder 2016, kam das acht Jahre her.
Und ich finde ja, die Journalisten in ihren Ämtern haben heute noch nicht verstanden,
dass das, was sie in ihrem Twitter lesen und auf ihren Abendveranstaltungen besprechen,
nicht die TikTok, Facebook, Instagram Realität ist, mit der sie es zu tun Wenn
sie Publikum suchen, wenn sie an eine politisch laufende Debatte,
nämlich die der anderen anschließen wollen, die verdrehen sich so in ihren eigenen
Sachen und das verstehe ich irgendwie nicht.
Also anscheinend muss man denen jedes Jahr wieder so ein Buch hinlegen,
damit sie dann nach zehn Jahren mal ärgern, jetzt nehme ich das mal ernst. Ja.
Also es scheint totale Lernunwille zu sein bei diesen strukturellen Fragen,
während man gleichzeitig inhaltlich sich total verkämpft in allem möglichen.
Also das ist ja Taurus wirklich nur Chiffre für alles mögliche.
Ja, wir gehen jetzt ein bisschen schnell durch die Rede. Ein letztes Wort von Scholz.
Aus meiner Sicht ist das eine sehr weitreichende Waffe.
Diese Waffe könnte angesichts der Bedeutung, dass man die Kontrolle über die
Ziele nicht verlieren darf, nicht ohne den Einsatz deutscher Soldaten eingesetzt
werden, das lehne ich ab.
Und hier spricht doch der Kanzler mal Klartext, das wollen doch immer alle.
Und vor allem, ich verstehe das auch. Also nicht nur, weil es meine Meinung
ist, sondern ich kann es auch nachvollziehen.
Wir haben da diesen riesigen Computer, den müssen wir da hinliefern.
Dann könnten die aber damit machen, was sie wollen. Das wollen wir nicht.
Also müssen da auch deutsche Soldaten hin. Das wollen wir nicht.
Das ist eins plus eins ist da einfach zwei.
Wir hören Mützenich.
In keinem anderen europäischen Land, geschweige denn außerhalb Europas,
wird über ein einzelnes Waffensystem so gestritten wie in Deutschland.
Auf diese Debatte brauchen wir uns nicht einzubilden, auch weil eigennützige
und niedere politische Beweggründe den Streit leider anheizen, meine Damen und Herren.
Vergessen wird auch, wie sehr Deutschland sich ja engagiert.
Es ist ja zum Teil, wenn kein Taurus geliefert wird, hat man den Eindruck,
Deutschland hat sich total zurückgezogen, macht nichts.
Wo leben sie eigentlich? Deutschland
ist das Land, was hinter den USA am meisten für die Ukraine tut.
Gut, 28 Milliarden Euro in den letzten zwei Jahren und da geht es eben in der
Tat, Herr Kollege Badefuhl, nicht allein um militärische Güter.
Und Mützenich gibt auch zu bedenken, wie blicken denn die anderen Länder,
die nicht europäisch sind, auf diesen Krieg?
Brauchen wir auch nicht eine kluge Debatte darüber,
wie wir die Länder, die den Krieg in der Ukraine anders deuten oder instrumentalisieren,
mehr für das Ziel eines Kriegsendes aktivieren.
Leider, und das müssen wir doch sagen, außerhalb Europas haben viele Länder einen anderen Blick.
Auf diesen Krieg.
Ja, was machen wir eigentlich damit? Also ich kann den beschimpfen,
ich kann sagen, ihr seid Verschwörungstheoretiker, ihr fallt auf Putin-Narrative
ein, ich kann die alle verdammen.
Und das ist ja auch dann passiert, kann total eskalieren angesichts der Äußerungen des Papstes.
Ich finde diese Papst-Äußerung auch für falsch und man kann nicht sagen,
die sollen die weiße Fahne hissen, um da keine Missverständnisse aufkommen zu lassen.
Ich gebe aber zu bedenken, das vergessen ja vor allem deutsche Katholiken häufig,
dass der Papst der Vertreter einer Weltkirche ist und nicht der Papst von katholischen Deutschen.
Er ist nicht der Bürgermeister von Rom.
Ja, und er ist auch nicht, also das war damals, als Franziskus es wurde,
war dann so direkt aus der Bischofskonferenz, wir freuen uns,
er hat ja auch in Deutschland mal studiert, er ist ein Papst mit deutscher Zunge,
völliger Unsinn natürlich, er hat über eine Milliarde Katholiken,
die er nicht regiert, aber an die er sich wenden kann Und für die macht er diese
Äußerungen und er denkt nicht über die 24 oder 27 Millionen Katholiken in Deutschland dabei nach.
Und das hat auch im Übrigen Benedikt XVI. nicht getan, wo dann auch immer große
Verwirrung war, wie kann denn das sein.
Nein, und ich muss das ja erst einmal zur Kenntnis nehmen, ich muss es gar nicht
gutheißen und würde auch nicht alles, was aus dem globalen Süden in Bezug auf
Ukraine kommt, gutheißen, nur ich muss mich ja irgendwie dazu verhalten,
weil ich nicht mit dem Kopf durch die Wand gehen kann.
Und ich würde auch, wir haben das heute nicht als großes Thema da sagen,
was gerade in Gaza passiert und wie die Bundesregierung wegschaut, wie das so weit geht,
dass die Opposition in Form von Julia Klöckner dort auftritt und sagt,
hier ist ein LKW, ich gucke da auch mal rein, mache ein paar schöne Fotos,
die Hilfslieferungen klappen ganz wunderbar, den Leuten könnte es eigentlich gut gehen in Gaza.
Wenn man das mitbekommt, dann kann man davon ausgehen, dass das im nicht westlichen
Ausland gesehen wird und die werden dann sagen, wovon redet ihr denn eigentlich?
Guckt doch da, da erleben wir einen Krieg gegen Zivilisten.
Und das muss man doch erkennen,
dass man sich damit extrem unglaubwürdig macht und dass man,
wenn man auf Dauer noch irgendwie mit anderen zusammenarbeiten will,
denn wir werden ja nicht gegen alle Krieg führen können.
Also so viel Taurus-Lieferung in alle Richtungen geht ja dann nicht.
Dann muss man überlegen, wie geht man damit um und deswegen finde ich diesen
Hinweis, auch wenn er uns jetzt keine Erklärung liefert, wie zunächst einmal
richtig, aber die anderen blenden es ja völlig aus.
Ja, Annalena Baerbock ist angetreten als feministische Außenpolitikerin und
endet damit wahrscheinlich, dass sie den globalen Süden komplett verloren haben.
Und zwar nicht nur in einer Frage, sondern dann tatsächlich einfach in allen.
Wir sind da kein guter Ansprechpartner mehr für irgendwen, irgendwo auf der Welt.
Ja, in der Koalition ist es nicht angenehm, Mützenich sagt.
Auch manches Maß in der Koalition ist nicht mehr dort und ich finde,
dass dem kein Einhalt geboten worden ist, ist ein Armutszeugnis.
Wenn der Regierungschef der Bundeskanzler mit Begriffen wie Sicherheitsrisiko
oder Unwahrheit belegt wird, dann ist das nicht nur unredlich,
sondern ich sage es sehr deutlich, auch bösartig.
Worum ging es also eigentlich? Wir haben jetzt bei Scholz gemerkt,
der kann jetzt vieles nicht sagen,
Mützenich kann aber mehr sagen, ohne auf dieses Wissen Bezug zu nehmen,
aber er kann jetzt so sagen,
naja, guck doch mal so vor ein paar Monaten, wie das sich so alles entwickelt
hatte und kann damit natürlich deutlich machen und ihr wisst ja jetzt,
könnte es auch gerade im Hintergrund sowas geben.
Um es noch mal etwas deutlicher zu sagen, damit auch Sie von der Opposition,
der Wadephul und vielleicht der ein oder andere verstehen, um was es eigentlich überhaupt geht.
Im Oktober 2022 befürchtete die amerikanische Regierung den Einsatz taktischer
Atomwaffen im Krieg in der Ukraine.
Also, selbst wenn man,
und da finde ich auch, sehr viele Argumentationen, die aus Russland so kommen,
sind natürlich auf dieses, wie Heinz Bude dann beschreibt, etwas hyperaktive
deutsche Publikum gemünzt, nur es sind ja trotzdem Atome.
Ja.
Und wir wissen ja trotzdem nicht genau, welche gibt es da, wie kann man die
vielleicht auch so einsetzen.
Und auch diese große Angst, angenommen, Putin wirft jetzt wirklich eine und
wir haben sie vorher so verteufelt.
Also wir haben Nolens Film nochmal und der ganze Kram. Und dann stellen wir
fest, achso, der Radius ist doch nur 50 Kilometer.
Dass wir plötzlich so eine Hypernormalisierung haben.
Ja, wir haben ja eine Normalisierung dahingehend, dass wir sagen,
ja, es sterben dann der Ukraine so 100.000, 200.000, 300.000 Männer.
Dass man dann sagt, ja, ist ja gar nicht so schlimm. Ja.
Also es ist überschaubar, das nukleare Material fällt zu Boden,
wir haben den kontaminierten Bereich eingegrenzt.
Okay, aber nicht nochmal bitte.
Also dass dann wirklich diese Kettenreaktionen.
Also wir haben alle den Nolens-Film gesehen, die Pointe ist die Kettenreaktion
und zwar die politisch in den Köpfen, Atomwaffen sind jetzt da,
dass man sie dann nicht nur als Arsenal, sondern wirklich als Argumentation im Krieg einfach hat.
Ja, also diese kleinen Nuklearwaffen sind ja genau auf so einen begrenzten,
also nicht 50 Kilometer, aber ein kleinerer Radius da rein.
Also es geht ja schon darum, dass man weiterhin Kriege führen will und jetzt
den letzten Tag das jüngste Gericht mit Atomwaffen hervorzurufen, das ist das eine,
das ist die totale Eskalation, aber wir sehen ja jetzt gerade, dass obwohl…,
hier Atommächte involviert sind, wenn auch die Ukraine nicht selbst Atomwaffen
hat, aber sie ist nun alliiert in gewisser Weise mit den NATO-Staaten,
hat man trotzdem einen Krieg.
Und man wird also immer mehr jetzt erleben, wir haben ständig Kriege und diese
absolute Bedrohung ist da, aber man kann die natürlich auch nochmal abschwächen dadurch,
dass man sagt, ja, das macht mal so eine mittelgroße Stadt kaputt und das Leben
ist dann dann nicht mehr möglich.
Aber das ist noch nicht die absolute Eskalation. Es ist nicht die Zarbombe.
Sondern es ist eben...
Und das ist die ganz große Gefahr und das bringt so viel Leid und Opfer mit
sich und ist dann eine Kettenreaktion in gewisser Weise natürlich,
die dann nicht so ganz schlagartig geschieht, also dass dann die eine Atombombe
fällt und dann kommt gleich die ganz große und dann ist alles platt,
sondern das kann sich natürlich dann immer weiter weiter hochschaukeln und hier nochmal Mütze nicht.
Wir können dankbar sein, dass im Weißen Haus ein amerikanischer Präsident sitzt,
der alle, glaube ich, notwendigen Signale gegeben hat an eben Moskau,
dass es nicht zu dieser Gefahr gibt, als viele Zehntausende von russischen Soldaten
zurückgedrängt worden waren,
eingeschlossen und möglicherweise auch gefährdet waren, dass diese taktische
Atomwampfe nicht zum Einsatz gekommen ist. Aber das hat nicht gereicht.
Ja, und dann bezieht er sich auf die Reise nach China von Scholz und das war
mir gar nicht in dem Sinne mehr bewusst.
Es bedurfte eines Wortes und das ist ja die Änderung der internationalen Ordnung.
Aus Peking, des chinesischen Regierungs- und Parteichefs, der das nukleare Tabu
nochmal bekräftigt hat.
Und wer war an seiner Seite, als dieses nukleare Tabu bekräftigt wurde,
um diesen Einsatz zurückzuhalten, einer taktischen Atomwaffe?
Es war der Bundeskanzler, der gegen ihren Willen nach China gereist ist und
dieses Gespräch gesucht hat.
Und leider gab es auch Zurückhaltung in der Regierung.
Ja, daran kann ich mich allerdings noch erinnern, dass das dann auch so strakt
Zimmermann, so Leute fanden das natürlich dann, warum muss der jetzt nach China
und das sind doch eher unsere Rivalen nun.
Also diese Reise, keine Ahnung, ob man die jetzt so vereinnahmen muss von Seiten
der SPD, dass sie die ausschlaggebende Funktion hatte in China.
Da sind wir wieder in der Sphäre des Nichtsbekannten.
Nein, keine Atomwaffen, macht was ihr wollt, aber keine Atomwaffen.
Na, wir wissen nicht, welche Gespräche im Hintergrund stattfinden.
Wir können ja eigentlich nur hoffen, dass die ganze Zeit Gespräche im Hintergrund stattfinden.
Dass Scholz da ist und hier nochmal Putin anruft und sagt, hör mal,
wollten uns da nochmal einig sein.
Also darauf kann man ja nur hoffen. Also da ist man ausgeliefert,
wenn man so möchte. Vielleicht ist das auch so ein bisschen das,
warum jetzt gerade so aus dem journalistischen Feld man sehr diese Strack-Zimmermann-
und Röttgen-Position einnimmt.
Ist nicht Scholz jetzt wieder in China? Söder war doch da und hatte Panda-Fotos.
Toll.
Und hatte wohl auch einen Termin mit Xi oder so, ich weiß nicht genau.
Während jetzt Scholz oder Ahad Baerbock waren, aber nur mit der Regierungs-,
nicht mit der präsidialen Ebene.
Ah, okay.
Kontakt, irgendwie so.
Naja, jedenfalls kann man doch daran ganz gut sehen,
dass wenn Journalisten sich so sehr gemein machen mit der Position von Röttgen
und Strack-Zimmermann, dann ist das ja eine Position, bei der man,
eine Handlungsmacht haben möchte. Man möchte eine Wirksamkeit haben.
Und wir erleben aber jetzt gerade in diesen Fragen Krieg und Frieden,
dass wir dem Wohl und Weh der Herrschenden ausgeliefert sind.
Wir können da jetzt nichts machen. Und in diese passive Haltung,
in die wir da hineingedrängt sind, die wollen wir eigentlich nicht akzeptieren.
Und deswegen sagen wir die ganze Zeit, wir können aber aktiv werden.
Jetzt muss aber Scholz mal. Scholz, mach mal und red mal mit uns.
Der handelnde Staat.
Bitte.
Genau das ist die Voraussetzung für den Umgang mit Taurus.
Der Bundeskanzler hat seine Gründe klar und unmissverständlich geäußert.
Es war an der Zeit, der Regierungschef, und das müssen Sie einfach mal akzeptieren,
hat alle Kenntnisse, alle Erfahrungen, alle notwendigen Informationen,
um abzuwägen und zu klaren Ergebnissen und auch Einsichten zu kommen.
Ja, und der Kanzler weiß dann auch noch mal mehr als Norbert Röttgen.
Und er hat alle Informationen.
Klarer kann man es dann nicht mehr sagen.
Aber was viel wichtiger ist, meine Damen und Herren, der Bundeskanzler trägt die Verantwortung.
Er hat hier im Deutschen Bundestag den Amtseid abgeleistet, dass er angemessen
handelt, aber nicht zum Schaden der Bundesrepublik Deutschland.
Und bitte akzeptieren Sie das und glauben Sie nicht denjenigen,
die in Talkshows meinen, sie wissen es besser und die da meinen,
sie müssten ihre neuen Bücher einfach anpreisen, die sie mal so schnell geschrieben haben.
Das ist nicht der Wert für eine angemessene, besonnene Diskussion in der internationalen Politik.
Ja, du zeigst uns aber nicht, wie sein Einfrieren spruch und so.
Ne, möchtest du den auch noch haben?
Nö, ich fand den nur amüsant. Es gab einen weiteren amüsanten, aber ich wundere mich.
Das wurde ja auch als so skandalös hingestellt. Also einfrieren meint ja,
du hast ja eben so von Ordnung schaffen gesprochen, also einfrieren können wir
ja sagen, bedeutet eigentlich,
wir wollen keine Eskalation,
aber es wird so sein, dass Russland da bleibt, wo es ist.
Putin wird vorläufig bleiben.
Ich würde ja sagen, der ist eigentlich eingefroren.
Ja nur noch auf Kosten von ganz ganz vielen Männern. Also das Ziel wäre dann
eines Einfrierens, dass man sagt,
das Sterben hört auf, aber die Konstellation bleibt ja so fragil wie sie ist,
aber diese Dauerfragilität ist dann schon wieder eine Art Stabilität,
denn Russland ist nicht zu besiegen.
Oder man kann sich das vornehmen, Russland zu besiegen, aber dann muss man damit
rechnen, dass wir einen dritten Weltkrieg haben.
Und das wollen die NATO-Staaten nicht, das wollen insbesondere Biden und Scholz auf keinen Fall.
Und deshalb ist dieses Einfrieren eine Möglichkeit, dass es dort für keinen so richtig weitergeht.
Das ist natürlich für die Ukrainer, die sich vielmehr erträumt haben,
eine sehr, sehr traurige Situation.
Situation, aber offenbar sind so die Fakten. Die größere Gefahr ist ja,
wir haben jetzt, betont er nochmal einen ganz tollen amerikanischen Präsidenten,
die große Gefahr ist ja, dass Trump nichts einfriert, sondern einfach mit Putin einen Deal macht,
der vermutlich dann nicht zugunsten der Ukrainer sein wird.
Also soziologisch ist es wahnsinnig interessant, dass man,
Bei diesem Einfrieren an so eine Art Erwartungsstabilisierung denkt,
von der wir normativ immer hoffen, ja das ist im Friedensfall so.
Und das ist aber einfach nicht so. So, das kann man zwar als sehr gut bewerten,
dass ein Frieden Erwartungen stabilisiert, im Sinne von, wenn jemand mir gegenüber
gewalttätig wird, gibt es einen großen Dritten, das Justizwesen,
dann wird der Täter als Täter identifiziert,
isoliert und spielt sozusagen gesellschaftlich keine Rolle mehr.
Entweder indem man ihm das Handlungsvermögen nimmt, Geldstrafe oder ihn sogar der Freiheit beraubt.
Nur auf kriegerischer Ebene ist das natürlich ein bisschen anders.
Putin bewegt sich weiterhin frei in Russland, soweit wir wissen.
Und Stabilität wird jetzt gerade dadurch garantiert, dass wir Russland auszehren.
Also wie wir es am Anfang betont haben.
Und das scheint mir ein sehr bedeutsames Muster zu sein, das,
finde ich, politisch und fötonistisch mal journalistisch begleitet werden sollte.
Aber gut, da wir bei Mütze nicht waren, ich gucke mal, ob es klappt.
Strack-Zimmermann hat eine Sitzung geleitet, in der diese Information,
über die die da gesprochen haben, später publik wurde.
Nämlich, dass es nur zwei dieser Steuerungskomputer für Taurus gibt,
die man dahin entsenden müsste und so weiter und so fort. Dass diese Sitzung
nicht geheim blieb, sondern publizistisch ausgeschlachtet wurde,
liegt daran, dass Strack-Zimmermann bei der Sitzungsleitung ein paar Fehler gemacht hat.
38 anwesende Mitglieder des Bundestags, die berechtigt sind,
in dieser Sitzung des Auswärtigen Ausschusses teilzunehmen, hatten insgesamt
pro Nase nochmal zwei Leute bei sich.
Also da sind über 100 Leute im Raum.
Und man weiß ja, wenn man Geheimnisse sich verhalten will, dann soll man es
eigentlich nur einem noch erzählen.
Und Mützenich hat es dann in der Pressekonferenz wie folgt abgehandelt.
Ich hoffe, das klappt jetzt, das hier abzuspielen.
Ja, doch immer stärker sehen, dass es einfach sehr sensible Informationen sind,
die da diskutiert werden und man da vielleicht nicht ausreichend geschützt ist
und deswegen vielleicht halt auch da die Risiken minimieren müsste.
Ja, ich bedauere sehr, dass aus einer geheimen Sitzung offensichtlich berichtet worden ist.
Ich habe gestern davon erfahren, dass eine Sitzung, an der 38 Abgeordnete teilgenommen haben,
insgesamt einschließlich dieser Abgeordneten dann 105 Teilnehmerinnen und Teilnehmer
bei dieser Sitzung gewesen sind.
Ich war etwas irritiert darüber gewesen,
weil ich schon gedacht hätte, dass die Vorsitzende in der Lage ist,
unabhängig von Zugangsberechtigungen, es schafft,
dass erst mal diese geheimen Informationen vorsorglich und auch sehr direkt
den Abgeordneten darüber informiert werden.
Und ich will schon sagen, dass nach meinem Dafürhalten Frau Strack-Zimmermann,
und sie hat ja nun wirklich einen überschaubaren kleinen Bereich,
wo sie ja ohnehin schon umstritten gewesen ist wegen ihres Ausschussvorsitzes,
auch diesmal es nicht geschafft.
Eine nicht nur geheime Sitzung so geheim zu halten, wie es erforderlich gewesen
wäre, insbesondere in diesem Moment.
Und ich finde, sie sollte sich schon fragen, warum ein Brief,
den sie an die Bundestagspräsidentin exklusiv geschrieben hat,
bevor er bei der Bundestagspräsidentin eingetroffen ist, auch schon einer interessierten
Öffentlichkeit zugänglich gemacht wurde.
Ich weiß nicht, wie die Postwege von Frau Strack-Zimmermann sind,
aber vielleicht gibt sie uns ja auch in Zukunft darüber Aufklärung,
solange sie zumindest noch hier ist.
Ja, da kann man eigentlich nichts weiteres noch zu sagen.
Das war politischer Mord. Also im Rahmen der deutschen Debattenkultur war das
10 von 10 Sterne, glaube ich. Das kriegt man. Mal gucken.
Mai oder so laufen die Wetten. Im Mai zerbricht die Ampel, sobald die Haushaltsdiskussionen
losgehen. Haushalt 2025.
Ich setze da Geld drauf, glaube ich.
Nein, ich wette natürlich nicht.
Aber ich glaube schon, dass es dies ja...
Nein, ich lasse mich ja von solchen Sachen nicht irritieren.
Nun gut. Wir haben eine Welt im Umbruch und zwar zum einen auf dem Felde,
es wird gekämpft, wir haben es besprochen, aber auch auf anderen Gebieten.
Wir steigen mal ein und verdeutlichen uns erst das anschließend mit einem kleinen
Exkurs, den wir nochmal machen.
Wir hören Kevin Roos und Casey Newton, die ihn ja nun im Hardfork-Podcast die
ganze Zeit schon begleiten, was uns auch interessiert, weshalb wir relativ häufig
Clips von denen spielen und sie markieren es auch deutlich.
Apple wird jetzt vom DOJ, also vom Department of Justice, richtig verklagt.
Die Lange Arme von John Law hat sich mit dem alten Tim Cook befasst, Kevin. Ja.
Okay, Casey, wir werden diesen Gesetzesantrag verbreiten und über all die Angelegenheiten
des DOJ sprechen. Aber erst mal, bist du überrascht?
Wussten wir, dass das kommt? We did.
In fact, it was just about a week ago that Bloomberg reported that the Department
of Justice had had a final meeting with Apple, giving Apple one last chance to plead its case.
And the reporting at the time suggested this is typically the last step before a lawsuit is filed.
So, yes, we did know this was coming. But what I would say is we didn't know
what the contents of the lawsuit would be. We didn't know what the allegations would be.
We didn't know what the supporting evidence would be. And now we have 88 pages of that to wade through.
So,
wir haben nicht genug Zeit, um auch die europäischen Auseinandersetzungen zu
begleiten. Apple musste ja...
Die auch heftig sind, ja.
Mega heftig. Also der Digital Markets Act ist ja jetzt in Full Swing, wie man so schön sagt.
Die zwei Jahre sind abgelaufen. Er gilt nun. Und eine Woche bevor es soweit
war, hat Apple also iOS geupdatet für die europäischen Nutzer.
Es gelten nur so ein paar Regeln. Man kann sich seinen Standardbrowser aussuchen.
Bei Google Maps zum Beispiel, also Google ist auch betroffen,
kann man nicht mehr einfach so durch einen Klick aus einer Google-Suche die Maps aufrufen.
Und das macht mich ja ehrlich gesagt schon wahnsinnig.
Ja, aber das eröffnet eben jetzt der Konkurrenz und so weiter.
Jetzt werden die Silos aufgebrochen.
Aber findest du es nicht so interessant, dass man als dummer Konsument und User,
der ich nun mal bin, es gerne einfach nur einfach hätte?
Genau. Und davon profitieren diese Konzerne, ich weiß, aber jetzt,
wenn ich gerade in der Straße irgendwas suche, mir was rausschreibe und dann
jedes Mal jetzt da rumklicken muss und denke, wo ist dieses verdammte Maps,
es regt mich schon wahnsinnig auf und da sieht man einfach diese Kluft,
das ist ja auch mit der DSGVO, dass man jedes Mal bei jeder neuen Seite,
die man anklickt, irgendwas bestätigen muss.
Da dagegen zu halten ist super easy. Also gegen deinen Vorwurf,
dass es ja jetzt nicht mehr einfach ist.
Denn das Ziel der Innovation ist,
ist ja der Brückenschlag, es noch einfacher zu machen.
Google Maps hat auch seine Probleme, die widersprechen sozusagen deiner Nutzungsgewohnheit.
Aber Google Maps hat durchaus Probleme, weil in Google Maps sind ganz schön
viele Funktionen, die ich mir wünsche, damit es einfacher wird,
nicht enthalten, weil sie gegen Googles Profitinteresse sind.
Ich würde mir zum Beispiel wünschen, so ein paar Anbieter und so weiter,
ich würde einfach mal gerne einen Briefkasten suchen oder sowas.
Das ist in Google Maps alles nicht drin. aus Gründen. Alle Entscheidungen,
wie Google Maps funktioniert, sind nach Profitinteresse von Google organisiert,
also muss das aufgebrochen werden.
Das heißt, ich habe mein, hier kann man es vielleicht wirklich mal sagen,
Mindset schon so sehr vergoogeln lassen, dass ich jetzt plötzlich merke,
ach, die Welt sieht anders aus.
Ja, und die Welt könnte auch anders gestaltet werden und uns noch sehr viel
einfacher sein, als wenn wir jetzt weiterhin dem,
zugegebenermaßen einen sehr feindlich strukturierten Verhaltenspfad,
den Google dir aufmacht, zu folgen.
Ja, es hat ja irgendwann den Eindruck, es ist etwas Intuitives,
was man dort so ausführt und das hat diese Idee, dass man das als alternativlos
wahrnimmt und jetzt bekomme ich diese Alternativen gesehen, muss plötzlich Entscheidungen treffen,
wo mir sie immer abgenommen wurde und ich werde also als Konsument direkt angesprochen,
muss mich also als aufgeklärtes das Subjekt nun verhalten und ich will eigentlich
Kind bleiben, wenn ich jetzt eine solche Kritik äußere.
Nur, und deswegen voller Anerkennung für deine Kritik, wir müssen jetzt durch
einen Tal der Tränen, denn TomTom oder die HierMaps oder was auch immer,
die sehen jetzt gerade erst, welche Lücken sich ergeben, wo man also rein innovieren könnte.
Gut. Es ist also jetzt eine Frage der Zeit.
So, die beiden sagen also, this is the big one.
In Europa lief das ja so, dass wir zuerst ganz transparent gesagt haben,
das ist der Digital Markets Act und dann dann haben sich die Apple-Juristen
einfach hingesetzt und haben mit den Technikern besprochen.
Okay, wir beuten das jetzt weitgehend in unsere Richtung aus und treten einfach
den Europäern richtig vor den Fuß.
Da gibt es sehr viele deutsche Podcasts, die das behandeln oder auch amerikanische,
aber vor allem die deutschen. Also,
Bits und so zum Beispiel, wo das so ein bisschen thematisiert wurde,
wie gemein eigentlich die Apple-Leute das Digital Markets Act Gesetz schlechtestmöglich
interpretiert haben, um da einfach nur zu zeigen, wir wollen weiter die Hausherren sein.
Das mal ausgeblendet, in Amerika haben wir jetzt gehört, gab es nicht vorher
ein großes neues Gesetz und dann konnte man sich daran orientieren,
sondern es gab einfach Gespräche zwischen dem Justizministerium und Apple,
weshalb dort auch, anders als bei uns, wo so, ja gut, dann wird jetzt auf juristischen
Feldern gekämpft, in Amerika ist es einfach der amerikanische Staat,
namentlich die Regierung,
das Weiße Haus, verklagt jetzt Apple.
So, man hatte Gespräche geführt, man hat sich aber nicht in die Karten schauen
lassen und jetzt liegt die 88-seitige Anklage vor und die wird jetzt durchgegangen.
Relativ viele Podcasts haben es natürlich behandelt, also nicht nur Hard Fork,
sondern auch der New York Times The Daily.
And they have brought a spate of these lawsuits. They sued Google for abusing
monopolies in online search and advertising technology.
They sued Meta, which owns Facebook, for allegedly stamping out nascent competition
when it bought Instagram and WhatsApp.
And the government sued Amazon for allegedly squeezing the third-party merchants that use its site.
And while the individual allegations in each one of these lawsuits varies,
Und letzte Woche hat die Justizdepartement eine dieser Verhandlungen gegen Apple gefeiert.
So, man weiß noch nicht genau, man hört jetzt hier auch aus so einem Podcast
auch in Länge nicht raus, was ist jetzt genau Sachstand so, sondern ja,
man bricht jetzt halt erstmal weltweite Traditionen des alltäglichen Verhaltens einfach mal auf,
um dann zu gucken, wo ergeben sich denn hier ökonomische Lücken und mit ökonomischen
Lücken ist ja immer das Nutzerinteresse gemeint, also irgendwelche Firmen werden
schon irgendwelche Ideen haben, die dir dann zeigen, ah ja, macht ja doch Sinn,
es mal anders zu machen als Google Maps und so weiter, aber so richtig wissen
sie auch nicht. Aber die Reichweite ist irgendwie groß.
Manche Sachen setzen sich auch durch. Wir haben ja schon hier über DeepL gesprochen.
Wir würden jetzt nicht als erstes zu Google Übersetzer gehen, wenn wir was brauchen.
Zum Beispiel, genau. DeepL ist ein sehr gutes Beispiel.
DeepL, dass OpenAI jetzt da so reingesprungen ist und Google wirklich vorführt,
weil Google Gemini nun echt einfach mal nicht so gut ist.
Muss man einfach sagen. Ich habe es jetzt beides im Abo. Und den Microsoft Co-Pilot,
der ist wirklich unter aller Sau.
Also OpenAI hat ja wirklich einen innovativen Schritt gemacht,
den sie einfach mit Hoheit über die Hälfte der GPUs weltweit oder so irgendwie
errungen haben, aber das ist wirklich der einzige Fall in 20 Jahren Silicon
Valley Geschichte, wo das mal so eine Rolle spielte.
Nun gut, diese ganze, also dass es jetzt gerade so parallel läuft,
dass in Europa auch der DMA nicht nur mit Apple konkret da, nach dem,
was sie schon in ihrer Software eingebaut haben, der wird ja auch nachjustiert,
sondern dass jetzt gerade auch wieder eine neue Klage läuft,
Europas gegen Apple, weil nicht alle Apps löschbar sind.
Also wo klar markiert wird, Betriebssystem zugestanden, aber die Apps,
die darauf laufen, müssen alle löschbar sein.
Es kommt nicht einfach mit, die Ford ist auf dem Homescreen schon mal und so
weiter, auf der 1 ist ARD und auf der 7 ist Pro7, sondern es muss jetzt alles löschbar sein.
Also eine klare Untertrennung zwischen Markt und Produkt, das man da anbietet.
Diese ganze Geschichte läuft jetzt parallel, Europa und Amerika.
Und in Amerika schon seit einer Weile, also in der Anklage, wird bis mehr als
zehn Jahre zurückgegangen, um einfach so einen Indizienkatalog zusammenzustellen.
Ja, dass jemand aus dem eigenen Betriebssystem Silo ausbricht und einfach Nutzungsverhalten
auf andere Plattformen mit rüber nimmt.
Also sozusagen nicht. Es gab damals ja, also zu dieser Zeit,
als ich es hier vor 14 Jahren, als das eine Rolle spielte, ich habe damals darüber
geschrieben, wie das Galaxy S3,
so von der Größe und von der Bildschirm, also der Bildschirm war von der Anmutung
genau, es war genau die Kopie des iPhone 3Gs und 3GS, was es damals gab.
Und ich habe dann über die Geräte als Prothese geschrieben, dass man nämlich
so ein Daumentraining hat, das einfach übertragbar ist auf das andere Gerät.
Man hat plötzlich das Samsung-Gerät in der Hand und kann dieselben Daumenbewegungen ausführen.
Und damals war dann Apple, hat dagegen geklagt und hat gesagt,
wir möchten hier unser Property verteidigen, unser Intellectual Property.
Und meine Pointe des Textes war dann, ja, aber das ist das das Intellectual Property in den Köpfen.
Also die Trainingserfolge in den Köpfen der Leute, dass man nämlich so ein Muscle
Memory aufbaut, was dann andere Firmen nutzen.
Apple hat da Anspruch auf diesen Muscle Memory in deinem Gehirn sozusagen.
Also auf der Ebene wird es ausgezeichnet.
Also man muss sich das so vorstellen, wenn jetzt Microsoft, die vor allem die
Personal Computer gemacht haben mit den Tastaturen, wenn die jetzt plötzlich
gesagt haben, sie haben sich jetzt an unsere Tastatur gewöhnt,
aber wenn jetzt andere auch eine Tastatur machen,
wo das W irgendwie links oben ist, dann müssen sie an uns was zahlen.
Man versucht das ja immer wieder durchzuboxen, aber diese Erfindung der Maus,
überhaupt die Erfindung der Tastatur.
Andere Computer dürfen nicht mit Tastaturen arbeiten. Da haben wir ein Patent
drauf, die müssen andere Eingabe formen. Wo man denkt, 10 Finger Schreibsystem
ist nun mal der Schreibmaschine entlehnt.
Das kann man nicht für sich einklagen.
Und die Firmen versuchen es aber trotzdem. Also es wird ja jeder Quatsch.
Und das waren eben auch die Abmaße. Welche Maße hat ein iPhone?
Wo sind welche Pixel wie zu verwenden? Also wo sind welche Apps platziert?
Das wird alles da reingeregelt.
Diese alte Anekdote, dass man vor 14 Jahren da sieht, die Leute nehmen einfach
diese eine App Und verlassen das Ökosystem und verhalten sich in einem anderen Gleich.
Das ist no fun to watch. Dagegen möchte man vorgehen, hat man ja dann auch.
Und dieses zieht sich bis heute Tim Cook auf der Bühne.
Dieser Spruch ist in der Anklage zitiert, in allen Werderen Podcasts rezitiert.
Zitiert. Hier beim Wall Street Journal hatten sie mal diesen Originalton von Tim Cook auf der Bühne.
Man versteht sofort, warum das DOJ heute sagt, so geht das nicht.
I don't hear our users asking that we put a lot of energy in on that at this point.
And so Da.
Geht es konkret um die Frage,
grüne Bubble und so weiter. Wir kommen darauf gleich zu sprechen.
Android-User finden sich stigmatisiert, weil sie eben keine Blue-Bubble und
reichhaltige Text-Kommunikation machen können, sondern nur SMS schicken.
Und sagt Tim Cook, nee, unsere User wollen gar nicht, dass die Android-User
nicht mehr erkennbar sind als das arme Vieh, das sich nur für 100 Euro...
Wir wollen so ein Elite-Markt bleiben.
Now, I would love to... I would love to convert you to iPhone.
It's just, it's tough. not to make it personal, but I can't send my mom certain
videos or she can't send me certain videos.
Buy your mom an iPhone.
So, buy your mom an iPhone. Das ist der Spruch, von dem das DOJ sagt,
nein, das ist die Quintessenz von allem, was wir nicht wollen.
Dass auf diese Art Marktmacht ausgenutzt wird.
Denn hier wird ja sozusagen das Kaufverhalten der Frau vorgegeben,
weil alle anderen schon schon kaufverhaltend gezeigt haben.
Also der berühmte Log-In-Effekt greift hier.
Der spielt dann auch eine sehr große Rolle.
Nun gut, Sie verhandeln jetzt im The Daily Podcast, nachdem Sie auch das minutenlang
besprechen und es nicht so richtig deutlich wird, wie weitreichend ist das jetzt,
um was geht es, in welche Richtung muss man jetzt hier denken.
Ich mache dann gleich ein eigenes Angebot, wie man das fassen kann.
Sie fragen sich selber, also in dem Fall den Korrespondenten,
was ist denn jetzt das Traum-Szenario des DOJ?
Was will man erwirken?
Und wir hören einfach nur so ein, wie ich finde, relativ ratloses Gestammel.
Ja, kluge Leute haben sich halt jetzt gedacht, das muss jetzt mal gemacht werden,
aber so richtig, wir kriegen es nicht vermittelt.
The things described in the lawsuit. Stop them from excluding certain types
of apps or making certain products less compatible with the iPhone than Apple's own products.
But the devil will really be in the details of the judge's ruling.
If the judge rules that Apple broke the law in a lot of different ways,
that may influence how the Department of Justice ultimately asks the judge to
fix matters in this case.
So they could ask for changes to Apple's behavior, they could ask for changes
to the structure of Apple, but they really are holding their cards fairly close
to the vest, while they wait to see how a court rules on the substance of the allegations.
Also mal sehen, mal sehen, aber eine kleine, bessere Erklärung,
die wir auch nutzen können, haben sie dann doch noch gefunden?
So, what the government believes is that, yes, they are accusing a major company
of wrongdoing, but that in doing so, they will open the door to innovations
that we can't even conceive of.
So, there would be a net benefit for both American society and Das heißt.
Wir haben es jetzt hier mit einem Paradigmenwechsel zu tun.
Das, was man proprietären Markt nennt, wird jetzt angegriffen.
Wir sind also vielleicht in einem Stadium, wo dieser Plattform- oder Überwachungskapitalismus
an seine Grenzen gerät, und zwar an seine legalen Grenzen, wenn sich die Gesetze jetzt verändern.
Und es bedeutet aber auch, dass wir eigentlich hier eine Entwicklung sehen,
die parallel noch zu einem anderen
Trend verläuft, nämlich es gibt ja eine Rückkehr der physischen Medien.
Man kann sich diese großen Studien ansehen, wie Leute heute lesen,
welche Bücher sie kaufen.
Und da gab es ja ganz tolle Prognosen vor fünf Jahren, vor zehn Jahren,
die Leute werden vorwiegend digital lesen. Stimmt alles nicht.
Der Digitalmarkt ist kein Wachstumsmarkt.
Der einzige Markt im digitalen Sinne der Wechsel ist der Hörbuchmarkt.
Das liegt nahe, die Leute hören Podcasts, also können sie auch ein Hörbuch sich
anhören. Aber der E-Reader…,
Hat sich gefestigt, er wird auch nicht verschwinden und er wird auch für manche
Texte vielleicht sogar sinnvoller sein.
Du hast das ja alles hier schon häufig beschrieben, was du alles Tolles machen
kannst, wenn du das digital liest.
Aber die Leute, die jetzt Belletristik lesen oder das populäre Sachbuch,
kaufen es in gedruckter Form und das bedeutet, sie entziehen sich diesen Logiken.
Sie fragen sich nicht, wenn ich mal irgendwann kein Kindle mehr haben will,
kann ich dann noch mit den Büchern was anfangen oder gebe ich die an Amazon
damit zurück? Ja, die Antwort ist, die gehören einem dann nicht mehr.
Das ist ja auch bei Audible, wenn man jetzt Bücher dort kauft,
dann hat man sie in dem Sinne nicht. Sie sind immer nur da so gemietet,
man ist einfach da und es gibt diesen Trend und da beim Buch fällt es uns noch
sehr leicht, das nachzuvollziehen.
Es gibt diesen Trend aber jetzt ganz stark bei Blu-Rays und DVDs,
denn diese Plattformen haben ja auch die Marktmacht zu sagen,
ja die Serie ist jetzt nicht mehr im Paket, die wird jetzt nicht mehr ausgestrahlt.
Ja, das ist mir auch schon aufgefallen.
Return of Physical Media oder irgendwas in diese Richtung, da gibt es ganz viele
Filmkritiker und nicht nur,
so richtige Nerds, sondern sehr sehr populär Leute, die sagen,
also ich kaufe jetzt wieder DVDs, ich will die Sachen haben,
ich will auch einen Film ein zweites Mal sehen und nicht darauf hoffen,
dass der dann auch noch bei Prime oder so verfügbar ist.
Das ist ja auch so frustrierend, bei Prime ist es so, wenn du das öffnest,
ich habe ja nicht so ein, es gibt ja glaube ich, kann man das alles dann machen,
dass man in allen Ländern irgendwas konsumieren kann, aber ich bin da nur auf
dem Deutschen und sehe dann aber, naja gut, wenn ich jetzt,
in den USA wäre oder sonst wo, dann könnte ich den Film gucken,
kann es aber nicht, weil die jetzt gerade dafür keine Lizenz haben.
Das ist eine wahnsinnig interessante Sache, denn so sehr ich immer betone,
wie ich lese, wie ich durchsuchen möchte,
wie ich nachträglich Sachen mir strukturieren möchte, was ja alles nur auf digitalem
Wege geht, ist ja dieses etwas Besitzen in Verfügbarkeit haben wirklich ein riesiges Problem.
Wenn man zum Beispiel bei Büchern, alle Bücher mit ISBN-Nummern,
die sind wirklich identifizierbar, bis hin zu Auflage.
Also man könnte sagen, die ISBN-Nummer, Auflage 2.
Wenn ich jetzt ein Buch kaufe, warum habe ich nicht ein staatlich garantiertes,
also einfach Rule of Law, ich habe es gekauft. Und zwar egal an welcher App.
Also tatsächlich mit der Vorstellung, ich kaufe bei iBooks ein Buch und wenn
ich mich in 10 Jahren entscheide, ich hole mir ein Android-Handy oder noch was
anderes, sage ich einfach nur,
das ist mein Account, da stehen meine ISBN-Nummern drin, das sind meine Bücher.
Bitte einmal reinladen.
Ich möchte nochmal sehr empfehlen.
Für Film und Musik müsste das auch gelten.
Da haben wir jetzt keine ISBN-Nummern oder so, aber da könnte man das ja genauso strukturieren.
Dafür bräuchten wir einfach jetzt wirklich politische Entscheidungen,
die das ermöglichen. Raus aus diesen Silos.
Was bedeutet, wir hätten diese digitale Proliferation als echte Infrastruktur.
An die man sich als Unternehmen drankoppeln kann, aber eben nur drankoppeln.
Man ist sie nicht. Die Infrastruktur selbst ist gegeben wie eine Straße.
Man kann dann ein Auto anbieten oder Mobilität als ein Service oder was auch
immer, aber die Straße bleibt erstmal der öffentlichste Raum, den es gibt.
So, und je nachdem, welche Kaufentscheidung ich traf, darf ich dann damit auf
der Straße mich bewegen.
Wir haben beim letzten Mal über die Bibliotheken gesprochen,
weil das Lafayette-Kaufhaus in Berlin jetzt eventuell da irgendwie Bücherei wird und so.
Wenn man in Deutschland einen Büchereiausweis hat, kann man in die Bücherei
gehen und dort auch aktuelle Tages- und Wochenzeitungen lesen.
Nur, zusätzlich kriegt man auch noch Zugang zu diesen Publikationen in digitaler Form.
Man muss also nicht physisch in die Bücherei laufen und hat trotzdem Zugang.
In Amerika ist es so, dass du so eine App dir runterladen kannst,
die einfach überall verfügbar ist. ist, du meldest dich in einer Bibliothek
an und alle physisch in der Bibliothek verfügbaren Bücher stehen dir dann noch digital zur Verfügung.
Das würde ja, wie ich finde, so Nutzungsverhalten eröffnen, wenn das mal alle
wüssten, dass man dann tatsächlich mehr ins digitale Stöbern kommt.
Dass man so eine Verfügbarkeit weiß, ah ja, das ist die öffentliche Bücherei,
das ist ein kommunaler Träger, der mir zusichert, ich habe da Zugang und so weiter.
Also das Das sind ja alles diese kleinen Shifts, die mal aus diesem Google Maps,
es ist ein kleiner Teil der Tränen im Nutzerverhalten, aber indem man mal kurz
das zertrümmert, kann man ja auch sehr viel Komplexität dann aufbauen.
Also es könnte durchaus eine Chance sein, oder sagen wir mal so,
das Indiz, dass Leute zurückgehen zum analogen Medium, so viele...
Gut gemeinte und auch normativ verständliche Argumentationen.
Es könnte auch ein Indikator dafür sein, dass in diesem digitalen Vertreiben
relativ viel schief läuft.
Ja, ja, ganz klar. Also daran liegt das. Das wird auch sehr offen so in diesen
YouTube-Videos kommuniziert.
Man tut das, weil man den Streaming-Diensten nicht mehr vertraut, so ist die Aussage.
Genau. Und wie weit muss man dieses Infrastruktur-Argument jetzt denken?
Ich komme mit zwei Clips zurück auf Jeff Bezos. Wir haben ihn gehört bei Alex Friedman im Podcast.
Die zwei Sachen hatte ich bisher nur genannt. Wir haben sie noch nicht gehört.
Wir fangen mal mit diesem Clip an.
So, Jeff Bezos fabuliert darüber, wie er sich die Zukunft vorstellt.
Ja, eine Billion Menschen leben so im Dunstkreis des Planeten Erde.
Erde, es gibt genug Ressourcen und es ist ein ganz individualistischer Blick.
Ich will tausend Mozarts und tausend Einsteins. Und wir sagen völlig zu Recht
als Kritik, naja, es gibt tausend Mozarts und tausend Einsteins, nur,
infrastrukturbedingt sitzen sie eben nicht in Universitäten,
sondern in Indien auf der Müllkippe und suchen halt irgendein Zeug zusammen, um zu überleben.
Ja, und es ist aber so interessant, dass er ja jetzt gegenüber zu uns als jemand erscheint, der ja,
unglaubliche Macht über ganz viele Menschen hat. Also er kann sich als der Unternehmer
bezeichnen, wahrscheinlich mit einem der größten Personalstäbe überhaupt, denke ich.
Und er hatte also unglaublich viele Wirkmacht, hätte er.
Also er könnte jetzt sagen, ich verbessere nur noch die Welt.
Ich habe diese ganzen Leute und dann denkt man, ach nee, das wäre aber jetzt
doof, wenn ich das jetzt machen müsste.
Also kapriziere ich mich mal darauf, darauf, was ist in 10.000 Jahren irgendwann
und dann ist man selbst ganz gut aus dem Schneider, weil man sagen kann,
ich kümmere mich ja um die 1.000 Mozarts, wo man auch dann die Frage stellen muss,
hast du überhaupt mal alle über 20 Mozart-Opern dir angehört?
Also da wäre ja schon mal einiges zu tun, wenn man sich nur mal den Mozart, den wir schon haben.
Erschließen will. Genau, warum eigentlich Mozart? Diese Frage kann man sich stellen, genau.
So, und jetzt macht er aber, nachdem er das hier so hochgradig individualisiert
hat, als Zielsetzung will ich 1000 Mozarts, 1000 Einsteins.
Jetzt macht er im Zweiten konkret auf ihn angesprochen, auf seine Biografie,
warum hat er jetzt Amazon verlassen, was ist seine neue Idee?
Und jetzt stellt er uns so eine Idee von Heavy Infrastructure vor.
And use that to build heavy infrastructure so that the next generation,
the generation that's my children and their children, those generations can
then use that heavy infrastructure.
Then there'll be space entrepreneurs who start in their dorm room.
That will be a marker of success.
When you can have a really valuable space company started in a dorm room,
then we know that we've built enough infrastructure,
So.
Eine juristische Anklage einer Regierung muss natürlich grammatikalisch richtig
und gut formuliert sein, damit die Richter verstehen, was da verhandelt wird.
Es darf nicht ausfransen.
Das kann aber nur gelingen, wenn drunter herum so ein publizistischer Rahmen
aufgemacht wird, in dem alles mal durchdiskutiert wird.
Und ich finde, auf solche Zitate sollte man sich phötonistisch und politisch
als Journalist stürzen.
Denn was er hier sagt ist, Amazon verstehe ich als Produkt.
Ich biete einen Service an, den biete ich an, ich schließe Konkurrenz aus,
nur das macht es erfolgreich und so weiter.
Und jetzt sagt er hier auf anderem, aber auch seinem Felde, dieser Raumfahrt,
eigentlich geht es gar nicht darum, Produkte herzustellen, sondern Infrastruktur zu schaffen.
Ein Markt eigentlich.
Ist im Grunde die Markierung einer ganz wichtigen Zäsur, wenn nämlich aus Produkten Infrastruktur wird.
Also wenn Service zu einer allgemein verfügbaren Infrastruktur wird,
auf die man sich dann verlassen muss, auch wenn der Chef irgendwelche Spiränzchen
mit der AGB schreiben will. Nein, es muss verlässlich sein.
Man braucht also demokratische Kontrolle. Und genau diese Zäsur findet ja jetzt statt.
Das iPhone ist eben nicht mehr ein Produkt von Apple, sondern es ist mittlerweile
allgemeine Infrastruktur ist, wenn Pandemie ist und es heißt Homeschooling,
Homeoffice, dann brauchen wir iPhones, dann brauchen wir Samsung-Geräte.
Es gibt zwei Hersteller auf der Welt, die alles dominieren.
Und so wie wir da auch Microsoft ein bisschen kurz und klein geschlagen haben,
gesagt haben, nee, da muss jede Software drauf laufen.
Ihr habt einen Universalkomputer der Gesellschaft zur Verfügung gestellt.
Den könnt ihr zwar verkaufen für einen hohen Preis, Aber danach ist das das
Gerät des Users, der im Rahmen seiner Jurisdiktion, seiner Demokratie damit
einfach hantieren möchte.
Eure AGBs gelten dann einfach nicht mehr. So und das wird jetzt gerade verhandelt
und dafür braucht man eine Definition von, was ist eigentlich ein Markt?
Wenn wir jetzt Produkte und Services haben, die umschlagen in allgemeine oder
wie im Kartellrecht eben wesentliche Einrichtungen zu sein, dann müssen wir
jetzt definieren, was das ist.
Und damit tun die sich sehr schwer. Es ist eigentlich interessant,
dass man das ja im Verfahren jetzt definieren müsste.
Aber der juristische Weg eben sagt, ihr müsst die Anklage gegen Apple schon klar formulieren.
Ihr dürft die nicht erst entwickeln, wenn ihr mit dem im Streit seid.
Aber die hatten ja vorher relativ viele Gespräche. Der Digital Marketers Act
wurde ja auch mit den Unternehmen zusammen so ein bisschen im Gespräch,
Lobby-Einflüsse und so weiter, da einfach verhandelt.
Und der Stand jetzt, wo die Anklagen geschrieben sind, ist folgender.
Also Markt und Monopole.
Die New York Times unterscheidet mal Marktdefinition, was Apple und was das
Justizministerium in Amerika darunter versteht.
Oh,
interessant. So Apple is saying, look, you got the wrong universe, right?
Ich kann die Argumentation von Apple sehr gut nachvollziehen.
Ich kann beide sehr gut nachvollziehen.
Denn es ist ja so, dass wir es ja hier mit einem der wichtigsten Konzerne in den USA zu tun haben.
Und wir sehen, wie heikel das ist, wenn chinesische Konzerne sehr, sehr mächtig werden.
Und dann kommen die auch ins Straucheln. Wie gehen wir jetzt damit um?
Soll man TikTok verbieten? All diese ganzen Debatten.
Und es ist ja so, sobald ich mein Flagship eindampfe, es seiner Möglichkeiten
der Profitmaximierung beraube, dann komme ich dazu,
dass dieses Unternehmen schwächer wird in der globalen Konkurrenz und damit
würde man möglicherweise nationalen Interessen schaden.
Und deswegen ist dieses Spiel, das da jetzt gerade gespielt wird,
das sehr ernst ist natürlich,
eines, das seine ganz klaren Grenzen hat,
nämlich dort werden diese Grenzen aufgezeigt, wo man tatsächlich riskiert,
den Konkurrenten aus dem Ausland plötzlich mehr Platz einzuräumen und das hat
natürlich Apple durch diese proprietäre Marktstruktur immer ganz gut geschafft.
Das Ausland zwar integriert war, aber am Ende lief alles über Apple.
Und wenn man jetzt aber plötzlich zum Beispiel Map-Anbieter hat,
die viel, viel besser sind, die aus China kommen und die dann nicht mehr Google Maps sind,
dann frage ich mich, ob dann zum Beispiel EU und USA noch in gleicher Weise sagen,
ach wie gut, dass wir mal den Markt zerschlagen haben.
Google sagt, wir sind gut in Search und dann übertragen sie das auch auf Maps,
weil sie einfach den ganzen Nutzermarkt einmal rüberschieben können.
Als erster Suchbegriff kommt die Google-Karte und die klicke ich dann sofort an.
Und das ist ja deine Einfachheit, die du ja haben möchtest, wie du betont hast.
Und so ist das hier natürlich auch.
Aber sie ist auch ein geopolitischer Faktor, wenn man so einen starken Konzern hat.
Das haben wir ja auf allen Ebenen wieder. Das deutsche Kartellrecht verbietet
ARD und und CDF eine gemeinsame Mediathek zu betreiben, weil die sollen ja Konkurrenten sein.
Dann kommt aber YouTube als einheitlicher Giga-Player und macht alles platt.
So, dass einfach die deutschen öffentlich-rechtlichen Anbieter ihre Sachen einfach
zu YouTube laden. Damit haben sie eine einheitliche, aber nicht ihre eigene.
Also da ging das Kartellrecht sozusagen in die falsche Richtung.
So, hier haben wir jetzt, wie du gesagt hast, auf beiden Seiten gute Argumente.
Wenn wir den Markt nicht als globalen Markt definieren, was nun mal in der wirtschaftlichen
Arena sinnvoll ist, nur noch eine Wirtschaft, eine Weltwirtschaft zu betonen.
Zumindest im digitalen Markt.
Ja, ich würde sagen in fast allen mittlerweile, selbst bei Milch und so hast du ja.
Ja, okay, aber ich glaube, du kannst schon nochmal kartellrechtlich,
wenn du es mit nationalen Playern zu tun hast, die ja auch nur da sind,
die können sich nicht auf den Markt beziehen.
Also wenn du jetzt zwei Medienhäuser hast, die nur in Deutschland publizieren
und die sagen, ja, aber wir verkaufen noch fünf Zeitungen in Frankreich,
seht doch, wir sind doch gar nicht der Markt.
Also mindestens bei digitalen Projekten und Produkten haben wir es mit globalem Markt zu tun.
Und trotzdem sagt das DOJ, naja, aber wir wollen jetzt hier den…,
Performance-Smartphone-Markt regeln.
Da fragt man sich ja auch wieder, das Performance-Smartphone,
also das iPhone 15 fällt da rein, aber das iPhone 10 nicht, weil der Chip vom
iPhone 10 irgendwie schwächer ist oder wie auch immer.
Also es sind ganz schwierige Argumentationen. Entsprechend bei Hardfork machen
sie auch ein bisschen drüber lustig.
Define a market. Are we talking about all smartphones? Are we talking about some smartphones?
So in this case, how does the DOJ in these states, how do they define the market
here? So they say that this case is about what they call performance smartphones.
I like that. It's like performance athleisure. Yes, exactly.
And they distinguish them from the low-end smartphones, the sort of,
you know, the Android phones that you might be able to pick up for $50 or $100.
They have a bunch of different things that they say distinguish.
So, wir haben also vorhin bei den New York Times gehört 65%,
hier haben wir jetzt 70% Marktanteil gehört bei Performance-Smartphones.
Jetzt ist ja die Frage, ein kleiner technischer Sprung.
Ich operate gar nicht mehr mit dem Chip auf dem Gerät, sondern ich bin streamingmäßig
angebunden. Ich benutze nur noch als Bildschirm.
Das reduziert ja die Kosten des Telefons auf eine Batterie und einen Bildschirm.
Also 80% der Computertechnik fallen da dann einfach raus.
Habe ich es dann trotzdem noch mit einem High-Performance-Smartphone zu tun?
Weil in der Cloud läuft ja noch viel krasseres, noch viel mehr Computer Power
als jetzt auf dem Gerät selbst. Also all solche Fragen.
Eine kleine technische Änderung kann schon alle Definitionen hier einfach zerschießen.
Aber jetzt hat man eben diese 70% Performance Smartphones gefunden.
Diese Marktdefinition wird auch im Big Technology Podcast verhandelt,
den ich auch sehr empfehle. Der ist mir kürzlich erst untergekommen.
IPhone-Markt in den USA, aber 70% der Performance-Smartphone-Markt in den USA.
Du, hast du einfach eine neue Kategorie zu 5% in den Markt gelegt?
Was ist da los? Und von dem, was ich verstehe, 70% ist nicht eine Monopolie.
Es ist eine dominante Position, aber nicht monopolistisch.
Ja, und dann auf der anderen Seite, und um es ehrlich zu sein,
hast du Apple, die versuchen zu sagen, oh, wir sind nur eine kleine,
kleine kleine Firma hier.
Und sie sprechen über ihren globalen Market Share, which is true,
it's, you know, 20%, maybe less.
Ich überlege gerade, was eigentlich mein Nokia-Handy ist. Ist das ein Performance-Handy? Nee, ne?
Nee, nee, das ist, das gilt gar nicht als Smartphone, glaube ich.
Aber ich glaube, man kommt irgendwie auch ins Internet damit rein.
Ah ja. Na gut. Kann sein.
Das kostet wahrscheinlich 5 Euro die Minute oder so.
Ja, muss ja mal nachfragen, ob für dich noch jemand das GSM irgendwas da nochmal datendurchschickt.
Ja.
Die krasseste, das krasseste Auseinanderklaffen, was wir bisher hatten,
war ja, dass Jeff Bezos zugeschaltet ist im Kongress.
Und dann sagt, nee, sie behaupten ja gerade, wir hätten 90% des Handels.
Damit ist ja nur online und auch nur in Amerika gemeint. Das ist ja nur ein Channel.
Weltweit am Einzelhandel sind wir nur mit 2% beteiligt. Also so weit kann man
es ja treiben. 90 und 2%, so irgendwo muss man dann so eine Definition finden.
Kevin Roos versucht es jetzt mal aus Apples Sicht zu argumentieren,
wie du es eben auch schon versucht hast.
So,
jetzt sagt sagt er,
ja, Apple baut ein anderes Phone.
Das ist aber eine komische Argumentation, finde ich. Denn es geht ja jetzt zunächst mal darum,
dass nicht nur andere Smartphone-Anbieter sich einen Markt erschließen können,
sondern dass diejenigen, die darauf angewiesen sind, dass ihre Apps im Podcast angezeigt werden,
die können ja nicht selbst, also du kannst ja nicht sagen, ich habe zwar eine
Dating-App entwickelt, jetzt muss ich nur noch ein passendes Smartphone dafür erfinden.
Also man kann ja auch mal ein anderes vielleicht ungerechtes Beispiel nehmen.
Plattenspieler kauft man, kosten 500 Euro und dann ist gut.
Dann hat Sony oder wer auch immer 500 Euro bekommen.
Wenn ich da jetzt Platten drauf abspiele, dann bekommt nicht Sony nochmal von
dem Plattenlabel oder gar dem Künstler immer 50 Cent.
Und so ist es aber eigentlich mit diesen Ja.
Also das ist ein wichtiger Punkt, dass Apple selber sagt, es ist nicht nur ein
Produkt, sondern eine Servicegrundlage und wir wollen wollen immer weiter eine
Service-Fee sozusagen haben.
Ich würde aber sagen, so wie er hier sagt, dann sagt Apple einfach den anderen,
ja, baut halt ein besseres Phone.
Da ist man ja noch in der, das Telefon ist ein Produkt, denke. Nur das ist vorbei.
Also das iPhone hat überhaupt nur Sinn, weil man nicht der Einzige ist,
der eins hat. Und umso mehr eins haben, umso besser für einen selber.
Die Synergieeffekte für den Anbieter eines Services spielen ja gerade eine große Rolle.
Es gibt keine Produkte für Telefone, die nur 10% der Menschen nutzen,
sondern man geht dorthin und entwickelt für die zuerst, die viele nutzen.
Weshalb das DOJ sagt ja 70%. 70% ist die Mehrheit.
Jeder, der eine App entwickelt, fragt sich, für welchen Markt will ich tätig
sein? Ah, Performance-Smartphone, ich entwickle zuerst für das iPhone und wenn
es dort gut läuft, kann ich auch noch eine Android-Version herstellen oder wie auch immer.
Das sind ja diese Entscheidungen und das kriegt man aber nur gefasst,
wenn man das iPhone nicht mehr als Produkt
ansieht, sondern nur noch als Grundlage-Infrastruktur in der Gesellschaft.
Die man eben auch mit benutzt.
Und wir sagen das hier ganz ausdrücklich und ich spreche da vor allem für dich,
wir wollen nicht, dass es noch verschiedene weitere Smartphones gibt.
Also das ist nicht das Ziel dieser ganzen Sache.
Genau, das ist nicht das Ziel.
Was jetzt Kevin Bruce jetzt hier ausführt. Und deswegen sind wir ja auch nicht
grundsätzlich gegen Monopole.
Wir sind ja in einer hochmodernen Gesellschaft und da kann man sehen, dass wenn,
Produktionsmittel sich konzentrieren, auch sehr viel dann möglich ist und diese
ganzen Netzwerke, die wir ja nutzen, funktionieren ja auch alle so, wie du sagst.
Also ich bin bei Instagram, weil dann noch andere bei Instagram sind,
zum Beispiel Freunde oder das Publikum ist bei Instagram.
Es nutzt ja nichts, wenn ich mir jetzt irgendeine kleine eigene Plattform baue
oder auf eine gehe und sage, hier bin ich aber für mich, da bin ich nicht beim Monopol.
Das heißt, das muss man schon akzeptieren, dass man in einem modernen Kapitalismus
es mit Monopolen zu tun hat, nur Nur darf man denen nicht unendlichen Spielraum
geben, weil dann natürlich das passiert,
dass diese Monopole zu Innovationsverhinderern werden und darum geht es ja hier.
Ja, und das ist noch ein bisschen feingliedriger. Ich hatte gestern die Erfahrung
gemacht, ich habe eine Story gepostet bei Instagram, in der ich ganz unten die
Erwähnung, der auf dem Bild sichtbar gemacht habe.
Und dann bekam ich Hinweise von Nutzern, dass sie die nicht anklicken können,
weil auf ihrem Telefon schon die Adresszeile, die Kommentarspalte drüber steht.
Wo ich wieder gedacht habe, ich baue natürlich meine so, dass sie auf dem iPhone gut aussieht.
Andere Hersteller machen andere Seiten-Ratio, sodass dann, wenn Instagram auf
Android auch in Vollbild die Story anzeigen will, unten einfach was rausfällt.
Und das zeigt mir schon wieder, hier ist so eine Inkompatibilität,
die einfach zeigt, das ist keine allgemeine Infrastruktur, über die einfach
mal entschieden wurde, das geht so nicht. sondern die hat einfach Apple Design durchgedrückt,
So, dass ich dann wieder anderen Leuten zurückkoppel, achso,
du hast gar kein iPhone, ich hab's fürs iPhone optimiert, ja,
ich orientiere mich an den 70% Performance-Smartphone-Markt,
sozusagen, und auf der kleinen Ebene werden diese Nutzerverhalten jetzt hoffentlich mal ausgewertet.
Die Argumentation wird nicht klüger, wenn Kevin Rose versucht,
mehr dazu zu sagen, als aus Apples Sicht zu sehen.
Das ist das beste Handy, weil wir unsere Ökosysteme stark kontrolliert haben.
Du kannst ein iPhone kaufen und weißt, dass du nicht malware-verpackt werden wirst.
Du weißt, dass es ein gewisser Standard für Privatsache sein wird.
All diese Dinge, die Regulierer jetzt sagen, sind schrecklich,
sind eigentlich nur wir, die
unseren Kunden servieren und ihnen das beste Handy auf dem Markt geben.
Und ich denke, es gibt eine Wahrheit dazu.
Ich bin ein iPhone-User. Ich bin ein glücklicher iPhone-User.
Ich habe versucht, Android-Handys zu schalten. It was not a great experience
and it was not just because of all the sort of switching costs and all the things
that Apple makes difficult about switching costs It's also because the iPhone is just a good product.
Das iPhone ist einfach ein gutes Produkt kommt hoffentlich nicht so weit vor Gericht, denn ja,
es ist ein gutes Produkt Also wenn die Verhandlungstage immer damit beginnen,
dass man erstmal abfeiert, was für ein gutes Produkt das ist,
genau das ist ja weshalb es jetzt allgemeine Infrastruktur geworden ist,
genau deswegen überführen wir es ja,
Und interessanterweise ist, und da habe ich jetzt auch gedacht,
okay, das ist jetzt wirklich, hier wird es jetzt brenzlig für Apple,
denn Apple lag uns ja jetzt Jahrzehnte eigentlich im Ohr mit,
wir sind das Supersicherheitssystem.
Bei uns wird Differential Privacy erfunden und der ganze Kram,
wir verkaufen keine Nutzerdaten und so weiter und so fort.
Und da werden sie wohl den, würde ich vorschlagen, die größte Einflugschneise
einfach nutzen, um diese Argumentation so ein bisschen zu zertrümmern.
Beim Daily wird nochmal Fokus drauf gelegt.
Into a big fight with the government over encryption. And Apple is saying that
that commitment to security lives in a lot of these practices that the government is targeting.
A great example is the wallet. So the way they exclude other companies from
making digital wallets is they don't let them access the physical chip that
interacts with the technology at the coffee shop to make the payment.
And Apple says they don't do that because they want to create the safest and
most secure experience for users when they go to pay for their coffee with their
sensitive banking information.
So, Apple hat das Angebot gemacht und jetzt wird es auch eingefordert von den Nutzern.
Das halte ich jetzt, was wir jetzt hören, für eine sehr relevante Argumentation.
And Apple is saying that users love the end result. They love this experience.
And then Apple is going to defend that experience from government intervention.
So Apple is basically saying, look, they're not trapped. They can leave anytime
they want. They want to be here.
That's right. And they want to be there because they love their Apple products.
Right, they want an iPhone. Right, exactly.
So, die Nutzer wollen ein sicheres Gerät haben. Apple hat es ihnen versprochen.
Und was sie kriegen, ist aber ein Gerät, das iMessage ist.
Also eine eigene Chat-Plattform, die auf der SMS, nicht Technologie,
aber Plattform aufsetzt. Also es gibt nur eine Nachrichten-App.
Entweder schickt man eine SMS oder automatisiert, wenn der Empfänger eben auch
ein iPhone hat, dann eine etwas andere, hochgradig verschlüsselte und so weiter.
Also iMessage, das erste Produkt auf der Infrastruktur des iPhones von iOS,
die hier thematisiert wird.
We are begrudgingly planning to update the way it handles text messages on the iPhone.
It does plan to support something called RCS, which is sort of a more kind of
friendlier to Android style of messaging that it says will come to the iPhone later this year.
But this is one that annoys a lot of people, and I think it is an underrated
factor in why people do not switch from iPhones to Android phones.
Und so that is something that the DOJ and these states are bringing up as well.
So, großer Log-In-Effekt. Leute, die auch iMessage haben, deswegen ja auch immer
iPhone-Familien, können eben da Gruppen machen, sich den Kram hin und her schicken.
Das bleibt alles, wenn ich jetzt so ein Foto mache, was eine zweisekündige Live-Videoaufnahme
mitnimmt und ich verschicke das in iMessage, bleibt das Zwei-Sekunden-Video
erhalten, in anderen Apps nicht.
Nach Android kann ich gar nicht über die Message-App überhaupt Bilder verschicken,
sondern da müsste ich dann einen iCloud-Link verschicken, den man dann aufrufen
kann im Browser. Also das ist total bescheuert.
Und nicht nur ist das eben sehr viel schlechter nutzbar, also da ist einfach
klar, das wäre besser zu machen durch diesen anderen Standard,
den er da jetzt genannt hat.
Wir hatten ja schon mal, dass SMS durch MMS geupdatet werden sollte.
Also das ist einfach ein anderer Standard, der dann auch Bilder und so weiter mit beinhaltet.
Apple hat sich immer dagegen gesträubt, das zu machen.
Google hat das Angebot gemacht. Komm, lasst uns mal hier den etwas richeren,
Messaging-Standard zu nehmen.
Und Casey Newton weist jetzt auf, finde ich, eine sehr große Problemlage hin,
die man Apple da jetzt mal richtig um die Ohren haut.
Ja, während es bisher immer hieß, ja, Apple forciert Privacy und den ganzen
Kram als Business Advantage.
Die Leute wissen, wenn sie ein iPhone nutzen, sind sie sicherer.
Wird hier aufgrund des Profitinteresses in Kauf genommen, dass man unsicherer
kommuniziert. Das ist abhörbar, das ist manipulierbar.
Wir kriegen relativ viel, ach, du lockst dich gerade ein, hier schick dir nochmal
ein Token per SMS, SMS, trag mal die sechs Buchstaben ein und so.
Und das wird, wenn es über SMS abgewickelt ist, einfach nicht sicher.
Das wird unverschlüsselt durch die Welt gesendet und jeder kann es abfangen.
In der Hinsicht nimmt Apple hier große Sicherheitsprobleme in Kauf,
einfach nur um diesen Markt abzuschirmen.
Und das dann ergänzt mit diesem ganzen Stigma-Kram.
Und die Regierung sagt, dass Apple diese Dichotomie des Green-Bubble-Blue-Bubble-Dichotomie
gegründet hat, um einen Stigma zu erzeugen, um Phones, die nicht das iPhone
sind, zu gestalten, um ihren niedrigeren Status zu gestalten.
Und dass tatsächlich einige Non-iPhone-User von einem sozialen Stigma verletzt
werden, weil sie kein iPhone haben.
Und die Justiz-Departement sagt, dass dies besonders für Teenager ist und Daten
präsentiert, dass etwa 88% von Teenagern sagen, dass ihr nächstes Handy ein iPhone sein wird.
Da kannst du mal sehen.
Wie ich mich fühle, wenn du von deinem iPhone schwärmst und ich dastehe und
denke, ja, so schön könnte also das Leben sein.
Ich leuchte hier in grün und so, ja, du schickst halt immer so schwarze Nokia-Texte.
Du zeigst mir das jetzt gerade mit der grünen Bubble, das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Also du bekommst, also die Leute, die dir vom iPhone schreiben,
das erscheint hier grün.
Also ich habe es farblich umgestellt.
Ja, okay, aber generell ist es so, dass die Kommunikation zwischen iPhone-Besitzern
ist grün und die, die von irgendwelchen Schrott-Telefonen dann schreiben,
ja, die erscheinen dann auch schon markiert als, die sind nicht die Privilegierten.
Also dieses Stigma, was jetzt hier beschrieben wird, unter dem offenbar Teenager
sehr zu leiden haben, das ist also etwas, was, also es ist total logisch.
Ich meine, man kann, also.
Die Sache ist die, mir war nicht klar, dass Apple nicht auch versucht,
da für alle die größte Sicherheit herzustellen.
Mir war immer klar, dass man also besonders sicher ist, wenn man von iPhone
zu iPhone kommuniziert und dass die sich auch anlegen mit der Regierung,
wenn sie was preisgeben sollen, all diese historischen Fälle,
die es da ja schon gegeben hat.
Mir war aber nicht klar, dass man das auch nicht nur als Verkaufsargument hat,
sondern auch nochmal so deutlich unterstreicht. Wenn du das machst, dann machst du das.
Und das ist ja sowieso, also das merke ich, weil ich mich ja viel im öffentlichen
Raum bewege durch diese ganzen Vortragsreisen.
Es gibt so viele Sachen, die jetzt nochmal so, also man kann sich nochmal so
ein bisschen mehr Sicherheit, ein bisschen mehr Schnelligkeit oder so laufend irgendwo erkaufen.
Also man, das ärgert mich auch zum Teil sehr,
weil es einfach lästig ist, dass man in ein Hotel einchecken will und dort gibt
es dann nochmal so eine extra Rezeption für die,
die irgendeine Rewards-Member-Karte haben, wo ich dann denke, ja,
das ist gegenüber allen anderen auch keine gute Psychologie.
Also klar soll der Druck auf mich auslösen, dass ich auch noch diese 10 Euro
zahle, die das kostet im Jahr oder keine Ahnung was.
Aber ich würde auch einfach mal gerne sagen, ich habe jetzt hier genug ausgegeben,
ich würde jetzt einfach mal gerne, dass es funktioniert.
Also dass man überall nochmal so eine kleine, so ein Mini-Update haben kann.
Erste Klasse abschaffen.
Sagte, ja, er findet das im Bordbistro so toll, da kommt die erste und die zweite Klasse zusammen.
Das war sein...
Ja, und er fände es doch schön, wenn man die erste Klasse abschaffen würde.
Dazu muss ich sagen, also ich finde, dass, also die Sache ist ja die,
die erste Klasse ist dafür gemacht, dass da Leute ein bisschen mehr Platz haben. Mhm.
Und das ist aber nicht so luxuriös, dass man jetzt sagen kann,
Wahnsinn, sondern man müsste eigentlich sagen, ja, das müsste eigentlich so
ein Standardniveau in einem Zug sein.
In dem man ja manchmal vier Stunden hängt.
Und ich finde, wir werden gleich Zahlen über Armut in Deutschland bekommen.
Wir leben in einer derart dramatisch ungleichen Gesellschaft.
Und dann solche Schaukämpfe da aufzuführen, wo man da sitzt,
dann würde ich auch sagen, das ist ja generell so, dass Leute, die bereit sind,
sehr viel mehr Geld auszugeben, in luxuriöseren Restaurants sind oder Hotels.
Und im Übrigen ist ja bei der ersten Klasse kommen diese Preisunterschiede,
es kommt ja sehr drauf an, was man da bucht.
Also ich glaube, diese Flex-Tickets oder so, die sind teurer,
diese Spartickets, ich glaube, das sind 10, 15 Euro.
Wie dem auch sei, ich will auch niemanden die Spaß am Zug fahren nehmen,
der gerne da den Klassenfrieden herstellen will im Bordbistro.
Ich würde eher mal die Frage stellen, wenn man glaubt, den Klassenfrieden im
Bordbistro herstellen zu können, ist das eigentlich für eine öffentliche Infrastruktur,
mit der wir es ja da ganz definitiv zu tun haben, richtig,
dass man dort völlig überteuertes Essen bekommt, während man dort sieht,
dass da sehr viele Familien reisen,
zum Beispiel auch in der zweiten Klasse und die müssen dann,
wenn die zwei Kinder haben und die wollen Pommes essen und eine Cola trinken, ein Vermögen ausgeben.
Warum muss in der Bahn, ich weiß nicht genau den Preis, ich habe gerade eine
Cola Light getrunken da, 3,80 Euro für eine Cola Light.
Womit ist das gerechtfertigt? Also wenn wir da mal ein bisschen Zusammenhalt
in der Gesellschaft und Klassenfrieden und alles herstellen wollen,
dann würde ich sagen, es müsste.
So sein, dass man dort sehr günstig was bekommt, weil das einfach für Leute
wichtig ist, dass sie da was trinken können Und sonst was.
Und das ist ein Riesenbatzen Geld, den Familien da zahlen müssen,
wenn die auf einer sechsstündigen Reise sind.
Und dann kann man sagen, ja, die hätten sich was einpacken können und so.
Aber es wäre auch einfach mal schön, wenn man für einen Euro ein Wasser bekäme.
Ich habe noch einen Vorschlag. Mal gucken, wie du den findest.
Nicht erste Klasse abschaffen, sondern erste Klasse bevölkern.
Ich habe jetzt gestern original die Erfahrung gemacht, ein Zugticket zu buchen.
Ich muss ja nur nach Köln fahren, ab dann Regionalexpress, um ins Phantasialand zu kommen.
Die Kinder haben sich gewünscht, Phantasialand. Ich fahre so mit drei Kindern, alle unter 15.
Sie sind also in diesem 6 bis 14 Range kostenlos.
Wir fahren also zu Fürth nach Köln und zurück und mir wurde angeboten,
erste Klasse Upgrade für 20 Euro. Habe ich natürlich gemacht.
Gilt ja auch für die Kinder. Die fahren ja auch in der ersten Klasse kostenlos.
Ich würde gerne alle Eltern hier aufrufen, bevölkert mit euren Kindern die erste
Klasse. Wenn ihr rechtzeitig bucht.
Nein, tut es nicht.
Wenn ihr rechtzeitig bucht, ist es nur für euch der kleine Aufschlag.
Nämlich diese 20 oder 30 Euro. Und danach sitzen aber alle Kinder in der ersten Klasse.
Ja, und damit wird auch die zweite Klasse wieder sehr attraktiv.
Denke ich.
Ich will nur sagen, ich will ja in Ruheabteil.
Und da verstehe ich nicht, warum, also Familien gehören nicht ins Ruheabteil.
Ich glaube, da sind wir uns einig.
Familien haben ja ihr eigenes Abteil, eigentlich. Es gibt zwar nur eins.
Aber wenn es voll ist.
Ist es voll.
Ganz häufig ist es so, dass in Ruheabteilen oder im Ruhebereich Familien mit.
Hast du was gegen deine Rentenzahler?
Nee, aber es ist einfach sinnlos, Kinder, die gerne reden und auch reden sollen
und singen sollen und machen und tun, in ein Abteil zu setzen,
wo alle ganz still sein sollen und man nicht mal ein Handy und nicht mal ein Telefon annehmen kann.
Ja, aber ich will mich ja nicht völlig zustopfen und nichts mehr von der Wirklichkeit
mitbekommen, aber ich möchte schon die Möglichkeit haben, in einem Zug einigermaßen arbeiten zu können.
Für mich ist das ja Arbeitszeit, wenn ich da irgendwo hinfahre.
Ich mache ja keine Lustfahrten.
TikTok mal U-Bahn-Fahrten in Japan.
Keiner sagt ein Wort.
Grandios.
Alle schweigen.
Ja.
Und die Touristen filmen sich noch verschämt gegenseitig, nur um sich zu zeigen, ich höre nicht.
Leute stehen da, lesen ihr Buch, niemand redet.
Es ist wunderbar. Und die meisten Leute reden im Zug auch doll Zeug.
Und deswegen würde ich sagen, das Schweigen lernen ist etwas so Schönes und
die Deutschen sind leider viel zu laut.
Die Deutschen sind ein sehr lautes Volk. Man braucht nur mal über die Grenze,
fährt nach Metz oder Straßburg, wie schön und angenehm ruhig die Franzosen miteinander verlieren.
Okay, bevor wir hier zurückkommen zu unserem Thema, ich will eine kleine Pointe,
ich will nochmal später darauf zurückkommen, aber ich bin seit März ein E-Bike-Fahrer,
weil ich trotz junger Jahre… Rentnerrepublik.
Naja, ich hab, also mit dem E-Bike kannst du einfach 60 Kilometer am Tag fahren
oder, also du kannst wirklich, ich muss wohin, 15 Kilometer, kein Problem.
25 Kilometer, eine Stunde. So, ja, das kannst du mit allem planen.
Das ist einfach super. Mir ist aufgefallen, weil du ja so gegen das Tempolimit
gewettert hast, es gibt ja auf Fahrradwegen durch E-Bikes ein Tempolimit.
Alle fahren die erlaubten 25 kmh.
Das heißt, auf einem E-Bike kommt dir niemand in die Quere.
Du wirst nicht überholt, du überholst niemanden auf diesen neuen Pendelwegen.
Da gibt es auch nochmal so zwei, drei, die so mit normalen Fahrrädern,
man fährt dann kurz vorbei.
Aber ansonsten, du hast absolute Ruhe auf diesen Wegen, weil alle fahren die
gleiche Geschwindigkeit.
Also das kann ich sehr empfehlen, E-Bikes. Es scheint mir doch eine größere
Nummer zu sein, als ich dachte und war bisher schon überzeugt.
Darf man die tunen?
Du darfst die tunen, aber wie du dir vorstellen kannst, wenn ich sage,
alle fahren eine Geschwindigkeit, fällst du dann sehr auf.
Du bist sehr sichtbar auf einem Fahrradweg. Also wenn du da mit 27 oder 32,
der amerikanischen Geschwindigkeit, vorbeifährst, wirst du relativ zügig angehalten.
Okay. Und dann wird gefragt, was du denn da treibst. Und ich muss auch sagen, 25 kmh ist schnell.
Also diese amerikanische 32 kmh, das ist für deutsche Radwege, glaube ich, nicht.
Ich kann das nicht empfehlen. Also tuned eure E-Bikes nicht.
Aber zum Thema 1. Klasse abschaffen.
Das iPhone hat mit iMessage ein erste Klasse Messenger, den sie nun selber abschaffen.
Ein Argument von Alex Kantrowitz, das natürlich, wenn man es dann hört,
denkt man sich, na klar, ist wirklich auch ein Problem.
Becomes a green bubble in the iphone and everyone's like yeah yeah no that's
proof of the apple lock-in and for i for a while was on that side as well and
was like look look how you know what they're trying to do to make people switch
to to uh to to prevent people from switching to android however,
because apple has been so insistent on this apple i message lock-in and they
don't make it interoperable people have been moving to whatsapp in the us yeah
whatsapp has really been on the,
Ja.
Der Log-In-Effekt greift nämlich nur so weit, bis man irgendwann in einem Verein
ist, die Kinder in der Schulklasse und so weiter und so fort,
wo einfach klar ist, die haben echt nicht alle ein iPhone. Tim Cook sagt aber,
wir wollen hier keinen allgemeinen Standard wie bei E-Mail oder sowas haben.
Wir bleiben bei unserem Standard. Also einigt man sich auf WhatsApp.
Und das ist nun wirklich mal nicht das, was wir wollen. Und es ist auch nicht
das, was Apple will eigentlich.
Meta als irgendwie Raumgewinne da geben. Also ganz bescheuert.
Infrastruktur statt Produktverwechslung, auch beim Thema Apple Pay.
Um mit dem Tappen ihres Smartphones gegen einen kleinen Payment-Terminal zu
bezahlen, anstatt ihre Kreditkarte rauszuholen.
Auf dem iPhone ist nur Apple ermöglicht, eine solche digitale Wallet zu bieten.
Es heißt die Apple-Wallet. Und die Justiz-Departement sagt,
dass sie andere Unternehmen nicht ermöglichen, diese Art von Service zu bieten,
weil es Apple's Hold auf iPhone-User reduzieren könnte und es weniger kostbar
wäre, für diese User einen anderen Smartphone zu schalten und ihre digitale
Wallet mit ihnen zu nehmen. Das ist ein Beispiel.
Und wenn du sagst, dass es weniger teuer ist, dann meinst du,
dass es einfacher wäre, aus einem iPhone zu wechseln? Genau.
Pay muss allgemein verfügbar sein. Wer ein Wallet hat, egal in welcher Hose,
man nimmt sein Portemonnaie mit.
Und nur weil man die Hose wechselt, soll man das Portemonnaie nicht mitnehmen
können. Das ist ja bescheuert. Also das ist einfach, das versteht niemand.
Von daher ist diese Monopolisierung, nur wir dürfen den Chip nutzen, den wir da einbauen.
Dieser NFC-Chip, Near Field Communication, der so dann wie die Chipkarte mit
dem Terminal interagiert, ist allgemeine Infrastruktur. Also dass Apple den
überhaupt noch für sich reklamiert, ist eigentlich total Banane.
Den haben sie ja auch nicht erfunden.
Sie haben nur danach die Abwecklung, also wie da dieser Token-Austausch und so weiter.
Nur das hat eben, Google macht das auch so. Und dass man dann Anspruch auf diese
Hardware, die man da einbaut, Anspruch ist einfach, das ist völlig unverständlich.
Das ist so wie, als wenn man eine Kontrolle über die Taschenlampe.
Die Taschenlampe geht nur, wenn du zu Hause bist.
Darfst sie nicht draußen benutzen oder sowas. Ja, solche Restriktionen.
Das versteht einfach niemand. Casey Newton versucht uns das auch nochmal zu erklären.
Das ist das, was Apple liebt, wie das NFC-Chip selbst zu behalten.
Es kann Apple Pay einlegen und Apple
Pay nimmt einen kleinen Fee für jede Transaktion, die Sie durchführen.
Das ist also essentiell nur Profit für sie, weil sie total Kontrolle über den
NFC-Chip in Ihrem iPhone haben.
Also dass man sich da selber eine Nutzergebühr nochmal anrechnet,
ist, finde ich, dann die Höhe irgendwie.
Zuerst erklärt man, das ist unsere Hardware und dann reklamiert man da noch diese kleinen Fees.
So, jetzt haben wir ja schon so ein paar.
Weil man es kann, also bislang konnte. Das ist ja die einfache Sache.
Also ich glaube, das ist nicht Dreistigkeit.
Das ist eher so, man schaut, was geht und das hat Grenzen und diese werden jetzt
ein bisschen verschoben wahrscheinlich.
Also es ist wirklich crazy. So, jetzt haben wir ja mit iMessage und Apple Pay,
also der Wallet, schon zwei Produkte auf der Betriebssystemebene gehört,
von denen jetzt, wie wir eben schon, wie ich gesagt habe,
einen Clip hätte ich dazu nochmal gucken, dass in Europa gesagt wird,
es müssen alle Apps löschbar sein, alle austauschbar sein.
Also die Diskussion, die das
DOJ hier gerade führt, führt die Europäische Union genau auf der Ebene.
Jede einzelne App wird jetzt hinterfragt.
Warum ist ja iMessage installiert und warum kann man nicht eine andere noch dazu installieren?
Warum ist hier der Safari-Browser installiert und nicht noch eine andere gleich
mit oder eben am Anfang gar nichts?
Warum ist hier iMessage drauf und anderes nicht? Warum funktioniert iMessage?
Also jede einzelne App wird auf ihre Weise hinterfragt.
Und jetzt haben wir ja eben schon festgestellt, Kevin Ruse, Casey Newton,
die New York Times, alle finden total überzeugend, das iMessage,
das Stigma, die Funktionsweise, der ganze Kram ist fragwürdig.
Und dann kam Alex Kantowitz und hat gesagt, also das verstehe ich ja gar nicht
bei iMessage, da schadet sich doch Apple selbst, da brauchen wir keine juristische
Klärung, das löst sich über die Zeit oder wie auch immer.
So, bei Pay sind alle einmütig und sagen, ja, ja, das ist totaler Quatsch,
dass sie da ein Monopol, wie ist das jetzt bei der Apple Watch?
Die findet jetzt nicht als Software auf dem Gerät statt und ist da austauschbar,
sondern es ist so eine Interaktion zwischen zwei Geräten, aber das eine ist
total abhängig von dem anderen.
Also man erweitert sozusagen das Hardware-Ökosystem seiner selbst und so.
Was ja Sinn der Sache war.
Was Sinn der Sache war.
Denn sonst hätte man sich ja eine andere Uhr kaufen können.
Genau, man könnte einfach eine Garmin-Uhr oder die Schweizer hätten auch mal
eine Chance, sich so ein bisschen ihren Uhrenmarkt zu digitalisieren und Angebote zu machen.
Ein digitaler Rolex.
Zum Beispiel, wer weiß, es gibt doch elektrische Porsches mittlerweile.
Ja, stimmt. Also in der Hinsicht, wir wollen mal nichts ausschließen.
Wir wollen ja, dass diese Innovation ausprobiert jetzt wieder ein Testfeld bekommen. kommen.
Bei der Watch, von den Sprechern, die wir jetzt gehört haben in der New York
Times, beim Big Technology Podcast und bei Hardfork, ganz ambivalent,
ob das jetzt wichtig ist oder nicht, ob es da großen Handlungsbedarf gibt.
Wir fangen mal an bei Hardfork.
Ja, ich glaube, das ist ein sehr guter Ansatz.
So, Casey Newton findet so ein paar Punkte, über die man diskutieren könnte,
aber Kevin Newton so, naja, Kevin Rose, keine Ahnung, ob man das jetzt,
die haben das als Platz 4 in der Anklage, ich würde das noch nicht so hoch ranken,
also da gibt es noch andere Sachen,
während sie vorher aber die iMessage-Sache so wichtig fanden,
jetzt kommt Alex Kantrowitz, der vorher die iMessage-Sache nicht so wichtig
fand und jetzt plötzlich die Uhr aber ganz wichtig.
Dass Smartwatches nicht gut bezahlen, zu dem iPhone.
Und das ist wirklich ein Schaden. Wenn du eine Smartwatch-Familie bist,
und du kannst nicht gut bezahlen, weil Apple den Apple Watch hat, das tut weh.
Und es ist wirklich exklusiver Verhalten.
Das ist eine Bereich, wo ich sage, okay, ich stimme wirklich mit dem DOJ hier.
Ja, dieses Pairing. Also wenn ich mich für ein Telefon entscheide,
habe ich mich für ein Telefon entscheiden.
Ich trage nicht zwei in der Tasche, nur weil die Uhr mit dem anderen Gerät besser funktioniert.
Hier würde man jetzt in diesem Kontext sagen, Apple muss einfach einsehen,
dass die Uhr ein anderes Gerät ist als das Telefon und das Telefon muss standardisiert
mit allen Anbietern gleich kommunizieren.
Da braucht man einen Standard für, wenn eine Mitteilung auf der Uhr auftaucht,
muss man da antworten können, egal über welches Gerät das abgewickelt wird.
Oder die Uhr macht es vielleicht sogar ganz selbst.
Okay, bis zu einem gewissen Punkt wird man das wahrscheinlich ganz gut connecten
können und hat das aus Gründen nicht getan, aber ich könnte mir schon vorstellen,
dass durch diesen engen Zusammenschluss von Apple macht das Smartphone etwas sehr gut funktioniert,
was dann vielleicht mit irgendeinem anderen nicht geht.
Also das ist eine Argumentation, die kann ich jetzt wenig nachvollziehen,
wo ich einfach sagen würde, naja, dass das eine mit dem anderen so zu tun hat.
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass es jetzt allzu viele Leute geben wird,
die dann mit zwei verschiedenen Systemen da rumrennen wollen.
Aber ist das, ich versuche gerade ein anderes Beispiel zu finden und mir fällt
jetzt keines ein, wo man auch so eine Verbindung herstellt und dann.
Ja, das ist beispiellos, was Apple da geschaffen hat. Ich finde zum Beispiel auch.
Ja, aber ist das, aber das ist doch nicht schlimm. Also da muss ich einfach
sagen, ja, dann ist das aneinander gekoppelt.
Nee, nee, nee. Also ich habe jetzt eine Apple Watch.
Du würdest jetzt, wenn du jetzt eine andere, sagen wir mal, es gäbe jetzt eine
andere Watch, die mit der gleichziehen würde.
Die vor allem schöner aussieht.
Die schöner aussieht. Dann würdest du die kaufen unter der Voraussetzung,
dass die ganz genau so gut connected ist mit deinem Smartphone.
Für mich ist ganz profan. Ich hätte erstens gerne eine runde Uhr,
hat Apple nicht im Angebot.
Ich hätte zweitens gerne eine Uhr, bei der ich, wenn ich Nachrichten bekomme,
auch die Bilder sehe, die mir geschickt werden. Und wenn ich eingestellt habe,
dass ich sehe, wo meine Kinder sind, möchte ich diese Anzeige auch auf der Uhr
haben und nicht nur auf dem Telefon.
So, also der Umgang mit Nachrichten alleine und dass ich diese Wo-Ist-App nutze
und gucke, wo sind die Kids.
Sind die zwei Sachen, die mir sagen, nee, das kannst du mit deiner Garmin-Uhr
nicht machen, die mir ansonsten, was Sport und so weiter angeht,
sehr viel weiterhilft als die Apple Watch.
Deswegen habe ich mich für die Apple Watch entschieden. Und das halte ich für
ein echtes Problem. Problem.
Es hat kein Anbieter eine Chance gerade, mir eine Uhr zu verkaufen,
weil mir diese zwei Funktionen wichtiger sind als alle weiteren Design- oder Sportentscheidungen.
Das glaube ich, aber jetzt könnte Apple sagen, gut, dann bieten wir das jetzt
an, das ist nur dann richtig teuer.
Hier geht es ja nicht nur einfach darum, dass man sagt, jedes Ladegerät sollte
gleich sein, dass man nicht für alles neue Stecker kaufen muss und und und.
Also solche Dinge, da würde ich sagen, das nimmt im Prinzip Pfennigsbeträge
am Ende, da versucht man wirklich irgendwas abzuschließen, was nicht sein müsste.
Aber, dass eine andere Smartwatch so gut interagieren kann mit deinem Apple-Smartphone,
das bedarf wahrscheinlich doch mehr als ein paar Programmatischen Griffe.
Nee, bedarf es nicht, weil wenn mir jemand per WhatsApp ein Foto schickt,
kriege ich das angezeigt, aber geblurrt.
Okay, aber die, ja gut, das ist natürlich gemein.
Das ist einfach nur bescheuert.
Ja, das ist natürlich gemein. Aber ich sage mal, wie jetzt mal von diesem Einzelfall
ausgehen, wenn man jetzt bedenkt, was das überhaupt alles kann in der Verbindung,
ja, also du trägst das ja auch als eine Erweiterung des Smartphones und du sagst
dann immer noch, ja, das Smartphone ist sowieso schon die Erweiterung meines Körpers.
Also dass das so wie ein Organ, das dazugehört, man braucht ein Herz,
man braucht noch eine Leber und das hängt aber alles so miteinander zusammen,
dass das so funktioniert.
Würde man das jetzt auf alles übertragen wollen, dann müsste Apple wahrscheinlich
einen sehr viel höheren Preis nehmen oder den Herstellern abverlangen, dass das geht. geht.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das hier einfach nur um Software und Standards geht.
Also Software ist halt Software. Es muss ja eh Software geschrieben werden.
Also das sind Designentscheidungen in der Software.
Und eben wir nutzen proprietäre Entscheidungen darüber, wie die Software funktioniert und keine Standards.
Ich meine, das Problem ist ja auch wieder, das wird sich wahrscheinlich von
alleine lösen, denn in meiner Uhr ist ja schon ein eigenes GPS zum Standort
bekannt geben und eine eigene SIM-Karte drin.
Das Das iPhone hing ja ganz lange am Computer und musste über iTunes synchronisiert werden.
Das ist ja jetzt schon seit 10 Jahren nicht mehr so. Die Uhr...
Braucht gerade noch das Telefon. Das wird aber in drei Generationen auch nicht mehr so sein.
Also da wird die Uhr auch ein eigenständiges Gerät, was dann für mich wieder
bedeutet, hoffentlich sind dann Messenger-Standards so weit,
dass ich wieder eine Uhr nach optischen Gesichtspunkten und nicht nach Funktionalität,
obwohl mir die Funktionalität ja wichtiger ist, aber ich hätte gerne standardisierte Funktionalität.
Aber man kann doch nicht alles haben. Ich kann doch nicht sagen,
ich hätte gerne eine Uhr.
Ich würde gerne einen Jaguar fahren, der soll aber einen Mercedes-Motor haben
und gerne das Navi von Porsche.
Also da mein Gegenargument ist einfach, einfach, die Uhr zeigt die Uhrzeit.
Und zwar nicht die, die sich die Uhr ausdenken oder was der Hersteller sagt,
das ist, sondern die Uhrzeit.
Also ich glaube niemandem, der eine Apple Watch trägt, dass es ihm in irgendeiner
Weise darum geht, die Uhrzeit an die Zeit zu bekommen.
Nein, ich wollte dir nur sagen, wie wichtig das ganze Gerät Uhr ist um den Standard die Uhrzeit gebaut.
Aber das ist ein Smartphone, das eine Uhrenform hat.
Ja, ich möchte gerne, dass alles, was auf der Uhr stattfindet,
nach Standards operiert, so wie die Uhrzeit. All meine Standards.
Der Hardforker, sagt, da gehen wir jetzt mal richtig rein. Auf der Uhr muss
nach allgemeinen Standards operiert werden, die wir definieren und nicht Apple einfach.
Und dann heißt es ja, das Pairing geht halt nur mit, das ist ja bei den Kopfhörern
auch, die AirPods Pro, die mit dem iPhone wunderbar funktionieren,
aber mit keinem anderen Gerät.
Das ist wirklich ärgerlich sowas, weil ich habe auch noch andere Geräte,
mit denen ich gerne mal was hören möchte.
Und dann bin ich daran gefesselt, dass mein 280 Euro Kopfhörer wirklich nur
mit dem, ja, klar, Apple hat als erstes gesagt, wir machen keine Kabelverbindung
mehr, damit sie genau diesen Log-In-Effekt dann machen können.
Ich habe Kopfhörer für 20 Euro mit einem Kabel und die kannst du überall reinstecken.
Sehr gut, wir gratulieren dir zu diesem Kauf. Die New York Times erklärt diesen
Log-In-Effekt via Uhr recht gut.
Ja, da steckt auch einfach dieses nicht
nur ökonomische Ich-will-nur-eine-Uhr-haben-und-nur-ein-Telefon-System.
Und ich möchte selber darüber entscheiden, welche jeweils diese.
Abhängigkeiten da sind. Wie gesagt, ich bin sehr gespannt, ob man das Risiko
eingehen will, Apple erheblich zu schwächen in Bezug auf die geopolitischen Faktoren.
Denn man geht ja sowieso mit Apple schon ziemlich hart um. Also ich bin verblüfft darüber.
Man lässt sie komplett alle Profitmargen durch dieses Wir-Produzieren-in-China
durchgehen, selbst unter Trump.
Ja, man kann, also es ist auch eine der mächtigsten Firmen überhaupt und wichtigsten
Firmen überhaupt für die USA.
Aber ich finde angesichts dieser Konfrontation mit China ist es schon erstaunlich,
dass man eine so harte Konfrontation wählt.
Das macht man ja zum Beispiel in Deutschland nicht, wo die Autoindustrie mindestens genauso wichtig ist.
Und dass man da so auf Konfrontation geht, obwohl man weiß, dass der Apple-Profit
ganz klar daher rührt, dass man in China produzieren lässt, das wundert mich schon.
Und dass man jetzt Apple auch nochmal von dieser Seite angeht, finde ich erstaunlich.
Bin ich gespannt, ob sich das durchsetzt oder ob man doch am Ende so sagt,
naja, aber geopolitisch ist es dann doch besser, wenn wir so einen Megakonzern
haben und den nicht allzu sehr schwächen.
Ja, also das sind alles Erwägungen, die vor allem in den Talks hinter der Bühne
eine Rolle spielen Apple telefoniert ja auch sehr viel mit der EU,
jedenfalls gab es Nachjustierungen,
nachdem die Software dann draußen war und ein bisschen mehr restriktiert wurde als,
das vorher vom Gesetz eigentlich und dann einfach so ein Blame Game wurde dann
so gespielt, wer ist jetzt für was verantwortlich und dann hat man sich da auch,
auf kurzem Dienstwege ein bisschen mehr geeinigt Ähm,
Tim Cook verbrachte seinen Tag ganz interessant, als in Amerika die Anklage veröffentlicht wurde.
So, er flüchtet nach China an dem Tag, damit er bloß nicht, wir werten gerne
ein Statement von Tim Cook, nee, der ist gerade in Shanghai.
Und jetzt hat er nochmal darauf hingewiesen, ja in Europa auch.
Wir hören nur kurz rein, wie im Deutschlandfunk, dass in der Tageszusammenfassung,
dass auch die in Europa nicht nur gegen Apple jetzt vorgehen.
Drei Schwergewichte der Digitalwirtschaft nimmt die EU-Kommission gleichzeitig ins Visier.
Allen dreien wird vorgeworfen, sich an die Verpflichtungen des Digital Market Acts nicht zu halten.
Dieses Gesetz, das Anfang März in Kraft getreten ist, definiert sogenannte Gatekeeper,
Torwächter also, die durch ihre schiere Größe die Macht haben,
festzulegen, zu welchen Bedingungen private User und andere Unternehmen Zugang
zu den digitalen Märkten haben.
Dem Google-Konzern Alphabet wird vorgeworfen, eigene Produkte bei der Google-Suche zu bevorzugen.
Mit dem Mutterkonzern von Facebook und Instagram wird vorgeworfen,
User auf unzulässige Weise zur Freigabe ihrer persönlichen Daten zu zwingen.
Und bei Apple lautet der Vorwurf, dass bestimmte Apps von den Telefonen des
Konzerns nicht gelöscht werden können.
Ja, kommt so ein bisschen unscheinbar daher, aber alle Apps stehen zur Disposition,
müssen löschbar sein, womit klar ist, Apple kann seinen eigenen Service und
Produkte dann nicht mehr anbieten auf der eigenen Infrastruktur,
die man ja für teuer Geld verkauft.
Mal gucken, wie das da weiter getrieben wird. Dass es parallel läuft,
finde ich wirklich sehr interessant.
Also dass sich die beiden prozessierenden DOJ und EU gegenseitig beobachten
können, wie es beim anderen gerade vor Gericht läuft.
Das ist so eine richtig schöne Klammer, die sich da um Apple.
Und als letzten Hinweis, ich finde es wirklich wahnsinnig interessant,
dass das jetzt gerade passiert,
während alle von Apple erwarten, dass zum Beispiel jetzt im Juni bei der neuen
Entwicklerkonferenz die große AI-Wende auch bei Apple stattfindet.
Und es auch droht, dass sie dort nicht kommen kann.
Sondern, dass Apple dann wieder sagt, wir vertrauen auf unsere Marktmacht und lagern das aus.
Liebe Investoren, glaubt uns, das ist der richtige Weg.
Und bisher war es ja so, bei der Suche hat man sich auf Google verlassen und
obwohl Android von Google ein Konkurrenzangebot zum iPhone ist,
ist es Google, glaube ich, pro Jahr 18 Milliarden Dollar oder so wert.
Die Suche auf Android-Telefon, also die.
Default Search, wenn man jetzt ein neues Gerät in Betrieb nimmt und man macht
einfach um in der Adresszeile vom Safari Browser eine Suche,
dann ist es einfach über Google.
Und das ist bisher Google 18 Milliarden wert, da auf dem iPhone präsent zu sein.
Vielleicht ist das jetzt auch eine Zäsur, in der wir erleben werden,
dass Apple sagt, wir schaffen es nicht alleine und wir mieten uns jetzt aber bei OpenAI ein.
Also wir zahlen OpenAI dafür, dass es umgedreht, dass es Siri klüger wird.
Also da könnten die Profite deutlich sinken für Apple und die Ausgaben erheblich steigen,
weil das war ja so eine Rente, die man da bekommen hat von den anderen und von
der Brille redet kein Mensch mehr.
Ne, man hat ja auch nur so und so viel hergestellt. Wahrscheinlich auch nur,
um Meta zu zeigen, falls es bei euch ein Erfolg wird, haben wir das bessere
Modell. Wenn auch dreimal so teuer.
Ich hatte ja jetzt auch meine erste Virtual Reality Experience zu SIPT in so
einem gemeinsamen Raum. Wir haben so ein paar Spiele gespielt.
Ganz nett, aber ich halte es für den Alltag nicht mal als Kinoleinwand überzeugend
eigentlich. Eigentlich bin mir noch nicht so ganz sicher.
Also es gibt so ein paar berufliche Kontexte, wo ich es, glaube ich,
ganz interessant finde.
Aber solange das nicht wie in Westworld Folge 1 Staffel 3 ist,
die wir ja besprochen hatten, wo in der ersten Szene telefoniert wird mit einer
ganz normalen Brille und das Gegenüber und man versteht gar nicht.
Achso, der war gar nicht hier.
Erst als er die Brille absetzt, sieht man, er hat quasi telefoniert.
Solange wir da noch so weit entfernt sind, dass wir uns so eine Schiebrille auf...
Glaube ich nicht, also keine Ahnung, kann natürlich Überraschendes passieren,
aber die nächsten fünf Jahre droht da glaube ich nichts an der Front.
Oder, und damit mache ich eine Überleitung, die Wirklichkeit ist dann so grau,
dass nur noch wie in Ready Player One die virtuelle Welt uns retten kann,
dann jedoch für die Leute, die diese Brille besonders brauchen,
ist sie viel zu teuer, denn wir sprechen jetzt über Armut in Deutschland,
wir haben jetzt eben über erste, zweite Klasse gesprochen,
wir reden hier also von vielen Leuten, für die kommt beides nicht in Frage,
die sind sehr schlimm dran und wir werden jetzt Zahlen präsentiert bekommen,
kommen, die einen ja nicht überraschen, aber doch, wenn man sie hört, immer wieder umhauen.
Ulrich Schneider hat den Armutsbericht vorgestellt in der Bundespressekonferenz.
Es war wieder eine besonders kurze Bundespressekonferenz. 28 Minuten hat sie gedauert.
Es waren wenige Journalisten da und man merkt dann auch, wer wird geschickt.
Vermutlich irgendwelche Praktikanten und Volontäre. Man hat sich dann nochmal
von Ulrich Schneider sagen lassen, dass dass die Lohnpreisspirale vielleicht
nicht unser größtes Problem ist, wenn wir einen höheren Mindestlohn haben.
Also es war absurd, bringen wir hier gar nicht. Aber man hat dann auch wieder
gesehen, okay, mediales Interesse ist gering, obwohl man sagen könnte,
ja, bei den Zahlen, das geht doch so viele Menschen in Deutschland an,
denn sie sind betroffen.
Unseren Armutsbericht 2024 vorzustellen, wie jedes Jahr basiert er auf den Daten
des Statistischen Bundesamtes, das ist genauer die Daten des Mikrozenses,
die nun als sozusagen im Endstadium für das Jahr 2022 vorliegen.
Mit denen konnten wir also arbeiten, mit denen konnten wir weiterrechnen und
Ihnen heute den Bericht vorstellen zur Lage in Deutschland unter Armutsmöglichen Gesichtspunkten.
Wie sieht die Lage nun aus?
Die Armutsquote hat in 2022 zumindest schon mal nicht weiter zugenommen. Das ist gut so.
Allerdings liegt sie mit 16,8 Prozent, nur 0,1 Prozentpunkte hinter dem Ergebnis aus dem Vorjahr.
So dass man auch nicht von einem wirklichen Rückgang sprechen kann,
sondern eher von einem statistischen Flimmern.
Die Armutsquote ist sehr hoch.
Flimmern.
Man kann fast fragen, wie sehr sollte sie auch noch steigen,
denn die Zahlen sind erschreckend.
Die Armut in Deutschland ist auch in 2022 auf sehr hohem Niveau verblieben.
14,2 Millionen Menschen waren in diesem Jahr armutsbetroffen.
Das sind 100.000 mehr als im Vorjahr und fast eine Million mehr als im Jahr
2019, also vor dem Beginn von Pandemie, Energie- und Preiskrise.
Und er kann auch die Entwicklung von etwa 18 Jahren überschauen?
Und es sind 2,7 Millionen arme Menschen mehr als im Jahr 2006.
Das ist das Jahr, an dem der Armutstrend in Deutschland einsetzte,
von dem ab wir feststellen müssen, dass die Armut fast jährlich zunimmt.
2,7 Millionen arme Menschen mehr in Deutschland seit dieser Trend 2006 einsetzte.
2006, als ich kürzlich mit Journalisten verglich, dass wir eine Geburtenrate
haben wie zuletzt 2009, meinten die so, 2009, was war denn da?
Also habe ich nochmal erklärt, Lehman ist pleite gegangen und so weiter.
Deswegen will ich es hier nochmal explizit machen, für alle,
die jetzt sagen, ja 2006, Fußball-WM, nein.
2006 ist, Merkel bildet ihre Regierung und regiert ab dann durch.
Wir haben drei Millionen mehr Arme und die Zahl der Millionäre hat sich verdoppelt.
Das ist die Merkel-Bilanz.
Und wir können uns überlegen, wird das besser?
Wenn man sich die Rahmendaten für 2023 ansieht, also Arbeitslosenquote,
Bruttoinlandpunkt und anderes, kann man zumindest nicht davon ausgehen,
dass wir hier den Beginn einer Trendwende haben.
Sonst ist eher eine vorläufige Stagnation auf diesem hohen Niveau.
Und wer jetzt gerade so ein bisschen verwirrt ist, warum redet der viel von 2022 und dann von 2023?
Also man hat alle Daten, die man benötigt, um diesen Armutsbericht zu erstellen, erst von 2022.
Und jetzt hat man aber schon ein vorläufiges zu 2023 und er sagt,
das wird sich nicht groß ändern dadurch.
Durch und wir haben sehr viel in solchen Zusammenhängen über den Osten geredet.
Ich will heute aber mal nicht über den Osten und Armut und Niedriglohnsektor
und alles da reden, sondern wir blicken heute mal nach NRW, das bevölkerungsstärkste
Bundesland und das war mir in dieser Weise nicht klar.
In Nordrhein-Westfalen hat die Armut seit 2006, als dieser Trend einsetze,
um 42 Prozent zugenommen.
Zum Vergleich im Bundesdurchschnitt waren es gerade mal 20 Prozent.
Das heißt, in Nordrhein-Westfalen ist die Armut gerade mal doppelt so schnell
gewachsen wie im Rest der Republik.
Hinzu kommt nämlich eine regionale Sache.
Es gibt in NRW das Ruhrgebiet.
Das Ruhrgebiet ist ganz klar die armutspolitische Problemregion Nummer 1 in Deutschland.
Und daran hat sich auch 2022 nichts geändert. Das Ruhrgebiet zeigt nach wie
vor eine exorbitant hohe Armutsquote mit 22,1 Prozent.
Nun könnte man sagen, na gut, Bremen hat 29 Prozent, aber Bremen hat 680.000 Einwohner.
Das Ruhrgebiet ist mit 5,1 Millionen Einwohnern der größte Ballungsraum Deutschlands.
Und von diesen 5,1 Millionen Einwohnern im Ruhrgebiet leben über eine Million
in Armut. Deswegen ganz klar, Ruhrgebiet bleibt leider traurigerweise die Armutsregion
Nummer eins in unserem Land.
Das finde ich, sollte man, also diesen Clip sollte man sich nochmal bereitlegen
für alle Diskussionen zum Thema Landtagswahl in Ostdeutschland.
Es ist hier das Ruhrgebiet und nicht Ostdeutschland. Die Renten sind jetzt angeglichen und so weiter.
Sollte man die eine oder andere Sehgewohnheit mal überprüfen mit ihr.
Wer ist denn eigentlich davon betroffen, von dieser Armut?
Die Gruppen, die am stärksten von Armuts betroffen sind, sind die,
die es auch im Vorjahr waren, die es in den letzten Jahren waren.
Es sind vor allen Dingen Alleinerziehende und kinderreiche Familien,
Erwerbslose, Menschen mit schlechten Bildungsabschlüssen und ohne deutsche Staatsangehörigkeit.
Wir kommen jetzt gleich auf diese Kategorie nochmal zurück, denn erstmal könnte
man ja da auch noch vielleicht ein konservatives Narrativ draus stricken.
Aber lassen wir es erstmal so stehen, gehen wir nochmal weiter.
Einen neuen traurigen Rekordwert kennzeichnet die Kinderarmut in Deutschland.
Da haben wir mittlerweile einen Wert, der war bisher so noch nie da,
seit gemessen wird, von 21,8 Prozent aller Kinder und Jugendlichen,
also mehr als jedes fünfte Kind und jeder fünfte Jugendliche,
die derzeit von Armut betroffen sind.
Also mein Vorschlag ist, direkt nach dem Armutsbericht hören wir die Nachrichten,
Linne-Mansche und Lau-Mansche Aufarbeitung zum Thema Raus aus der Armut.
Können wir gerne machen. Bevor wir da Christian Lindner Also wir müssen noch
Christian Lindner hören und dann wird uns auch nochmal sehr viel klar in Bezug darauf.
Ja, also mehr also jedes fünfte Kind und wir haben natürlich.
Ab jetzt 2024, wir müssen Kinder jetzt immer kollektiv verbuchen.
Wenn dann es immer heißt, ja das ist aber schade für die Familien,
nee, das ist nicht schade für die Familien, für die ist es auch schade.
Aber so wie Michael Friedmann sagt,
wir müssen mal auf die Fremden unter ökonomischen Gesichtspunkten,
also selbst er macht dieses Argument, müssen wir jetzt auch sagen,
nee, Kinder sind nicht Kinder und es tut uns leid, dass sie ein schlechtes Leben
haben, sondern die Kinder sind unsere Rentenbezahler.
Ja, es sind Investitionen. Kinder sind Investitionen. Und man kann eigentlich
sagen, man kann als Staat nichts falsch machen, wenn man möglichst viel in Kinder investiert.
Also das DEW sagt Faktor 7, Return on Investment. Faktor 7, gute Sozialisation
führt zu sehr viel Produktivität.
Alleinerziehende.
Unter Alleinerziehenden lag die Armutsquote bei sage und schreibe 43,2 Prozent in 2022. 22.
Also für dein Familienbuch auch nochmal eine gute Zahl, dass man sich da auch
schon fast sagt, also jede zweite alleinerziehende Person ist arm.
Alleinerziehende brauchen kein,
wie soll man sagen, Persönlichkeitsentwicklung, Selbstentwicklungsprogramm über YouTube oder sowas.
Geld. 42% heißt, das ist einfach Schicksalsgemeinschaft, das ist herangetragenes
Schicksal, dafür kann man gar nichts.
Also das ist einfach, bei solchen Zahlen wird es unhintergehbar,
das ist ein politisches und gesellschaftliches Versagen und nicht irgendwie
der Einzelne hat es verbockt oder so.
Jetzt hat Schneider eben schon aufgezählt, wer von Armut betroffen ist und wir
gehen jetzt aber nochmal auf diese Frage zurück.
Und einen letzten Punkt will ich auch hervorheben aus unserem Bericht,
weil dieser politisch sehr wichtig ist.
Wir haben uns auch angeschaut, wer sind eigentlich diese 14,2 Millionen Armen?
Denn da gibt es häufig Missverständnisse und dann gibt es auch häufig falsche
politische Ableitungen.
Also wenn ich auch diese Zahlen nochmal, 14,2 Millionen Arme,
das ist Prozent. Das ist einfach so, Wenn jetzt immer so dieses Loblied gesungen
wird, bald haben wir wieder ein Fest der Demokratie, wenn alle wieder wählen können und so weiter.
Für die Leute, das ist so weit weg.
Also die erleben den Staat nur als gängelnden Staat, als nichts anderes eigentlich.
Also der Staat, während wir dann immer so Tagesschau gucken sollen,
brav die Nachrichten, manifestiert sich für diese Leute der Staat im Amtszimmer,
wenn sie ihm gegenüber sitzen und ihm komplett ausgeliefert sind.
Also jetzt haben wir diese Unionsdiskussion, du wirst uns ja gleich was spielen,
diese Arbeitslosen, die alle nicht arbeiten wollen, wo kommen wir denn da hin? Hören wir mal hier.
Wenn man sich anschaut, wer sind diese 14,2 Millionen, wie setzen die sich zusammen,
dann stellen wir beispielsweise fest, dass lediglich 6 Prozent der erwerbstätigen
Armen arbeitslos sind. Nur 6 Prozent.
Stattdessen sind zwei Drittel etwa der Erwerbstätigen arbeitslos.
Die volljährigen Armen sind entweder Rentnerinnen und Rentner oder erwerbstätig.
Das heißt, wenn man schon typisieren will, dann muss man sagen,
Armut, das sind Menschen im Ruhestand und Armut, das sind Erwerbstätige zu zwei Drittel.
Ja, Arm trotz Arbeit, hört, hört, merken wir uns für nachher,
wenn es heißt, die Totalverweigerer.
Da müssen wir jetzt mal ran.
Und dazu kommen natürlich 20 Prozent der Armen, die Kinder sind.
Das sind die Gruppen, um die man sich kümmern muss, wenn man Armut tatsächlich bekämpfen will.
Er sagt es nochmal deutlich, Arm trotz Arbeit.
Wir betonen das deshalb, weil wir heute diese Diskussion haben,
dass es bei der Bekämpfung der Armut lediglich darauf ankäme,
Menschen in Arbeit zu vermitteln, Menschen in den Arbeitsmarkt zu integrieren.
Nochmal, damit erreichen sie lediglich, wenn sie alle erreichen,
sechs Prozent der armen Bevölkerung.
Er macht dann sehr viele Vorschläge, die wir aber in dem Sinne kennen,
die wir jetzt nicht nochmal alle hier spielen, was man gegen Armut tun könnte.
Umverteilung ist da ein Stichwort nur. Und wir hören uns aber jetzt noch einen Aspekt hier an.
Und deswegen sagen wir, die Rentenversicherung muss umgestaltet werden zu einer
echten Bürgerrentenversicherung.
Das heißt, alle zahlen ein und alle zahlen mit allen Einkommen ein.
Nicht nur mit dem Einkommen aus Erwerbstätigkeit, auch Einkommen aus Vermietung,
auch Einkommen aus Kapitalerträgen.
Alle Einkommen werden zur Berechnung des Beitrags herangezogen.
Und dann wäre auch die Frage, ob man wirklich neben das Äquivalenzprinzip nicht
ein Solidarprinzip setzen soll, wie es etwa die Schweizer machen.
Arbeit, also wenn man ein christlicher Mensch ist, darf man es Menschen nicht
verwehren, an Gottes Schöpfung mitzuarbeiten.
Das passt jetzt dann sehr gut zu dem tollen Christian Lindner Podcast.
Klimageld führt ja auch noch an.
Wir brauchen ein Klimageld. Das darf nicht mehr länger auf die lange Bank geschoben werden.
Es ist am 1. April der Tag, wo die Mehrwertsteuer wieder erhöht wird auf Gas.
Das wird gerade kleine Einkommen ganz erheblich belasten.
Neu belasten und wir brauchen hier die versprochene im Koalitionsvertrag versprochene
Kompensation, gerade für die kleinen Einkommen.
Ja, wir haben jetzt hier nochmal diese Zahlen präsentiert bekommen und wir sehen
jetzt hier ja die Leute, die als arm bezeichnet werden oder armutsbetroffen,
wie auch immer dann gerade die Terminologie ist.
Das heißt aber auch alle, die darüber sind, sind nicht reich.
Also bis wir dann mal in eine Liga kommen, wo man sagt, gut für die ist die
Überlegung da, ach lege ich noch 20 Euro drauf und fahre erste Klasse,
da ist schon ein ganz großer Sprung wieder.
Das heißt, es wird in Deutschland generell sehr wenig verdient.
Und wir haben zugleich die immer weiter vererbten Vermögen, die wachsen und wachsen und wachsen.
Und das sieht man dann im Übrigen auch daran, ich kann das so in meiner Nachbarschaft
ein bisschen beobachten, da ist jemand, der in einem unglaublich großen Haus
mit seiner Frau und einem Kind eingezogen ist.
Und ich weiß, was der beruflich macht und ich denke, dass der so etwa 2000 netto
oder so nach Hause bringt, das ist nicht schlecht.
Aber natürlich könnte der sich niemals dieses Haus leisten. Naja,
die Familie ist reich, man hat mehrere Häuser und dann haben die Söhne auch
jeder ein Häuschen jetzt bekommen mit Blick auf den Rhein und so weiter.
Und man denkt so, ja klar, und die werden dann nochmal einen großen Batzen erben.
Insofern ist jetzt deren Einkommen eher so das Taschengeld.
Also alles ist schon bezahlt und dann hat man halt 2000 Euro im Monat zur freien
Verfügung und dann kommt man natürlich sehr gut.
Man käme in Deutschland schon besser klar, wenn einfach die Wohnkosten nicht
mit 40, 50 Prozent da drin hingen.
Das würde in vielen schon so weniger Kopfzerbrechen im Alltag bereiten.
Aber allgemein kann man sagen, also Einkommen,
Ich fand es ja auch erstaunlich, dann in der alten Republik das mal so aufzuschreiben,
aber die Vermögensfragen entscheiden sich am Vermögen.
Das wird durch Einkommen von niemandem auch, die Top-1-Prozenter spielen da keine Rolle.
Ja, du hast ja eben gesagt, Top 1 Prozent, da ist man so bei 8000 netto und
wir hören jetzt mal jemanden zu, den ich mal wahrscheinlich dazuzählen würde,
also wir hören jetzt rein in die Sendung von Thaddeus und die Beobachter heißt
die glaube ich, da ist jetzt Claudius Seidel, den ich als Feuilletonist und
Filmkritiker schätze, aber ich verstehe nicht,
was da in diese Leute fährt.
Also der war 20 Jahre Feuilleton-Chef der FAS.
Der schreibt Bücher, der ist in Talkshows, der ist da regelmäßig oder ist ständiger
Gast in dieser Sendung von Thaddeus.
Wir müssen uns wahrscheinlich finanziell um ihn keine Sorgen machen.
Und dann hört man solche Äußerungen jetzt in Bezug auf Ukraine und wie wenig
Deutschland sich engagiert und all das.
Er hat, und weil sie wie Hajo argumentiert, ist in sich schlüssig,
bleibt aber so in der Immanenz derer stecken, die sagen, naja,
da ist dieser Krieg in der Ukraine,
aber eigentlich hat er mit uns nichts zu tun.
Beziehungsweise in dem Moment, wo er anfängt, unseren Alltag,
unsere Wirklichkeit zu berühren, zum Beispiel damit, dass wir für diese 300
Milliarden, die eigentlich notwendig sind, Opfer bringen müssten.
In dem Moment wollen wir von diesem Krieg nichts wissen.
Damit werden wir aber mit Putin nicht fertig werden.
Mit dem, so quasi mit dem, mit so einem halb fiktionalen Blick,
da ist halt dieser Krieg, der ist interessant, wir schicken da auch was hin,
aber er hat nicht den Wirklichkeitsstatus unserer Rechnung an der Tankstelle.
Ja, aber der Wirklichkeitsstatus der Leute,
die wenig haben und das muss noch nicht mal so wenig sein, als die,
die Schneider jetzt gerade da beschrieben hat, sondern die in einem mittleren
Einkommen sind, für die hat das eine ganz entscheidende Wirklichkeitskomponente,
wenn die plötzlich 100 Euro mehr für Energie ausgeben müssen oder für ihre Mobilität,
weil sie zum Arbeitsplatz kommen müssen.
Und da kann man nicht dann sitzen und sagen, ja das muss man jetzt,
da muss man auch mal Verzicht üben und so weiter.
Ja das kann man da machen, wo das nicht spürt. Wenn man Feuilleton-Chef einer
großen deutschen Zeitung ist, dann wird das einem völlig egal sein,
ob der Strompreis 100 Euro mehr oder weniger ist.
Und ich kann nicht begreifen, dass man, man muss doch mal, also man hat die
Statistik, man hat ja auch Augen im Kopf, sieht andere Menschen,
man muss doch da mal darüber hinaus gehen.
Und ich würde genau, aber einen Begriff, und das zeigt wieder,
dass er ein guter Feuilletonist ist, aufgreifen, nämlich halbfiktional.
Halbfiktional. So wie über...
Und wie die Leute sich mal verhalten sollen und wie sie verzichten sollen, geredet wird.
Das ist halb fiktional, weil man nicht wahrhaben will, wie die tatsächliche
ökonomische Realität aussieht.
Und halb fiktional ist auch das, was wir bei Claudia Major, Masala und wie sie alle heißen erleben.
Also man redet mal so über den Krieg und alle Podcaster aus der linksliberalen
Blase, die schließen sich dann mal so an, ja der soll mal liefern und die Ukrainer
wollen kämpfen und die sind alle so mutig und so.
Das ist genauso halbfiktional, man sitzt nämlich so da, ja also ich selbst,
also toll, dass die da so mutig kämpfen. Also ich gucke da am Ende auch nur
den Film und halte mich dann aus all dem raus.
Insofern halbfiktional, guter Begriff, sonst eher schwierige Einordnung.
Ich finde das eh schräg. Und das ist ja auch eine Überleitung zu diesem CDU-Semantik-Geplänkel.
Alle Institute sagen uns, die ärmere Hälfte der Bevölkerung hat nichts.
Also da hat man einfach ein Lohnkonto.
Da wird dann am Anfang des Monats Geld draufgezahlt. Am Ende des Monats ist
alle und dann kommt ein neuer Monat. Und das ist so der Rhythmus.
So betrifft 40 Millionen Deutsche.
Wenn man jetzt sagt, wir haben ein übergroßes Problem. Krieg, Klima.
Warum spielen die da überhaupt eine Rolle, diese 40 Millionen?
Das ist doch völlig absurd.
Also in Deutschland gibt es 20 Billionen Euro Privatvermögen.
Und darüber kann man ja auch diskutieren. Nur das hat mit der Hälfte der Bevölkerung nichts zu tun.
Also wenn man hier irgendwen irgendwas wegnehmen will oder was umstrukturieren
oder eine neue Finanzierungsrunde oder was auch immer, dann braucht man die
gar nicht im Blick nehmen.
Also das ist einfach, man kann ja einfach sagen, okay, wir wollen aber die Sachen
jetzt auch mal geregelt kriegen.
Wir lassen die einfach außen vor. So, die zerstören das Klima nicht.
Klima wird durch diesen Servicekonsum zerstört, Fliegen, dieses ganze Zeug und beim Krieg genauso.
Wenn man jetzt dringend Geld brauchen würde und man sagt, gut,
ich versuche mal in meinem Freundeskreis, vielleicht leidt mir jemand was,
geht man dann zu den Ärmsten?
Ja, man weiß doch genau, wo man nicht fragen muss.
Sagt man da, guck mal, kannst du mir zwei Euro geben, wenn ich aber eigentlich
2000 brauche oder geht man zu dem, wo man sagt, gut, für den wird es kein Problem sein?
Sehr, sehr, sehr schräg. Also wie redet die CDU, nachdem sie jetzt ihre Grundwertekommission
und der ganze Kram, ihr Neues und so.
Und Carsten Linnemann hat dieser Tage den ganz großen Aufschlag gemacht.
Deutschland befindet sich in einer Krise. Die Bundesregierung hat in unseren
Augen keinen Plan, wie wir aus dieser Krise herauskommen.
Und deshalb wollen wir an einem Plan arbeiten.
Wir wollen zeigen und darstellen, was wir besser machen. wollen nicht nur meckern,
wollen ganz konkret sagen, was sind unsere Konzepte, was wir besser machen als die Ampel.
Dazu bereiten wir eine Agenda 2030 vor, ein Gesamtkonzept.
Wow.
So, wie findest du die Authentizität der Ankündigung, in der angekündigt wird,
dass eine Ankündigung kommt, dass man jetzt etwas plant, weil ja die Ampel nichts tut?
Ja, das hört sich schon nach Tun an jetzt bei der CDU.
Passt, ja. Ja.
Ja, also es wird die ganz große Nummer. In der Fragerunde wurde dann noch aufgeworfen,
Agenda 2030, so wie er das dann nennt, schließt ja an, Agenda 2010 und so weiter.
Wie groß ist es jetzt wirklich zu denken?
Die Agenda 2010 war eine Arbeitsmarktreform. Die Agenda 2030,
so unser Arbeitstitel, wird eine breite Reform sein, wo natürlich auch das Thema
Energie, Steuern, Fachkräfte, Bürokratie und vieles mehr Niederschlag findet.
Wir haben einen Plan für Deutschland.
Kann man dann nicht auch einfach so als Pressevertreter so geschlossen aufstehen
und sagen, gut, ist jetzt Quatsch, wir gehen jetzt Kaffee trinken?
Ein paar Trollfragen, aber es ist, ja.
Oder man geht, oder die machen, die kündigen diese Pressekonferenz an, man geht aber nicht hin.
So wie damals, es war Michelle, die damals verkündet hat, dass sie nicht mehr auftritt.
Ja, das ist ja inzwischen schon sieben Mal, sieben Comebacks gehabt.
Aber da hat die dann auch so eine große Pressekonferenz angekündigt.
Da waren, glaube ich, zwei Journalisten da, weil alle anderen sagten,
ja gut, dann singt sie halt nicht mehr. Macht ja nichts.
Ja, in dem Fall ist es leider so, dass anders als bei Ulrich Schneider am Anfang
gesagt werden musste, sorry, wir hatten das Konrad-Adenauer-Haus eigentlich
schon für heute Abend umgebaut, wir wussten nicht, dass jetzt so viele Journalisten kommen.
Also Lindemann hat sie irgendwie alle nochmal da hingekriegt.
Nun gut, also wir haben eine Agenda 2030. Während die Agenda 2010 ja nur den
Arbeitsmarkt geht, geht es jetzt hier um alles.
Ich denke, die Agenda 2010 ging um alles, aber gut. Es ist also hier viel größer
und jetzt ist die Frage, was ist der Ausgangspunkt?
Was ist der Kern des Kerns? Was ist diese CDU pur, die uns immer versprochen wird?
Und ein zentraler Baustein dieses Konzepts ist die neue Grundsicherung.
Wir werden das Bürgergeld in der jetzigen Form abschaffen und werden eine neue
Grundsicherung schaffen.
Wir werden ein gerechtes System schaffen, in dem wir vor allen Dingen für die
Menschen da sind, die Hilfe bedürfen, vielleicht sogar noch mehr als heute.
Und auf der anderen Seite werden Menschen, die arbeiten können,
auch arbeiten gehen müssen, ansonsten entfallen Sozialleistungen.
Das ist gesunder Menschenverstand, das ist CDU pur und das ist Kern des Kerns
dieses neuen Konzeptes, neue Grundsicherung.
So, wir haben ja jetzt im Salon schon Schirits Text gelesen,
diese Bürgergeldempfänger, wer sind die denn?
Naja, zur Hälfte arbeiten sie, ein Viertel sind sie Kinder, es sind so ein Prozent,
die irgendwie so total verweigern, keine Ahnung.
Die sind bei ihm jetzt Kern des Kerns, das ist der Grundpfeiler der ganzen Agenda 2030.
Alles orientiert sich, ist ausgerichtet auf diese Totalverweigerung,
irgendwelche Leute missbrauchen den Staaten.
Wir sagen also, 40 Millionen Menschen werden in solchen Diskussionen,
haben die nichts zu suchen und er sagt jetzt, ne die Ärmsten der 40 Millionen
sind der Kern des Kerns, um die muss man sich jetzt kümmern.
Also dieses Wettern gegen Totalverweigerer.
Ich habe mir auch verschiedene Systeme angeschaut, auch in den Niederlanden,
Dänemark, auch in Japan und alle Systeme, die gut laufen weltweit,
laufen eigentlich gleich,
dass man auf der einen Seite für die Menschen da ist, die Unterstützung brauchen
und auf der anderen Seite das Fordern ernst nehmen.
Und da haben wir einen neuen Punkt, dass wir eine verbindliche Kooperation wollen.
Die derzeitige Kooperation zwischen dem Staat und dem Bürgergeldempfänger ist
unverbindlich. Diese soll in Zukunft verbindlich sein.
Und wir wollen für Totalverweigerer einen neuen Passus einführen,
nämlich wir gehen davon aus, dass Totalverweigerer keine Unterstützungsleistung benötigen.
Er versucht aber so souverän wie Christian Lindner aufzutreten.
Das ist sein Vorbild. Das ist sein Vorbild. Er hat die Rhetorik-Schule auf YouTube
wahrscheinlich, die die ganzen Studenten da für Christian Lindner machen,
um darzustellen, dass er der größte Redner aller Zeiten ist.
Versucht er zu übernehmen. Wir lassen uns davon nicht ablenken.
Wir machen einen innerlichen Exkurs. Denn die Frage ist,
er hat so einen Arbeitsmarkt vor Augen, bei dem noch Lücken sind.
Er möchte die gerne auffüllen.
Nun sagen wir, ja, ja, die kann man auch vielerlei auffüllen,
also man könnte, keine Ahnung, die, sage ich mal, vielleicht nicht so ganz kompatibel
für den Arbeitsmarkt total verweigern nehmen.
Wir haben zuletzt die NEEDS vorgestellt, die Not in Education,
Employment oder was auch immer sind, 630.000 junge Menschen,
die einfach nicht die richtige Ansprache bekommen haben.
Da jetzt Weltfrauentag war, hören wir hier auch mal kurz in die Presseschau
rein zum Thema Care-Arbeit, die natürlich pflichtgemäß am 7.3.
Im Deutschlandfunk, das war der Tag, gesendet wurde.
Zum morgigen Internationalen Frauentag schreibt die Süddeutsche Zeitung,
für Frauen in Deutschland ist es auch im Jahr 2024 ein berufliches und finanzielles
Risiko, ein Kind zu bekommen.
Mütter verbringen an die 40 Stunden pro Woche mit unbezahlter Sorgearbeit,
also mit Putzen, Kinderbetreuen, Kochen.
Weil kaum ein Mensch daneben noch Vollzeit erwerbsarbeiten kann,
arbeitet jede zweite Frau in Deutschland in Teilzeit. Das Handelsblatt mahnt
konkrete Änderungen an.
Das Ehegattensplitting gehört abgeschafft. Das Betreuungs- und Bildungssystem modernisiert.
Der Gender-Pay-Gap, also die Lohnlücke zwischen Frauen und Männern, geschlossen.
Und Kinder sollten endlich keine reine Frauenangelegenheit mehr sein,
sondern eine gesamtgesellschaftliche.
So, jetzt sagt der Linnemann also...
Totalverweigerer geben uns das Signal, sie brauchen den Staat nicht,
damit haben sie alle Ansprüche verwirkt.
Das ist sozusagen das neue Verhältnis zwischen Bürger und Staat.
Jetzt kommt hier so eine Presseschau, die sagt, naja, zum Weltfrauentag stellen
wir mal wieder fest, ganz schön viele Menschen machen ganz schön viele Arbeit,
die man auch staatlich organisieren könnte mit einigen Synergieeffekten,
wird aber nicht gemacht.
Bei Fluta kam gestern über Instagram so eine Kachel laut Statistischem Bundesamt
mal durchgerechnet 500 Milliarden Euro. Euro wären bei Mindestlohn an Lohnzahlung
fällig, wenn man mal die ganze Care-Arbeit institutionalisieren würde.
Wenn man die nicht Mindestlohn, sondern etwas höheren Betreuungs- und Pflegersätze
nehmen würde, wären es schon 700, 800 Milliarden Euro.
Das könnte man ja von Linnemann auch erwarten, ja, also wenn du einen Arbeitsmarkt
auffüllen willst mit Frauen, die beispielsweise in Teilzeit arbeiten,
dann investiere doch mal 500 Milliarden, Milliarden, damit er einfach frei ist,
auf dem Arbeitsmarkt tätig zu werden.
Der Präsident der Deutschen Industrie- und Handelskammer, Peter Adrian,
war beim Table-Podcast am 14.03.
Zu Gast und hat es mal sehr interessant durchgerechnet, wenn man Frauen,
die heute in Teilzeit stecken, und wir reden hier von 10 Millionen.
Einfach nur zwei Wochen Arbeitsstunden ersetzt. Also man kümmert sich um deren
Care-Arbeitsverpflichtung, beispielsweise durch Mobilisierung dieser Gelder,
wie eben genannt, und käme sie dafür in den Arbeitsmarkt.
Wie viele äquivalente Vollzeitkräfte hätte man denn dann?
Frauen in unserer Gesellschaft werden schlechter bezahlt, aber vor allen Dingen
deshalb schlechter bezahlt, weil wir nach wie vor die Situation haben,
dass viele oder viel zu viele in Teilzeit sind.
Also wir müssten Frauen die Chance geben, aus der Teilzeit rauszukommen.
Nur zwei Stunden mehr Arbeit bei denen Teilzeit beschäftigen würde uns im Schnitt
pro Woche 500.000 Vollzeitarbeitskräfte pro Jahr ergeben.
Das heißt, da steckt ein Rieseneffekt drin. Das heißt Betreuung,
Kitas, Infrastruktur. Genau, trotz guter Kita-Gesetz funktioniert die Kinderbetreuung
in Deutschland nicht zufriedenstellend für die jungen Familien.
So, wenn Lindemann das Pferd richtig aufzäuben würde,
würde er einfach den Staat als soziale Infrastruktur aufrüsten,
der dafür sorgt, dass nicht 600.000
Menschen nach ihrer Ausbildung in der Schule, die verpflichtend ist,
einfach versacken in der Unsichtbarkeit.
Plus er könnte über, okay, dann ermöglichen wir den Frauen einfach zwei Stunden
mehr die Woche für ihre Lohnarbeit tätig zu sein.
500.000 Arbeitskraftsequivalente.
Also man wäre schon bei einer Million insgesamt, nur an diesen beiden Stellschrauben.
Aber nein, es muss hier der Totalverweigerer irgendwie mobilisiert werden.
Ich will mal noch etwas hinzufügen, nämlich wir haben diese Debatte jetzt gerade
über 30 Stunden Woche, 35 Stunden Woche, Arbeitszeitreduktion,
geht das überhaupt angesichts der wirtschaftlichen Lage?
Ich will das jetzt hier nicht durchdeklinieren, aber ich will einen Punkt bezogen
auf die Care-Arbeit mal bringen.
Sehr viele Frauen sind ja in Care-Arbeit deshalb, weil es anders in Teilzeit
deshalb, weil sie sich meistens um die Care-Arbeit kümmern und.
Das führt dann dazu, dass sie von Altersarmut und all dem betroffen sind.
Wenn jetzt die Vollzeit, die Vollarbeitszeit sinkt, sagen wir auf 35 Stunden
oder auf 30 Stunden, dann ist es also sehr viel leichter, den Sprung von der
Teilzeit auf die Vollzeit zu gehen.
Zugleich reduziert sich auch, und es sind in dem Fall ja dann meistens die Männer,
die arbeiten, auch weil es den Pay Gap gibt,
haben diese Männer auch mehr Freizeit dann, um zum Beispiel Care Arbeit zu übernehmen.
Das heißt man könnte also mit dieser vier Tage Woche oder wie sie dann ausgestaltet
ist, gar nicht so große Produktionsverluste,
wie das jetzt von vielen ausgemalt wird, in Kauf nehmen müssen,
sondern es wäre vielmehr so, dass der Anreiz steigt in die Vollzeit zu gehen,
weil man nicht ganz so viele Stunden erbringen muss und weil der Partner zu
Hause ist und auch drei, vier oder acht Stunden mehr Zeit hat für die Care-Arbeit.
Und diesen Effekt sollte man wirklich mal sich sehr genau vor Augen führen,
ob nicht gerade eine Reduktion der Arbeitszeit eine Produktivitätssteigerung bedeuten könnte.
Wolfgang, das ist alles viel zu klug. Wir müssen uns jetzt wieder runter transferieren.
Ich bin ja auch nicht in der CDU.
Wir sind ja bei der CDU. Wir hören das soziale Gewissen. Ich glaube,
wir hören jetzt einen Spruch von Karl-Josef Laumann.
Es funktioniert ein Sozialstaat, wie wir uns in den letzten 75 Jahren den geschaffen
haben, immer nur aus einem guten Verhältnis von Solidarität auf der einen Seite
und Eigenverantwortung auf der anderen Seite.
Und das Bürgergeld ist ausgeschlagen, zu sehr in die Frage der Solidarität und
zu wenig in die Frage der Eigenverantwortung.
Wir haben eben Ulrich Schneider gehört, also in der Merkel-Ära,
du hast es ja nochmal genau benannt, 2006, während dieser Merkel-Ära haben wir
knapp drei Millionen Arme in Deutschland mehr.
Wer war da jetzt unsolidarisch?
Also, 43% der Alleinerziehenden, 95% der Fälle sind es einfach Frauen, leben in Armut.
So, sie leben in Armut, weil sie den ganzen Tag mit Care-Arbeit zu tun haben,
die es ihnen nicht ermöglicht, Vollzeit zu arbeiten, für Lohnarbeit.
Das bedeutet, Deutschland macht sich hier einen schlanken Fuß,
verzichtet auf die Investitionen von 500 Milliarden Und macht einfach so eine,
die CDU ist ja eine christliche Partei, betende Handbewegung,
dass am Ende von 20 Jahren, in denen das Kind in diesem Armutsverhältnis mit
der Mutter lebte, dann Produktivkraft für die Volkswirtschaft kommt.
So. Diese 500 Milliarden sind eins
zu eins umrechenbar in, das ist ein solidarisches Verhalten der Mutter.
Sie könnte ihr Kind auch einfach, warum muss sie sich mit dem Kind befassen?
Ja. So.
Dass er jetzt hier kommt und sagt, das Pendel ist in die falsche Richtung ausgeschlagen.
Zu viel Solidarität, zu wenig Eigenverantwortung. Während wir gleichzeitig so
eine 500 Milliarden Rechnung pro Jahr bekommen, wo es heißt,
nee, der Staat kommt ja seiner Verpflichtung nicht nach.
Finde ich einfach grotesk. Und das ist das soziale Gewissen der CDU.
Das ist ja der Typ, der die ganze Zeit immer vorgeschickt wird.
So der Letzte, der noch übrig ist, nachdem Norbert Blüm, Geisler usw.
Das ist Karl-Josef Laumann. Also es ist wirklich grotesk.
Jetzt schießt man sich auf die Totalverweigerer ein. Die sind eigentlich gar
kein relevanter Begriff. Wo kommt das her?
Die Frage ist es denn möglich, dass man Totalverweigerer die Leistung entzieht?
Und diese Frage ist ganz klar zu bejahen. Die Entscheidung, an der man diese
Frage messen muss, ist eine Entscheidung des Bundesverfassungsgerichts vom 5.
November 2019, die sogenannte Sanktionsentscheidung, wo Karlsruhe zu entscheiden
hatte, ob die Sanktionen, die im SGB II vorgesehen sind,
rechtmäßig und mit dem Grundgesetz vereinbar sind.
So, also zu viel Solidarität wird genutzt von Totalverweigerern und hier haben wir Rainer Schlegel,
der als Gastredner bei der Veranstaltung und den vorherigen Präsidiumssitzungen
und so, ehemaliger Vorsitzender des Bundessozialgerichts jetzt sagt,
naja, das ist halt so eine aus der juristischen Urteilsfindung des Bundesverfassungsgerichts.
Ich sage, ja klar, die müssen das halt definieren, dass es sowas gibt,
um den Randbereich operabel zu machen für die Politik.
Aber das hat in der öffentlichen Debatte nichts zu suchen, weil für den Totalverweiger
gibt es faktisch kein sinnvolles empirisches Korrelat.
Außer zu sagen, ja, jeder hundertste Bürgergeldempfänger ist ein Totalverweigerer.
Nur das ist halt so ein brenzliger Fall, da muss man sich überlegen.
Was soll denn eigentlich dann genau mit denen geschehen? Also die bekommen gar nichts mehr?
Ja genau, also die haben damit verwirkt, wenn man ihnen eine Arbeit anbietet.
Das heißt, wenn die dann verhungern, dann verhungern die, oder was?
Genau, wir kommen gleich auf die, was ihr wem zugemutet wird und so zu sprechen.
Nun bauen sie noch so ein anderes Argument. Wenn die CDU nicht den Sozialstaat
schützt, indem sie den Bürgergeldempfänger an die Kandare nimmt,
dann kommen andere, die den ganzen Sozialstaat zerstören.
Es ist also nicht die CDU, die den Sozialstaat zerstört, sie will ihn eigentlich schützen.
Es gibt immer mehr Menschen, die sich die Frage stellen, ob das alles noch richtig ist, was jetzt ist.
Und wir möchten nicht denjenigen Vorschub leisten, die am Ende die Grundsicherung zerstören wollen.
Und deswegen ist es wichtig, bevor das Problem entstanden ist,
mit einer Idee zu kommen, wie man sich denn dieses System auch für die Zukunft sicher machen kann.
Das ist so, wie wir schubsen Flüchtlinge zurück ins Meer, damit nicht am Ende
Rechte kommen und sagen, wir schubsen Flüchtlinge zurück ins Meer.
Das ist die Aktion von Joachim Gauck. Der hat ja ein ganzes Buch jetzt darüber geschrieben.
Wenn wir hier die Flüchtlinge zulassen, dann handeln wir uns Ärger ein und damit
wir dann später nicht Entscheidungen treffen müssen, die uns wehtun als gute Menschen,
müssen wir die Flüchtlinge jetzt dem Mittelmeer übergeben. Das ist im Grunde die Botschaft.
Gitta Connemann versucht uns das jetzt auch nochmal zu erklären.
Die CDU muss den Totalverweigerer zerstören, damit nicht die AfD kommt und sagt,
seht ihr, das ganze Sozialsystem funktioniert nicht.
Wenn wir fordern und fördern, nicht wieder einführen, wie wir es vorgeschlagen
haben, dann wird die Akzeptanz der Bevölkerung, und das zeigen uns jeden Tag
ja auch Anschriften, die wir bekommen,
für zu, in diesem Fall auch zum Teil,
zu hohe Sozialleistungen sinken und es werden radikale Kräfte gestärkt,
die unseren Sozialstaat letztlich auch grundsätzlich zerstören wollen.
Das finde ich auch ganz interessant, dass wir ja von der AfD viel,
viel weniger zu diesem ganzen Hickhack um Bürgergeld hören, als von der CDU.
Die CDU spielt die ganze Zeit das Thema und sagt, das ist der Kern des Kerns
und das Schlimmste überhaupt.
Ich sage jetzt einfach, wir wollen ja die AfD zerstören oder weghaben und damit
ist alles erlaubt, feuerfrei.
Wir können jedes Argument, was wir jemals machen wollten, einfach unter dem
Deckmantel, ansonsten regiert hier die AfD.
Das erinnert mich ein bisschen, als Cem Özdemir die Zuckersteuer einführen wollte,
die besonders hohe und so weiter, dass dann irgendwer von diesen Verbänden da
kam und meinte, ne, also so hart zuletzt reinregiert wurde im Dritten Reich.
Ah ja, ja.
Also von dem Deutschlandfunk einfach so gesendet. So, Laumann jetzt zu dieser
Frage, ja aber Totalverweigerer, spielt das jetzt auch strukturell eine Rolle
oder ist das hier ein reines Semantik-Theater?
Laumann erklärt uns jetzt, wie viele Totalverweigerer es gibt.
Also das Thema Totalverweigerer, deswegen steht es auch so drin mit Totalverweigerer,
ist eine ganz, ganz kleine Zahl.
Aber ein riesen Aufriss gemacht.
Ja, das ist natürlich blöd, wenn ich jetzt einfach aus der 50.
Minute der Pressekonferenz das schon mal nach vorne ziehe und sage,
es ist eine ganz, ganz kleine Zahl. Wir reden hier im Grunde jetzt über nichts.
Also die Totalverweigerer.
Linnemann freut sich, er stellt ihn uns hier nochmal vor, Rainer Schlegel.
Ich freue mich auch, dass der ehemalige Präsident des Bundessozialgerichtes
in Kassel, Herr Rainer Schlegel, uns hier unterstützt.
Und der greift das nämlich selber auf und da könnte man ja zumindest sagen,
ja gut, noch aus Praxisgesichtspunkten irgendwie.
Es gibt eine kleine Anzahl von Menschen, die das anders sehen und die sich nicht
so verhalten, wie das Gesetz es eigentlich erwartet.
So, einem Juristen gestehe ich das zu. Ja, ich würde ja mal sagen.
Er hat mit den Randgebieten zu tun.
Ach, Sie meinen bestimmt die Multimillionäre, diese kleine Randgruppe, die alles anders sieht.
Ja, das können wir gleich am Gitterkonnemann diskutieren. Aber dass ein Jurist
auf der Bühne steht und sagt, ja, die Randbereiche, ja klar,
du bist der Jurist. Du musst dich darum kümmern.
So, als Polizist wirst du nochmal dahin gerufen, wo gerade der Unfall passiert
ist und üblicherweise wird dir gesagt, halt dich da mal fern.
So, und als Feuerwehrmann gehst du genau zu dem Haus, das brennt.
Und so ist das bei so einem Sozialgerichter eben auch. Der guckt sich genau
diesen Fall an, der eben aus der Rolle fällt.
Und ich meine, das Ganze geht nur so, also man muss ja jetzt mal erklären,
welche Strategie hat die CDU da jetzt eigentlich, wenn sie selbst weiß,
es ist eine ganz, ganz kleine Gruppe.
Nun, es geht darum, dass man generell Druck aufbaut auf alle, die arbeiten. Genau.
Also wenn du mal in Bürgergeld fällst, dann wird dir überall mitgespielt,
deswegen akzeptiere den niedrigen Mindestlohn und komm ja nicht auf die Idee,
denn wir hatten ja jetzt einen sehr erfolgreichen Arbeitskampf,
komm ja nicht auf die Idee, dass du auch so ein Kram machen kannst wie die GDL.
Ja, also ich sehe das hier auch an dieser ganz großen Wende.
Wir werden demnächst, deswegen wird auch diese Rentenreform nicht ganz unbedeutend,
zumindest was die Zäsur, die sie markiert, ist.
Wir laufen, das hat Heil auch nochmal gesagt, in diese 7 Millionen Defizite rein.
Die Leute werden diktieren können, unter welcher Maßgabe sie arbeiten.
Und die Unternehmen werden den Sozialstaat ersetzen. Du wirst deine Wohnung
und deinen Kindergartenplatz von deinem Arbeitgeber einfach bekommen.
Man hatte ja früher die Werkskindergärten, Werkswohnungen und damit haben ja
schon die großen Player, ich glaube auch zur BASF und so, wirklich die großen
Player für die Leute, die sie dringend brauchen,
haben sie das ja auch schon alles möglich gemacht und wir organisieren ihnen den Umzug.
Ja, dein Recruiting bei Siemens irgendwie läuft total schief,
wenn du immer Leute beim Vorstellungsgespräch hast, die dann anrufen und sagen,
ich fange an, wenn ich eine Wohnung habe.
Und das bedeutet für Siemens, ja nie. Die kommen einfach nicht nach München.
Also ich weiß von einer Dame, die ein tolles Angebot hatte für die Schweiz, für Zürich.
Und da war ganz klar, sie ist auch Mutter, da war auch ganz klar,
wir organisieren in den Amt, wir machen das und das und das.
Also da ging es noch gar nicht um das eigentliche Gehalt, sondern erstmal so
die Infrastruktur machen wir dann schon mal.
Ja, also da ist relativ wenig Marktwirtschaft noch, sondern da läuft jetzt auf anderen Ebenen.
Wir lassen mal Rainer Schlegel Rainer Schlegel sein. Er betont natürlich auch,
dass die Akzeptanz hier diskreditiert wird und damit das Gesamtsystem wankt.
Gitta Connemann, wir hören hier mal eine Minute 36 zu.
Vielleicht verstehst du, was sie uns sagen will. Es ist, sie bringt in Sachen
Sozialstaat, Totalverweigerung und so weiter alles durcheinander.
Weil am Ende zur Zeit der Sozialstaat auch Fehlanreize bietet.
Und das ist ja auch das Ergebnis der IFO-ZEW-Studie, die das BMAS selbst in
Auftrag gegeben hatte, das ja Anfang des Jahres vorgelegt worden ist.
Und die sehr deutlich sagt,
wir haben hier das Problem, dass ein steigendes Einkommen durch ein Abschmelzen
staatlicher Leistungen wie zum Beispiel Bürgergeld, aber auch Kindergeldzuschlag,
Wohngeld etc.
Und einer steigenden Steuer- und Sozialabgabenbelastung wieder aufgefressen wird,
sodass wir hier auch bei dem Punkt sind, dass es zunehmend Diskussionen vor
Ort gibt, lohnt es sich überhaupt noch, zu arbeiten. Und ...
Und ich komme jetzt am Wochenende von einem kleinen Betrieb,
den ich besucht habe, einen Metallbaubetrieb, der immer noch sehr gut zu tun hat.
Das ist die erste gute Nachricht, der aber inzwischen bei einer Viertagewoche ist.
Und wir reden über Nordwestdeutschland, also jetzt nicht Ballungszentren,
aber eine Viertagewoche inzwischen
hat, weil es nicht mehr ausreichend Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter gibt.
Dass auf der einen Seite und auf der anderen Seite die wachsende Zahl auch entsprechend
an Bürgergeldempfängern, wobei es sicherlich so ist, auch das in aller Deutlichkeit zu sagen,
dass nicht jeder Bürgergeldempfänger sofort in Arbeit vermittelt werden könnte.
Ja, nämlich nur ganz.
Ganz wenige Leute.
Ich komme nachher mit einem ähnlichen Beispiel um die Ecke und man kann sich nur wundern.
Aber da sind wir jetzt an so einem interessanten Punkt. Nicht nur Gitta Connemann glaubt das,
sondern ganz viele Leute in Deutschland und wahrscheinlich viele Unternehmer,
die jetzt zum Beispiel dein Buch nicht gelesen haben, die mit der Demografie
das noch nicht so ganz verstanden haben, die wundern sich auch und können sich
natürlich nichts anderes denken wie, naja, es wird wohl daran liegen,
dass das Bürgergeld zu hoch ist.
Ja, dieser O-Ton, ne? Hier in Frankfurt gibt es ja auch immer mal Veranstaltungen,
ich bin ja immer mal da, wo so, keine Ahnung, und dann sind ja relativ häufig
abends so die Unternehmer unter sich und so der ganze Kram.
Wir wettern hier auch oft gegen Unternehmer. Sie bereichern sich,
sie nutzen den Sozialstaat aus, wie auch immer.
Im konkreten Nahkampf alles nette Leute.
Belesen, haben Verantwortung, schlafen nicht gut und so weiter.
Also wirklich ganz normale, interessante Leute.
Ich stelle mir da manchmal vor, wie in diesen Runden so jemand wie Gitta Connemann auftaucht.
Die halten sich alle den Handfuhren Schädel und sagen, da kommt Gitta Connemann.
Bitte alle mal das IQ-Niveau jetzt runterfahren.
Sie versteht eh nichts. Wenn sie irgendwas sagt, einfach lächeln.
Diese Leute, diese CDU-Leute, die sich in ihren Gremiensitzungen irgendwie miteinander,
da ist auch keine Boshaftigkeit oder Intrigenz oder so dahinter.
Sie hat keine Ahnung, wovon sie spricht.
Eine gefährliche Schlichtheit, aber ich werde dir gleich einen anderen Unternehmer
zeigen und da ist das nicht schwarz und scharf.
Das teilt sich sehr auf. Ich glaube, alles, was da in diesem CDU-Kreis ist und
Und die, die damit zu tun haben,
die werden so denken und sagen, ja, das ist ja auch die Bürgergeldempfänger,
die liegen uns hier auf der Tasche und ich suche mir hier die Leute.
Also ich glaube, diesen Satz wirst du bei ganz vielen Unternehmern kennen.
Ich denke aber, und hier ist wieder der große Unterschied, auch hier,
du bist hier in einer sehr weltoffenen, internationalen Stadt wie Frankfurt,
die zudem auch noch mit Zahlen sehr viel zu tun hat.
Da hat man vielleicht auch mal selbst mal in der Statistik geblickt und gedacht,
naja, daran wird es wohl nicht liegen.
Solche Gitterkonnemanns kannst du hier nicht in Abendveranstaltungen bringen.
Nee, kannst du nicht machen.
Zum Gelächter wieder, weil die WhatsApp-Gruppen voll davon da sind.
Ganz, ganz, ganz schlimm.
Wo ist sie denn überhaupt?
MDB, zuständig für, keine Ahnung. Keine Ahnung, warum sie da reingewachsen ist.
Aber ist das NRW?
Ich glaube, man wollte eine Frau auf der Bühne haben, die CDU.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass ich zu schlichte Argumente über die CDU
mache. Ich glaube, Sie wollten einfach eine Frau auf der Bühne haben.
Ja, möglich.
So, wem wird hier was zugemutet? Herr Schlegel führt auf.
Am Ende des ganzen Urteils steht dann allerdings der Satz, dass derjenige,
dem eine Arbeit, eine zumutbare Arbeit angeboten wird. Es geht immer nur um zumutbare Arbeit.
Es geht nicht um etwas, was nicht zumutbar ist. Zumutbar im Sinne von gesundheitlich
zumutbar, im Hinblick auf seelische Gesundheit, körperliche Gesundheit,
im Hinblick auf Familie, auf Kinderbetreuung, auf sonstige Gründe abstellen.
Es muss immer zumutbar sein.
Etwas Unzumutbares wird nicht angeboten.
Da sind wir ja schon mal froh. Einherziehende müssen nicht die Kinder zu Hause
verhungern lassen, um arbeiten zu gehen. Da kann man nochmal schauen.
Und jemand, der schon den Rücken kaputt hat, der wird auch nicht mehr in die Mine gesteckt.
Ist auch gut von der CDU, dass sie sich so macht. die Expertise für die Selbstverständlichkeiten holt.
Also das muss zumutbar sein. Das 19. Jahrhundert ist also schon vorbei.
Darauf hat man sich jetzt mal geeinigt.
Genau, wir sind ja gar nicht im 19. Jahrhundert, wie du feststellst, sondern im 21.
Was ja bedeutet, die Unternehmen haben ja Ansprüche an ihre Mitarbeiter.
Es geht ja nicht darum, dass jemand sich ein halbes Jahr verschleißt und dann
einfach, ja gut, hätte auch drei Schippen mehr pro Schicht rausholen können aus der Kohlegrube.
Aber man hat ja gewisse Niveauansprüche.
Laumann kommt da auch mal drauf zu sprechen, dass es ja dieses Zumutbarkeitsargument
auch für die Unternehmen gilt.
Auch Jobcenter müssen für ihr Klientel bei der Wirtschaft werben,
dass man es auch mit diesen Menschen mal versucht.
Aber dann, wenn wir diesen Menschen eine Arbeit anbieten können,
dann müssen wir auch davon ausgehen, dass diese Arbeit angenommen wird.
So, ich habe das ja schon ein paar Mal betont, dass es jetzt diesen neuen Dreh
gibt, zu sagen, dass die Rentenkassen nicht jeden, der von den Arbeitgebern
einfach für die Rentenkasse angemeldet wird, akzeptiert wird,
sondern man dann sagt, nee, wir können ja auch ein Reha-Programm machen und
dann kommt der nochmal zurück zu euch.
Ja, ihr müsst mit dem noch ein bisschen produktiv sein. So, aufgrund dieser Knappheit.
Jetzt haben wir es hier aber mit diesen Totalverweigerern zu tun.
Wir haben es ja in mehreren Texten gelesen. Diese Menschen brauchen Hilfe.
Die sind nicht ohne Grund Totalverweigerer.
Die halten sich mit Absicht raus. Jetzt in diesem Gespräch mit Peter Adrian beim Table am 14.03.
Wurde das auch mal thematisiert. Es gibt ja offene Stellen und dann Menschen, die keine Arbeit haben.
Ist denn da ein Matching möglich? Wirklich, Maurice Höfgen betont das ja auch
immer wieder und an diesem Punkt habe ich mir auch schon mal deutlich widersprochen
und ich will es auch hier wieder deutlich machen,
nur weil wir offene Stellen haben, heißt das doch nicht, dass wir dann da dann
keine Migration oder sowas brauchen, also dass wir einfach eine Diskussion gegen
eine andere austauschen können.
Weil wir ja noch Arbeitslose haben.
Ja, ja, sie hat ja da gerade von diesem Metallunternehmen geredet,
die Konnemann, wo sie war.
Das ist ja eine sehr spezifische Ausbildung.
Alle Berufe sind sehr anspruchsvoll.
Ja, also wenn man sich zum Beispiel anschaut in der Pflege, welche Komplexität
dieser Beruf angenommen hat, mit was alles beherrscht werden muss.
Die haben immer so die Vorstellung, man lernt mal schnell jemanden an.
Das geht nicht, man kann jemanden anlernen, dass der ein Tablett hin und her
trägt oder so und dann wird das nach ein paar Wochen schon einigermaßen gehen
und dann wird es aber bei allen anderen Tätigkeiten ganz schwer.
Der Friseur, ich hatte ein tolles Gespräch, weil beim Friseur da saß neben mir
auch ein Herr und fragte dann meinen Friseur, ja, wenn du mir jetzt beibringen
solltest, dass ich auch Haare schneiden kann und du würdest das so ganz intensiv machen,
wie lange würdest du dann so brauchen dann dafür? Und dann meinte er, geht das in drei Wochen?
Und dann sagte der, nee, das wird so acht Monate dauern. Ja,
nasse Haare schneiden und zu wissen.
Wie sie trocken aussehen.
Ja, da müsste ich acht Monate ganz intensiv mich nur darum kümmern und dann
würdest du da da würdest du das so machen können.
Es ist überall. Wenn du ein gefließtes Bad verkaufen willst,
musst du das auch visualisieren können für den Kunden vorher.
Wie sieht es denn am Ende aus?
Du musst wissen, wo wir jetzt gerade sitzen, fand eine energetische Gebäudesanierung statt.
Man denkt so, ja gut, da werden Platten draußen dran geklebt.
Nein, hier wird irgendwie fünf
Wochen, sechs Wochen ist hier Action mit zehn Leuten an so einem Haus.
Es ist einfach alles sehr anspruchsvoll. Und jetzt hören wir mal von Seiten
der Industrie- und Handelskammer.
Und da ging es nur um das, dass, wenn hier Friseure zuhören,
sich wundern mit acht Monaten, ich habe doch eine längere Ausbildung,
da ging es nur ums Haareschneiden.
Also da waren noch keine Hochsteckfrisuren, was da so alles dabei ist.
Also alles, was wir tun, ist wahnsinnig kompliziert. Und entsprechend kompliziert
ist dann auch dieses Matching.
Wenn zwei Millionen offene Stellen auf zweieinhalb Millionen Arbeitslose treffen,
was läuft da gerade in diesem Land falsch?
Wenn Sie diese Zahlen betrachten, dann muss man sagen, da ist ein Matching wohl kaum möglich.
Das heißt, aus den zweieinhalb Millionen Arbeitslosen und können sie die zwei
Millionen offene Stellen nicht bedienen.
Ja, hier muss man sich einfach in die Rolle der verantwortlichen Unternehmer
setzen, die schon drei Leute angestellt haben und sich dann überlegen,
gebe ich jetzt 130.000 Euro für diese Person aus?
Ja. Und da kann einfach jeder mal in seine Arbeitsagentur gehen und gucken,
wer da morgens Schlange steht.
Einfach nur, ohne dass man da jetzt große Wertungen und so weiter,
diese Leute sind zu Recht verantwortlich.
Oder nicht so recht, sondern sie sind aus Gründen Feinde hier in die Kategorie Totalverweigerung.
Da hat sich auch der Staat total verweigert, sich um die zu kümmern.
Ja, wir haben ja auch da schon Ulrich Schneider in früheren Podcasts gehört,
wo er sagte, ja in Anbetracht der Corona-Maßnahmen, Schulen sind geschlossen
und so, werden wir viel, viel mehr Schulabbrecher haben.
Ist genauso dann eingetreten. Das sind also Leute, die sind aus dem System herausgefallen,
beziehungsweise die hat das System herausgetreten und dass die jetzt nicht da
irgendwo in der Schlange zu finden sind und sagen, wollen sie nicht Ingenieur
werden und die sagen, ja klar, komme ich doch gerade mit.
Ist ja völlig logisch.
Deswegen ist da wiederum die Sache, die Investition, die eigentlich hätte laufen
müssen, nämlich in die Kinder, in die Ausbildung und all das,
die ist schon in ganz vielen Bereichen nicht passiert und jetzt wundert man
sich, dass man das irgendwie nicht gematcht kriegt.
Die CDU kriegt es ja selbst nicht gematcht, also die CDU ist noch eine relativ
große Partei und die stellt uns solche Leute da auf die Bühne,
die da reden, dann denke ich mir auch, geht es nicht mit ein bisschen mehr Kompetenz.
Also die CDU besteht ja auch zu 80
Prozent aus Rentnern. Die hat ja selber Nachwuchssorgen, was das angeht.
Und die kann auch nicht sehr gut sozialisieren. Wir sehen ja,
wer auf die Bühne gestellt wird dafür.
Dann haben wir da so ein paar Laber. Also es ist wirklich gruselig.
Hören wir uns noch kurz an, wie die CDU über Arbeit an sich spricht.
Und deswegen ist eine gute Sozialpolitik, eine Sozialpolitik,
die die Menschen an die Hand nimmt, sie auch anleitet, wieder zu einem Leben
zu kommen, wo sie eine Aufgabe haben.
Und das ist natürlich im erwerbsfähigen Alter auch die Ausübung einer Berufstätigkeit.
So, der Staat nimmt also dem Bürger an die Hand und er führt sie zur Arbeit.
Das widerspricht allem, was wir hier besprochen und kritisiert haben.
Das findet einfach so nicht statt.
Laumann fabuliert noch so ein bisschen kreuz und quer zum Thema Arbeit.
Ich würde nochmal sagen, ich glaube, wir müssen einfach aus einer Debatte raus.
Dass Arbeit etwas Schlimmes ist. Arbeit ist eine entscheidende,
die Teilhabe an Arbeit ist eine entscheidende Frage, ob Integration gelungen ist.
Egal, welchen Menschen ich in dieser Gesellschaft integrieren will,
egal aus welchem Grund, ob behinderte Menschen, ältere Menschen,
zugezogene Menschen, Christus in der Arbeit, aber Christus nicht,
dass sie in die Arbeit kommen, ist die Integration, finde ich, immer unvollendet.
Und Arbeit ist, wir reden ja immer von zumutbarer Arbeit, von vernünftiger Arbeit,
von Leuten, die zumindest der Mindestlohn gezahlt wird, die Arbeitszeitgesetze
in diesem Land eingehalten werden, die wir ja auch kontrollieren und vieles andere.
Wo es vernünftig Urlaub gibt, wo es auch Urlaubsgeld gibt und all diese Dinge.
Arbeit ist ein Bestandteil des menschlichen Lebens.
Und wenn man ein religiöser Mensch ist, dann darf man keinen Menschen es verwehren,
an der Schöpfung Gottes mitzuwirken.
Und zu arbeiten. Wir sind eine C-Partei. Und da kann man nicht hingehen wie
bei Maschinen und Leuten Geld überweisen, damit sie ruhig sind.
Mit Menschen kann man nicht stilllegen.
Wenn ich eine Maschine nicht mehr haben will, kann ich sie meinetwegen stilllegen,
wenn ich es finanzieren kann.
Ein Menschen darf man nicht stilllegen. Und eine gute Sozialpolitik sorgt dafür,
dass die Menschen wieder Fuß fassen in einer solchen Welt.
So, Menschen kann man nicht stilllegen. Also da reintritt ins Rentenalter,
bei dem dir gesagt wird, sorry, wir haben hier kein weiteres Programm für dich,
wir geben dir einfach Geld.
Achso, du wolltest mehr, nee, wir haben nur noch 60% deines letzten Einkommens
für dich. So, wir müssen dich jetzt hier mal stilllegen. Du lebst noch 20 Jahre übrigens. jetzt.
Ach, du kommst aus der Schule und findest nicht weiter? Ja, ist uns egal.
Solange du nicht zum Amt gehst, soll doch das Statistische Bundesamt irgendwann
mal ausrechnen, wie viele Leute hier so unsichtbar verschollen sind. Ach so, 600.000.
Die CDU legt Leute still rechts und links. Und dann kommt er mit seinem Herz
sich tiefer fallen als Gottes Hände.
Am Werk Gottes mit.
Wir sind alle am Werk Gottes beschäftigt.
Also das, so kann es ja auch mal morgen vor so ein Amazon-Lager stellen und
sagen also, jetzt geht's wieder ran ans Werk Gottes.
Macht alle mit. Wir verrichten hier Gotteswerk. Die CDU macht so einen komischen
Aufriss mit dem Quatsch.
Ein Journalist sitzt in der ersten Reihe und stellt die einzig richtige Frage.
Zwei kurze Fragen. Braucht Deutschland
vielleicht auch eine Obergrenze an Bürgergeldempfängern, Herr Linnemann?
Ja, brauchen wir eine Obergrenze. Der 500.000. wird abgewiesen.
Also ich meine, Ich würde sagen, ja, wir brauchen eine Obergrenze.
Die liegt da, die ist dynamisch, die hat einen atmenden Deckel.
Menschen, die in Beschäftigung sind, dürfen kein Bürgergeld bekommen.
Wenn danach Krawall und Remedemi ist, weil der Arbeitgeber zu wenig zahlt,
ja, dann muss man das Problem mal lösen.
Genauso wie wir auch eine Obergrenze bei Wohngeldempfängern brauchen,
die muss nämlich null sein.
Wenn ein Vermieter sagt, meine Miete ist aber so und so hoch und es findet sich
keiner, der ohne Wohngeldunterstützung nie bezahlt, dann kann er sich ja nicht vermieten.
Ja, das ist wirklich so absurd, wenn man das mal bedenkt für andere Bereiche.
Also wir sind ja, wenn wir irgendwie einen Vortrag halten, dann nehmen wir ein Honorar.
Und jetzt stellt man sich irgendwie vor, wir nehmen einfach ein zu hohes Honorar
und der Veranstalter kann das nicht zahlen.
Und dann sage ich ja, dann muss die Bundesregierung rein. Dann muss die Bundesregierung
noch 300 Euro drauflegen.
Hauptsache, die Dividenden werden gezahlt. Er ist wirklich Banane.
Und Linnemann antwortet aber tapfer auf die Frage zur Obergrenze.
Sie haben ja die Lage am Arbeitsmarkt mehrfach angesprochen.
Über wie viel Arbeitslose weniger reden wir hier perspektivisch,
wenn Sie das 100% umgesetzt kriegen? Zur ersten Frage nein.
Und zur zweiten Frage, es geht um Akzeptanz. Ich möchte gerne,
dass nach der Reform die Bäckereifachverkäuferin weiß.
Dass Er antwortet jetzt noch so ein bisschen.
Ich möchte euch schon mal sagen, er hat ja diese Frage gestellt,
um wie viel Erleichterung reden wir denn?
Wie viele Leute kriegen sie denn in den Arbeitsmarkt? Haben sie das mal durchgerechnet?
Linnemann wird diese Frage nicht beantworten, Laumann und Connemann werden sie
aber gleich beantworten im Zuge.
Sie warten alle ab, bis Linnemann hier durch ist mit seiner Fabulierung.
Derjenige, der vom Staat Geld bekommt, es wirklich braucht, weil er bedürftig ist.
Und nicht wie heute, wo der eine oder andere das Gefühl hat,
dass ein System ausgenutzt wird.
Das ist aber dann nicht, Schuld hat dann nicht derjenige, der das ausnutzt,
sondern eher mehr oder weniger die Politik, weil es Anreize setzt.
Und diejenigen, die es ausnutzen, verhalten sich nur rational.
Also wir wollen ein gerechtes System. Das ist das Ziel.
Nein, kann man nicht. Kann man nicht? Für den Arbeitsmarkt. Kann man keine Zahl
nennen. Kann man nicht nennen. Also es gibt eine interessante Zahl.
Jetzt formuliert er einfach weiter. Die haben gerade gesagt,
das ist alles sinnlos, was wir hier machen. Man kann das gar nicht sagen.
Ich rede ein bisschen weiter.
Sie hat Herrn Middelberg genannt, dass wenn 100.000 in Arbeit kommen aus dem
jetzigen System, ist das ein Äquivalent zu drei Milliarden Euro Steuersparnis.
Und gleichzeitig gehe ich davon aus, dass wir schon den Anspruch haben müssen,
in solchen Bereichen zu denken und die Menschen wieder in Arbeit zu bringen.
Wir reden hier also nicht über ein paar hundert, sondern um mehr.
Also das ist irgendwie, wenn man dann einen Erbschaftsschall von 0,1 Prozent
macht, dann hat man etwa diesen Betrag, ja.
Wir reden hier nicht nur über ein paar hundert Menschen, hat er am Ende nochmal
gesagt, sondern über mehr. Könnten durchaus tausend total vorweiger sein in Deutschland.
Also das ist wirklich grotesk. Linnemann, zwei Clips zum Thema,
wie versteht er jetzt seinen Posten eigentlich?
Ist das Arbeit, was er da macht? Wie beschreibt er denn seine Arbeit?
Wenn wir uns jeden Tag Gedanken machen, mit wem wir unsere Politik durchsetzen
können, dann könnten wir uns unsere Arbeit sparen.
Würde ich mich lieber jetzt hier ins Café setzen und einen Kaffee trinken,
vielleicht einen Cappuccino und Zeitung lesen. Eine Partei darf nie in Kompromissen denken.
Eine Partei muss immer sagen, was würde sie machen, wenn sie die absolute Mehrheit hätte.
100 Prozent Union, CDU pur.
Und ich sage Ihnen ganz ehrlich, die Argumente...
Des gesunden Menschenverstandes liegen auf unserer Seite. Nach dieser Pressekonferenz
werden wir sehr viele Mails bekommen von Mitarbeitern in Jobcentern, die uns Recht geben.
Ja, das sind die berühmten Zuschriften, die kennen wir aus der CDU.
Annegret Kramp-Karrenbauer sitzt da. Viele Menschen schreiben mir,
sie hätten so gerne eine Dienstpflicht.
Viele Menschen werden sich bedanken, dass der gesunde Menschenverstand und Gottes
Werk dort wieder auf der Bühne Platz gefunden haben.
Es ist einfach grotesk. und die abschließende Lehre von ihm ist...
Und wir müssen in Deutschland einen Mentalitätswandel einleiten.
Das hört sich so abstrakt an.
Aber Wohlstand ohne Anstrengung ist eine Illusion. Gibt es nicht.
Ja, und wenn man jetzt denkt, das ist doch eigentlich gar nicht zu steigern.
Jetzt haben wir doch schon alles gehört.
Dann springen wir doch mal zu
Christian Lindner. Christian Lindner hat ja einen Podcast, der heißt CL+.
Und mir war aufgefallen, dass es diesen Podcast gibt.
Ich habe natürlich nie gehört. Dann schrieb mir ein Hörer, ich sollte mir doch
vielleicht mal diesen Podcast anhören mit Bulletproof.
Und es geht da um Abenteuer und um Militär. Das könnte für mich interessant sein.
Und dann habe ich das erstmal so aufgespart und dachte, oh Gott,
diesen Podcast mir anzuhören.
Ich werde bestimmt Qualen leiden. Und es war so. Es war wirklich ganz,
ganz schlimm. Aber wir gehen da jetzt durch und ich reagiere mich an den Clips
ab, aber wir können wirklich sehr viel Erhellendes hier nochmal mitbekommen.
Man wird verwundert sein.
Bulletproof ist ein YouTuber, Instagramer, Influencer, der Survival Training macht.
Wir haben hier schon mal Clips von ihm gespielt, als es darum ging,
wir müssen mal mit, ne der nicht, nicht der vom Rudel,
aber so jemand, der sagt, wir müssen jetzt hier mal wieder uns spüren,
wir gehen mal in den Wald, Männer,
raus, Abenteuer und dieser Bulletproof ist Elite-Soldat gewesen und hat eine
ständige oder immer mal wieder stattfindende Kooperation mit der Bundeswehr.
Denn uns war ja schon mal aufgefallen, die Bundeswehr lockt gerne so mit das
Abenteuer sucht. Wir waren auf der Gamescom, haben da diese großen Bundeswehr Städte gesehen.
Also Gamification und Survival spür dich mal wieder hinaus.
Da ist das Abenteuer, wie man das auch im britischen Militär schon gemacht hat.
Also diese Strategien übernimmt man jetzt, deswegen ist dieser Bulletproof inzwischen
so wichtig, dass er kürzlich auch in Hard Aber Fair stand und hat da nochmal gesagt, jetzt aber ran.
Ja, zum Thema Wehrbildung, wir haben heute kein Thema draus gemacht,
weil noch nichtiger als der Totalverweigerer ist der Soldat,
der in die Schule geht und irgendeinem Schüler irgendwas erzählt. Wir alle wissen, wie...
14-Jährige in der Schule so sind. Und dass die Bundeswehr 200 Offiziere hat,
die auch mal in eine Schule gehen, bedeutet, selbst wenn die Bundeswehr sich
richtig anstrengt, schafft sie es, jeden 70.000.
Schüler alle 10 Jahre mal zu erreichen damit. Für eine Unterrichtsstunde.
Es spielt also keine Rolle, würde ich sagen.
Naja, es müssen ja nicht nur die Offiziere gehen. Also bei uns war zum Beispiel
kein Offizier. Bei uns an der Schule war jemand von der Bundeswehr.
Und das war aber kein Offizier. Das war so mittlerer Dienstgrad.
Das war aber noch eine andere Mentalität. Ich bin mir heute alles nicht mehr
sicher. Also wir werden das jetzt uns anhören.
Und zwar denken wir nochmal darüber nach, wie arm Deutschland ist.
Wir denken daran, was eigentlich Krieg bedeutet.
Nämlich sterben. Und jetzt sehen wir aber, es gibt Nachwuchsmangel überall,
also auch bei der Bundeswehr und jetzt gibt es diesen Faktor Outdoor-Abenteuer-Leben
und kriegt man das nicht so miteinander verbunden,
kann man nicht über so einen Abenteuer-Diskurs eigentlich auch so eine Militarisierung herstellen.
Und wir beginnen mit der Anmoderation von Christian Lindner.
Heute werden wir nicht nur über Outdoor-Leben und Survival sprechen,
sondern auch über Unternehmertum, über die Gründerszene, über die Bundeswehr und ja.
Denn dieser Mann hat inzwischen natürlich auch ein Riesenimperium da errichtet.
Klang ein bisschen übersteuert. Hat er das übersteuert?
Der hat das so übersteuert.
Wahrscheinlich hat dieser Podcast Christian Lindner nur 50.000 Euro gekostet
für irgendeine Agentur statt 100.000.
Möglich.
Ob man das mit dem Übersteuern nochmal ordentlich macht.
Möglich. Jedenfalls ist also dieser, der heißt eigentlich Bulletproof Otto-Gerd
Karasch, ist also ein großer Unternehmer jetzt inzwischen. Wir werden mal sehen,
wie weit das schon da gegangen ist, dieses Unternehmertum. Und wir hören weiter.
Mein Gast ist ehemaliger Elite-Soldat, mittlerweile Weltenreiser,
Abenteurer, Content-Creator mit Millionen Reichweite und Unternehmer.
Otto-Gerd Karasch ist hier, vielen besser bekannt unter dem Namen Otto Bulletproof.
Otto Ballett-Proof. Cool.
Also so ein Mann, ich denke, Mitte 40 wird er sein.
Also körperlich so ein Fitness-Prepper.
Ja, der geht dann sehr lange irgendwo in die Wälder und macht Videos darüber.
Und ja, wir hören mal rein.
Was mich immer schon so gereizt hat, also wirklich in einer absoluten unberührten
Wildnis zu sein. Das war letztes Jahr das größere Abenteuer in Kanada,
wo ich mich mit einem Freund habe echt aussetzen lassen.
In den Northwest Territories, wirklich nirgendwo, ohne Essen,
Waffe dabei, Angelsachen dabei.
Und dann gucken, wie weit kommen wir hin. Und eine Vorbereitung,
das heißt, ihr jagt, ihr fischt alles selbst.
Wir sind hier in der, man könnte sagen, apolitischen Sphäre.
Denn erstmal ist das irgendeine Leidenschaft, die hat jemand.
Wäre jetzt nicht mein Ding.
Ich hoffe, dass ich in meinem Leben nie wieder in ein Zelt muss.
Ich habe das schon als Kind nicht gemacht. Man kann es sich denken.
Ich weiß noch, wie ich dir ein Foto schickte, wie ich in einer Hängermatte hing
und du mir Grüße aus dem Steigenberger Köln zurückgeschickt hast.
Ja, ich fühle mich grundsätzlich in Hotels doch besser aufgehoben als im Zelt.
Aber jeder soll ja machen, was er will.
Wir sind also wie gesagt erstmal in der nicht politischen Sphäre.
Und das kann auch mal schief gehen sowas, dass man vielleicht dann sagt,
oh, hätte ich gedacht, hier ist mehr Wild vorhanden oder mehr Fisch.
Aber gehört auf jeden Fall dazu. Und so eine Vorbereitung, naja,
kann natürlich zehren aus einer langen Zeit aus der Bundeswehr mit vielen tollen Lehrgängen.
Also hier blitzt schon mal so die Bundeswehr durch. Da macht man ja auch so einiges.
Der Staat hat in ihn investiert.
Kann man auch so sehen. Lindner ist jetzt besonders lustig.
Hast du so ein paar Tipps? Also ich frage für einen Freund, wenn es ums Überleben geht.
Hast du so ein paar Alltagstipps für unsere Prepper und sonstige Großstadtkinder?
Für die Großstadtkinder. Ich glaube, es fängt einfach an, die Komfortzone zu
verlassen und es einfach mal zu machen. Also viele haben allein im deutschen Wald Angst.
Ja, einfach mal raus. Da sind sie sich also dann ganz einig.
Lindner ist ja auch Jäger. Lindner weiter.
Nimmst du drei Kilo zu vor so einer Tour, sicherheitshalber?
Es waren ein bisschen mehr als drei. Also ich habe tatsächlich knapp zehn draufgepackt,
weil ich gedacht habe, okay. Echt? Tatsächlich? Das war jetzt ins Blaue geraten.
Das war ins Blaue geraten, aber sehr gut getroffen.
Also ich habe tatsächlich zehn Kilo zugelegt vorher. Ich habe gedacht,
alles klar. Nur der dicke Bär kommt durch den Winter.
Und ich wusste, okay, es könnte wirklich, wir haben uns mit einem Gebirge aussetzen
lassen, da in Kanada, bei dieser Tour.
Ja, die Stimmung ist heiter, man vermutet mal noch so gar nichts.
In welche Richtung geht das eigentlich?
Wir sind jetzt so gerade in den ersten 15 Minuten des Gesprächs.
Nun geht es aber auch darum, was er dann so unternehmerisch tut.
Und er vermittelt nämlich auch, was er tut, nicht nur via Social Media.
Ihr macht auch Kurse und vermittelt das anderen. Was lernen die Leute da?
Ne, das sind verschiedene Sachen. Also ich habe einmal so, das kann bei mir
aus dem, weil ich ja noch nicht lange mache, YouTube, erst zweieinhalb Jahre.
Ich habe eine, das nenne ich Warrior Talk, wo ich dann halt andere ehemalige
Soldaten einlade oder meist zu denen hinfahre, ein Gespräch im Wald nenne ich
es mal, zwei Stühle aufstelle und wie war beim Kampfschwimmer die Erfahrung,
Door Gunner, Medic, Psy-Ops und sowas.
Und da hatte ich damals mit einem Kammstürmer gesprochen, haben so ein Trainingcenter
oben in Enge Sande tatsächlich und das haben wir schon mehrmals mit Leuten gemacht, so dieses,
so eine Erfahrung, was passiert, wenn ich im Hubschrauber ins Wasser stürze,
wie komme ich da wieder raus und wenn ein Boot kentert und das sind so einfach so Tageskurse.
Reizt dich das?
Was mache ich, wenn ich mit dem Hubschrauber ins Wasser stürze?
Ja, das sind ja Fragen, die man sich stellt.
Ja. Sehr gut, dass unser Bundesfinanzminister diese Fragen für uns klärt.
Ja, oder du bist ja Vater von Kindern.
Was ich auch sonst als Herzensangelegenheit mache, so ein, zweimal im Jahr mit
Eltern-Kind-Geschichten.
Einfach Kids einladen, wir haben mit meinen Eltern ein recht großes Grundstück
und Anwesen dann im Wildenburger Land und dann hatten wir mit 30 Eltern und
50 Kindern in Wäldern, jeder baut einen Shelter und Feuermacher und Wasser, abfiltern.
Ja, auch da sind wir immer noch im vorpolitischen Raum und wir können uns aber jetzt mal überlegen.
Hier sind wir wirklich im vorpolitischen Raum, weil das sind ja nach der Apokalypse.
Berlin ist ausgeschaltet.
Der nicht politische Raum ist jetzt euer Schicksal. Warte nicht auf Carlo Josef
Laumann, der dich nochmal an die Hand des Staates nimmt.
Ja, Moment. Man kann natürlich auch sagen, der vorpolitische Raum ist sozusagen
der Raum, den man durchschreiten muss, um in den politischen Raum zu kommen.
Und man macht ja vielleicht manche Dinge nur, wenn man im vorpolitischen Raum
sich schon so und so verhalten hat.
Also Staaten haben ja in der Vergangenheit auch immer wieder gewisse Überlegungen
angestellt, wie kann man eigentlich dafür sorgen, dass es Nachschub gibt.
Und man kann ja hier durchaus mal sagen, naja, das eine ist ja irgendwie so
ein privates Hobby, was weiß ich, wie jetzt jemand,
weißt du nicht auch mal mit diesem Lasertag oder irgendwas, was du doch spielst,
irgendwas hast du doch mal erzählt.
Ich habe irgendwann vor ganz vielen Jahren mal Lasertag gespielt.
Also das ist jetzt für dich, würde ich mal sagen, nicht die große Vorbereitung
auf den Krieg, sondern hast du das einfach mal gemacht.
Meine Vorbereitung auf den Krieg ist, es wäre ein Marathonlauf.
Soweit die Füße tragen, weg vom Krieg.
Ja, also ich versuche mit dem Auto abzuhauen, aber wir werden sehen.
Ich nehme mein E-Bike.
Du mit dem E-Bike, ja. Das ist vielleicht noch das Klügste sogar,
dass du da über die Alpen oder so mit dem E-Bike, ja, möglicherweise gar nicht schlecht.
Jedenfalls haben wir jetzt noch nicht den politischen Raum eigentlich betreten.
Wir wissen nur, da sitzt also ein ehemaliger Elite-Soldat.
Wir wissen auch, der zehrt ein bisschen von dem, was er bei der Bundeswehr gelernt hat.
Und Lindner sagt jetzt auch, dass er hin und wieder den politischen Raum verlässt.
Ich bin echt auch gerne und oft draußen. Jetzt im Sommer habe ich auch mal sowas gemacht mit Freunden.
Zwei Tage draußen und dann am Lagerfeuer grillen. Das ist einfach ein ganz anderes Gefühl.
Übrigens auch untereinander führt man ganz andere Gespräche,
wenn man unter freiem Himmel am Lagerfeuer sitzt und eine Nacht verbringt.
Also ich weiß nicht, vielleicht hängt das damit zusammen, dass wir so stark
technisiert und Großstadt und Job, dass dann zumindest bei manchen wie bei mir
die Sehnsucht wächst, irgendwie so rückanzuknüpfen an so eine Naturfrage.
Ja, Landlust halt. Landlust lesen.
Ja, am Lagerfeuer mit Lindner sitzen. Ich könnte mir nichts Schlimmeres vorstellen als das.
Am Ende sinkt der.
Wasser aufdrehen, Wasser haben, es kommt frisches Wasser. Wir haben allen Luxus,
den man sich vorstellen kann.
Das weiß man dann wieder zu schätzen. Total. Total, eine Dusche,
ein Bett ist danach, wo man sagt, wie super ist das denn und deswegen mag ich
das auch so, dieses mit Absicht rauszugehen und zu sagen, ich beschneide mich
da komplett und verzichte da wirklich auf alles.
Wir haben allen Luxus, naja, also wenn man sagt, eine Dusche ist Luxus und klar,
im globalen Vergleich ist fließend Wasser überall zu haben immer noch Luxus dann,
zumindest wenn man sich manche Regionen ansieht, aber wir haben ja diese Armut
gesehen, also von Luxus da zu sprechen ist schon etwas Eigenartiges.
Jetzt machen wir eine kurze Unterbrechung für einen Trailer,
nämlich Bulletproof macht jetzt eine große Serie,
die bei Join und dann bei YouTube gezeigt wird und diese Sendung sammelt verschiedene
Influencer und Mixed Martial Arts Kämpfer ein,
um dann sie solchen Abenteuern auszusetzen.
Alles in Militärkluft, in Kasernen und es handelt sich hier um eine Kooperation mit der Bundeswehr.
Fünf Teams stellen sich den härtesten 48 Stunden ihres Lebens und müssen meine
Challenges überstehen.
Wer wird es bis zum Ende schaffen und gewinnen? Das ist Bulletproof, die Challenge.
Also wir sahen da jetzt Panzer und Bundeswehr, Hubschrauber.
Ich glaube, das ist das krasseste Gewissen, was ich mit meinem Körper jemals
gemacht habe. Geisteskrank.
Da ist man schon an einigen Stellen an seine Grenzen gekommen.
Alle Gliedmaßen tun weh. Ich bin am Arschtort.
Wir haben dann irgendwie über ihre Köpfe geschlagen.
Jetzt ist der Spaß ja wirklich vorbei. Jetzt gehen wir hier vor.
Also ich frage mich ja, wie bekommt man überhaupt Leute dazu,
dass sie bereit wären, in den Krieg zu gehen?
Und wir haben jetzt solche Formate wie Seven vs.
Wild, die wahnsinnig erfolgreich sind, die aber auch im Vorpolitischen stattfinden.
Aber man kann es natürlich schaffen, da so einen gleitenden Übergang herzustellen,
den Krieg als Abenteuer zu verkaufen, eigentlich das, was einen Ernst Jünger
angetrieben hat, in den Ersten Weltkrieg zu ziehen,
um das Abenteuer zu erleben und das hat man ja dann auch später nochmal geschafft.
Und hier sehen wir genau diese Strategie von der Bundeswehr,
die sich jetzt so einen Influencer nimmt, der mit anderen Influencern zusammen
so eine Survival-Show macht, aber die ganze Zeit im Bundeswehr-Setting und den
Krieg als Abenteuer verkauft.
Und damit kommen wir jetzt zurück zu diesem Podcast von Lindner,
in dem wir auch jetzt mal ganz klar…,
Ideologie von diesem Bulletproof hören.
Das Schlimmste befürchtet, aber schon gedacht, okay, ist schon angreifbar.
Warum hast du es trotzdem gemacht?
Ja, weil ich natürlich hinter dem Beruf Soldat voll und ganz stehe.
Sonst hätte ich auch nicht selber offiziell dran gehängt.
Wenn ich wirklich mein Land liebe und alles dafür tun würde und einstehen,
auch jederzeit wieder in den Einsatz gehen würde tatsächlich.
Ja, ich habe eben schon gedacht, wenn man in die Natur gehen will,
kann man in die Natur gehen. Man braucht dafür wieder einen Helm.
Man muss auch nicht von einer Brücke runterspringen und man muss sich auch nicht boxen.
Man kann sich einfach die Rheinstrecken aussuchen und dann auf halber Höhe Weinberg
einfach durch die Sonne laufen.
Da spürt man sich auch und da hat man auch viel Zeit für irgendwelche Gespräche
und so weiter und so fort.
Dieser ganze Trara, der hier so militarisiert daherkommt, den braucht man gar nicht.
Plus, man macht sich ja da wieder völlig abhängig von irgendwelchen Sachen.
Also Technikram, Material und so weiter, dass das alles hinhaut.
Ja und man muss, man macht, man befreit sich ja nicht dadurch,
dass man einer Hierarchie sich unterordnet.
Man taucht im Grunde nur die zivile oder die friedliche zivile Technik gegen
die militärische Technik aus.
Ich glaube, das ist auch sehr ernüchternd für relativ viele Söldner,
die in die Ukraine kommen und denken, sie werden jetzt die ganze Zeit in so
einem Faustkampf verwickelt.
Wir sehen hier gar keine Russen oder eben keine Ukrainer, je nachdem,
für wen sie kämpfen, sondern sind nur damit befasst, irgendwelche Drohnen abzuholen,
irgendwelche Kommunikationsleitungen aufzubauen und sowas, die relativ viel Bürokram auch...
Ich hatte kürzlich ein Gespräch mit jemandem, der bei der Marine gedient hat
und da stellt man sich ja zumindest so ein bisschen nach Abenteuer vor und dann
sagt man, naja, die meiste Zeit,
schrubbt man halt den Boden oder muss irgendeinen Lack abschleifen und knet
den ganzen Tag und bekommt von Leuten, die,
Eher blöder sind, als man selbst irgendwas gesagt, von dem man annimmt,
dass es Quatsch ist, aber man kann nicht widersprechen.
Also diese Freiheit, die da verschwommen wird, ist ja noch eine relativ geringe.
Und du musst das ganze Buch führen.
Mit welchen Newtonmeter du die Schrauben angezogen hast, mit denen du zu tun hattest.
Und ich finde es ja wirklich so interessant, dass man offenbar mit der Freiheit
nicht umgehen kann, denn man hat die Freiheit aus der Wohnung heraus zu gehen,
kann in die Natur gehen, kann ja dort tun was man will, wegen mir auch unter
freiem Himmel schlafen, aber dass man dann schon wieder so eine neue Struktur
braucht, das muss wieder eine Challenge werden,
also das Ganze heißt dann auch, also diese Serie heißt Bulletproof die Challenge
und damit sind wir ja schon an so einem Punkt angelangt, wo man sagen kann,
es geht hier also um sehr viel mehr als nur so ein Abenteuer.
Er sagt schon hier, ja, ich bin Soldat geworden, weil ich dieses Land liebe
und bereit bin, alles zu tun.
Er hatte dann einen Afghanistan-Einsatz und berichtet jetzt davon.
Und hier sehen wir wirklich so Ideologie des Krieges, beziehungsweise was man
sich quasi als Soldat auch vormachen muss, damit man es überhaupt sein kann.
Und das ist jetzt überhaupt nicht von mir irgendwie bösartig gemeint,
sondern ich sehe das eher als eine große Tragödie an, was wir jetzt so in den folgenden Clips hören.
Es war in Kunduz tatsächlich damals, bei der European Battle Group hieß es damals,
da waren wir abrufbereit für internationale Einsätze.
Dann war in Kunduz das Thema, da war das PRT, Provincial Reconstruction Team
der Bundeswehr, was ständig angegriffen worden ist mit Raketen auf einmal.
Wir hatten in meiner Zeit knapp 50 Raketenangriffe, also ungelenkte,
grob in die Richtung gefeuerte Raketen.
War ein sehr für uns blutiges Jahr, also man hat vier Tote gehabt,
viele Verletzte, durchaus Anschläge. ein sehr guter Freund von mir,
ist gefallen, dass vor mir das Fahrzeug in die Luft gesprengt worden tatsächlich.
Mischa Meier liegt in Köln begraben. Nachdem wurde danach eine Brücke auch benannt,
die da gebaut wurde, die auch wiederum jetzt zerschört ist leider.
Also ist es,
Schon von dieser Brücke, die da benannt wurde, nach dem gefallenen Kameraden,
nichts übrig geblieben.
Wir wissen, wie dieser Afghanistan-Einsatz geendet hat.
Wir wissen, dass es der teuerste Krieg war, dass es ein Krieg war mit unglaublich
vielen Toten und dass es ein unendlich sinnloser Krieg war. Und jetzt hat man... Ja, stimmt auch.
Also es gab ja jetzt Enquete-Kommissionen zum Afghanistan-Einsatz,
auch im Bundestag, wo ja einfach die Lehre dann auch war, ja,
das hat die Zäsur eingeläutet, das weltweite Signal, der Westen ist nicht mehr handlungsfähig.
Also es war eigentlich kontraproduktiv von der Drohmacht im Sinne von,
da einfach reinzugehen und zu zeigen, wir können eigentlich mit gar nichts drohen.
Ja und jetzt stell dir vor, du hast jetzt einen Freund oder du hast ein Kind,
das für diese Sinnlosigkeit gestorben ist.
Es gibt ja dann immer so welche, die sagen, ja aber die großen Widerstandskämpfer.
Ja klar, also ich will ja nicht generell absprechen, dass Leute über sich hinausgewachsen
sind oder offenbar auch bereit waren, sich zu opfern für andere und all das.
Ich sage immer nur, ich mach's nicht.
Aber wir sehen hier eigentlich diese ganz große Sinnlosigkeit und wir haben
jetzt auch heute ja viele Politiker so gehört und dachte ich so,
man muss sich auch einfach so vorstellen,
stell dir vor, da von diesen CDU-Leuten, die du mir eben vorgestellt hast,
schicken uns jetzt Leute in den Krieg.
Den vertraue ich ja nicht mal bei so einer Bürgergeldsgeschichte,
da denke ich schon, das ist ja vollkommen irre.
Also den soll ich jetzt anvertrauen, dass die schon wissen, dass das gut für mich ist.
Ein Einberufungsbefehl, den Steinmeier unterschrieben hat, stell dir das mal vor.
Ja.
Das ist grotesk.
Ja, und das kannst du aber nicht, wenn du dauerhaft Soldat bleiben willst,
kannst du natürlich diese Gedanken dir nicht in dieser Form machen und jetzt
diese Rechtfertigung und das ist wirklich, deswegen sage ich,
das ist tragisch, wie jetzt diese Rechtfertigung so langsam stattfindet.
Also erstmal beschreibt er diese Kameradschaft, kennen wir uns jetzt dank des
Bregmann-Buchs sowieso gut mit aus.
Und das waren natürlich schon sehr einschneidende Erlebnisse.
Ich habe seinen Leichnam mit nach Deutschland überbracht, bin aber dann wieder
zurückgeflogen zu den Restleuten der Jungs.
Also auch dieses, man lässt sich halt gegenseitig nicht im Stich.
Und Kameradschaft ist halt schwer zu beschreiben für Leute, die nie gedient haben.
Und das schweißt einen natürlich sehr eng zusammen, wenn man so ein Ding erlebt
hat. Und wir treffen uns jedes Jahr zum Beispiel immer noch an den Gräbern der Gefallenen.
Da habe ich es auch mit den Müttern, wo echt ein sehr gutes Verhältnis zu entstanden ist.
Also wie Lindner ihm hier die ganze Zeit zustimmt, Kameradschaft,
das, sagen wir mal so wie er definiert, sich nicht im Stich lassen.
Also die wurden ja nur wirklich mal im Stich gelassen. Die hatten eigentlich
einen ganz anderen Auftrag. Eigentlich sollten zivile Helfer,
Entwicklungsleute und so weiter nach Afghanistan kommen und die Bundeswehr war
nur dafür da, die zu schützen.
Dann hat sich gar keiner mehr bereit erklärt, das zu machen,
also war nur noch die Bundeswehr da, mit welchem Mandat eigentlich,
ja sich selber zu schützen. So, dann werden die mit Raketen angegriffen,
völlig sinnlose Todesfälle, zu denen es da kommt.
Und jetzt erzählt er das einem Politiker, der dann einfach, ja, ist wirklich schlimm.
Obwohl er in der Rechtsfolge derjenigen ist, die da verantwortlich sind für sowas. Ja.
Und da muss man auch sagen, also diese individuelle Kameradschaft,
die will ich ja gar nicht absprechen, aber einfach diese Perspektive,
das sind jetzt keine Kameraden, aber wir treffen uns ja auch hier häufig am
Abend dann in Frankfurt mit lieben, netten Menschen.
Ich fände es jetzt irgendwie nicht als Perspektive so, dass man sagt,
gut und dann treffen wir uns immer so und dann suchen wir mal die Gräber.
Also man will ja mit den Lebenden sein. Und das ist jetzt wirklich erstaunlich,
wie er jetzt, also wir haben jetzt gerade schon eigentlich diesen Afghanistan-Krieg abgeräumt.
Und was sagt er jetzt? Also war dieser Einsatz sinnvoll?
Ja, das war glaube ich noch so eine Zeit, viele fragen halt immer, was hat das gebracht?
Wenn man jetzt natürlich sieht, wie die Armee sich verändert hat in der Zeit, ist das schon enorm.
Also angefangen von Ausrüstung, von Holstern, von Ausbildungsinhalten,
hat das die Bundeswehr durch Einsätze.
Also ich meine, es gibt irgendwie so einen Spruch, von Klausitz war das damals,
ein alter Schinken, eine Armee, die sieben Jahre nicht im Krieg gestanden hat,
sollte aufgelöst werden.
Damit man halt immer merkt, okay, was verändert sich eigentlich da draußen? Ja, ja.
Und da hat der Bundeswehr selber natürlich sehr viel gebracht an Weiterentwicklung, muss man sagen.
Also das heißt, diese Leute sind gestorben, um das Equipment zu optimieren.
Das ist also Versuch am lebenden Objekt.
Also da, wo wir schon bei Tierversuchen sagen, das ist aber heikel.
Aber wir haben ja diese ganzen Debatten bei Tesla.
Kann man da jetzt mal jemanden reinsetzen und der fährt automatisiert und so
und was ist, wenn dann ein Unfall passiert?
Riesending, wenn da tatsächlich dann ein Unfall ist. und hier sagt man,
ja, da haben wir mal getestet, offenbar ist jetzt Radar besser geworden,
haben ja jetzt erkannt, dass da also, wenn man da im Geröll unterwegs ist, das und das passiert.
Ja und dann jetzt nochmal eine zweite Rechtfertigung.
Ich fand, es war richtig, das getan zu haben. Jetzt maße ich mir als,
ich sag mal, kleiner Milcheascher Führer ja nicht ein, das Gesamtbild natürlich
immer zu überblicken, aber wir haben so viele positive Dinge auch vor Ort gesehen.
Man kann ja sagen, in diesen 20 Jahren, wo die Bundeswehr vor Ort war,
durften Mädchen zur Schule gehen, es war Bildung für nahezu jeden zugänglich,
wurden viele, viele Dinge verbessert.
So, auf der anderen Seite kann man nicht die Weltfeuerwehr spielen,
also das geht auch nicht, die eigenen Ressourcen leiden auch enorm darunter,
aber in diesen 20 Jahren ist so meine Hoffnung, hat man auch so einen Samen
gesetzt in Form von, dass die nächste Generation vielleicht sagt,
vielleicht ist ja gar nicht so schlecht, doch ein bisschen mehr zu öffnen.
Also ob da sich jemand noch mal dem Westen zuwendet, nach dem Debakel,
das würde ich ja doch sehr in Frage stellen.
Und dann passiert etwas ganz Entscheidendes in diesem Podcast.
Die gehen dann einfach so so davon weg. Die sind sich natürlich nochmal einig,
wie wichtig das ist, dass die Bundeswehr jetzt viel mehr im Mittelpunkt steht
und wir müssen den jungen Leuten auch sagen, dass das ein toller Beruf ist,
So weiter. Aber sie sprechen dann auch über ihn als Unternehmer.
Und damit kommen wir jetzt an den CDU-Diskurs wieder.
Was läuft eigentlich schief in Deutschland? Und da geht es viel um bürokratische
Hürden. Die gibt es natürlich auch bei der Bundeswehr.
Und das glaube ich auch, dass da gerade was…,
Es geht dann plötzlich um etwas anderes.
Ja, also ganz viele Dinge. Von Arbeitskräften genauso, dass wir jetzt so Leute
haben, die sagen, ja, lohnt gar nicht zu kommen, denn ich kriege mit dem Bürgergeld
heute, rechnen Sie nicht, für 100 Euro aus Essen zu dir nach Neuss zu kommen,
bleibe ich besser zu Hause. Das kann doch nicht wahr sein.
Bürokratie ist genauso. Das erlebst du konkret? Ja, bei einem Mitarbeiter, ja.
Tatsächlich, der jetzt gesagt hat, wir müssen irgendwie mal katschen,
weil irgendwie, ich habe es mir durchgerechnet, das macht keinen Sinn mehr.
Ich denke, das kann doch nicht, der ist seit elf Jahren bei mir.
Also ganz viele Themen. Ich will dich damit nicht aufrufen.
Also der Mann arbeitet seit elf Jahren für ihn und sagt, er würde nur 100 Euro
mehr bekommen, wie wenn er nur Bürgergeld bekäme. Das kann ja niemals stimmen.
Spring noch mal ein bisschen zurück.
Ja, ich springe ein bisschen zurück.
Nur so ein Stück.
Das kann ja niemals sein.
Spiel noch mal ab.
Bürokratie ist genauso. Das erlebst du konkret? Ja, bei einem Mitarbeiter.
Tatsächlich, der jetzt gesagt hat, wir müssen irgendwie mal katschen,
weil ich habe es mir durchgerechnet, das macht keinen Sinn mehr.
Das kann er nicht, der ist seit elf Jahren bei mir.
Also ganz viele Themen. Ich will dich damit nicht auf die Füße treten.
Lass diesen Punkt mal laufen. Drück mal einmal zurück und dann lass mal weiterlaufen. Und jetzt play.
Nein, das tust du gar nicht. Ich will dir damit nicht auf die Füße treten.
Er versteht gar nicht, in welchem Setting er da ist. Christian Lindner wartet
ja nur darauf, dass er endlich gegen den Staat anwettern kann.
Dann kommt er mit diesen Anekdoten, von denen wir wissen, das ist wirklich empirische
Evidenz, die sich mit keiner strukturellen Erfahrung deckt. Das IFO-Institut hat es durchgerechnet.
Und wir haben auch in absoluten Zahlen so wenig Bürgergeldempfänger,
die wirklich nicht arbeiten, also die nicht aufstocken wie jemals und so weiter und so fort.
Und er glaubt jetzt, er argumentiert gegen Christian Lindner,
obwohl er genau sein Geschäft gerade macht.
So haben wir auch in Afghanistan den Krieg geführt. Anstatt uns dort sozial,
einbinden zu lassen in die Struktur, wie sie sie halt vor Ort ist,
haben wir einfach die Geschäfte in der Taliban geführt, in der wir alle Vorbehalte
und so weiter gegen staatliche Strukturen und so weiter einfach nur verschärft und verhärtet haben,
ohne einmal mit sozusagen kultureller Ahnung, wir hatten ja relativ häufig,
ich habe jetzt den Namen leider nicht parat, aber die DDR hatte ja ihrerseits.
Afghanistan-Kultur als eigenen Studiengang und so. Man wusste,
dann müssen wir jetzt mal bei denen anfragen und so.
Die Bundeswehr hat sich nicht einmal darum gekümmert, da irgendwie eine kulturelle
Expertise und so zu erringen.
Und so wie man dann da als Soldat völlig blind einfach,
irgendeines Fremden Aufträge erfüllt, die man selber nicht versteht und dann
aber später sagt, naja, ich sag jetzt mal, das war schon sinnvoll,
sitzt er und sagt, naja, ich will das jetzt jetzt gegen dich sagen,
weil du ein Politiker bist, ihr macht das da irgendwie falsch.
Und Lindner so, sehr gut, sehr gut, sehr gut.
Also er weiß gar nicht, wie sehr er ein FDP Mindset hat und um das nochmal ganz
deutlich zu unterstreichen, also es kann nicht sein,
also das Bürgergeld gibt das nicht her, was er beschreibt und er müsste sich
natürlich als Unternehmer erstmal die Frage stellen, ja wie wenig zahle ich
eigentlich Leuten, wenn der Abstand so groß ist.
Aber natürlich Schuld ist das Bürgergeld, Also das ist ja Connemann,
Linnemann, diese ganzen Leute.
Es ist exakt diese Argumentation, auf die Lindner nur gewartet hat und es geht dann richtig los.
Auch mein Umfeld, Leute, die ich kenne, mir das erzählen.
Mein Gefühl, wenn ich die Zahlen sehe, was mit Kosten der Unterkunft und so
weiter, wenn Kinder dazukommen, da ausgezahlt wird als solidarische Leistung der Gesellschaft.
Und das vergleiche, was Leute verdienen können, wenn sie jetzt nicht super qualifiziert
sind, sondern einfach einen normalen guten Job haben.
Da ist eine Unwucht. Völlig. Auf jeden Fall.
Das Arbeiten sich nicht lohnt für viele und nicht der Anreiz geschaffen wird, da was zu tun.
Also hier sitzen sich ja quasi zwei Millionäre gegenüber, die sich jetzt darüber
unterhalten, dass es aber unglaublich ist, dass die Mitarbeiter da mehr Geld haben wollen.
Ja, die spielen jetzt vor der Öffentlichkeit so ein Spiel. Christian Lindner
natürlich hier intrigant, clever. Er weiß gar nicht, was passiert.
Und dass Lindner ja auch noch mit empirischer Evidenz kommt,
ja, die bezahlen so viel für die Unterkunft und so.
Ja, wenn der Staat kommt und sagt, ich zahle die Unterkunft, sagt der Vermieter...
Hier wohnen vier Leute, zwei Kinder, ihr kriegt für die nie eine andere Wohnung,
die sind schicksalshaft hier gefangen in meiner Wohnung, die kostet 1500 Euro.
Dann muss der Staat das bezahlen und dann wird halt für eine Bürgergeldfamilie
1500 Euro Wohndings abgerechnet.
Nur das ist kein Sozialstaat für die Hartz-IV-Familie, sondern für den Vermieter.
Und es gibt dann doch einen erheblichen Unterschied, wenn man dann arbeitet,
aber das will man nicht sehen.
Jetzt geht es um diese zumutbare Arbeit. Also eben haben wir ja schon gehört,
das ist ein tolles Land. Dafür möchte ich am liebsten alles tun.
Ich bin sogar bereit, mich dafür zu opfern, wenn es sein muss.
Und diese Opferbereitschaft, die soll natürlich überall an den Tag gelegt werden.
Wie du das gerade geschildert hast, für 100 Euro mehr lohnt es sich nicht.
Das macht mich, ehrlich gesagt, wenn ich sowas höre, dass Leute so denken,
fuchs ich deshalb, weil Bürgergeld ist ja nicht eine Rente.
Ja, aber so sehen die das. Ja, aber selbst wenn es 100 Euro nur mehr sind,
ja dann ist das eben so, weil das Bürgergeld selbst...
Als würde ein Christian Lindner für 100 Euro mehr im Monat irgendetwas machen.
100 Euro, ja wirklich.
Ja nur wenn du keine Arbeit hast, nicht weil du sagst, die Arbeit mag ich nicht.
Also diese Idee, dass zumutbare Arbeit angenommen werden muss,
die müssen wir stärker durchsetzen.
Ja, also alles ist zumutbar im Prinzip, nur weil man da keine Lust hat.
Also wir merken uns mal, da gibt es keinen Hedonismus.
Wenn Christian Lindner sagt, 100 Euro, egal in welchem Zusammenhang,
das ist das Budget für eine Mahlzeit bei ihm.
Faktisch einfach. Der geht zweimal am Tag, lässt er sich bewirten oder was auch
immer und irgendwo werden dafür 100 Euro abgerechnet. Sei es als Personalkosten
im Ministerium, sei es als Abendveranstaltung, sei es irgendwas.
100 Euro pro Mahlzeit bei Christian Lindner zu rechnen. Ja.
Jetzt denke ich an damals, Ende Zweiter Weltkrieg, die Flüchtlinge,
die aus dem Osten gekommen sind.
Jeder hätte jede Arbeit angenommen und gesagt, okay, ich bekomme hier Unterkunft, Unverpflege und allem.
Es ist eine totale Gerechtigkeitsfrage.
Ja, also wir sind jetzt schon daran, dass wir sagen, also die Flüchtlinge nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg.
Also jetzt sind wir bei der CDU, die sagen noch, wir verrichten noch das Werk
Gottes und zwar alle gemeinsam. Hier ist eigentlich schon Survival statt Sozialstaat, was gepredigt wird.
Und jetzt aber diese Umkehr. Wir haben die Zahlen von Schneider gehört.
Es ist dramatisch. Ganz vielen Menschen geht es ganz, ganz schlecht.
Über 20 Prozent der Kinder, jedes fünfte Kind ist arm. Wir hören aber.
Also wir leben in einem tollen Land, das muss man einfach mal sagen.
Man kann ja nur sagen, bei uns sind alle Freiheiten. Jeder kann eigentlich nahe zu tun und lassen.
Wir stehen uns nur selbst im Weg. Wir stehen uns völlig selber im Weg.
Deshalb machen wir uns den Weg frei.
Wir machen uns den Weg frei.
Und wir haben eben gehört, ja, die sollen mal die Arbeit annehmen.
Die sollen doch dankbar sein, dass sie überhaupt eine Arbeit bekommen.
Lindner sagt so tatsächlich auch noch, das habe ich jetzt nicht noch mitgebracht,
es heißt ja auch Arbeitgeber.
Und deswegen, der gibt die Arbeit und die anderen nehmen sie ja nur und jetzt
hören wir hier, also den anderen ist ja alles zumutbar, aber hier?
Eigentlich machst du nur die Dinge, die dir Spaß machen, ja. Deswegen würde ich auch.
Man selbst hat es natürlich geschafft, andere für sich arbeiten zu lassen.
Oh Mann, das ist wirklich.
Und wir hören deswegen zum Abschluss nochmal eine kleine Lindner-Philosophie
über die Kürze des Lebens.
Das müssen wir eigentlich alle tun. Das Leben ist zu kurz, um Dinge zu machen, die man nicht mag.
Ja, und genau mit dieser Haltung sollte man auch da rangehen und sagen,
nö, das Leben ist zu kurz, um mir eine Arbeit aufschwatzen zu lassen,
die Christian Lindner und Herr Linnemann für mich vorgesehen hat.
Und deswegen sage ich, ich mache das, was ich gerne machen möchte.
Also Mindset doch eigentlich gut, würde ich sagen, nur muss man es dann wirklich
übertragen, skalieren auf alle anderen.
Und man sieht da tatsächlich, wie gut sich diese Influencer jetzt verknüpfen
lassen aus dem Vorpolitischen raus,
also erst machen wir mal nur so Abenteuer und Vermittlung für die Kinder ist auch wichtig,
hin zum Militärischen und dann auch zu einem Staatsverständnis,
wo der Untertan sich bitte gefügig zu verhalten hat und entweder bereit ist,
in den Krieg zu ziehen oder bereit ist,
jede zumutbare Arbeit anzunehmen.
In der Hinsicht, ob es dir Spaß macht oder nicht, wir beginnen jetzt noch die
Rente. Denn ich habe auf die Uhr geschaut, wir haben noch Zeit.
Schaffen wir das noch? Wir müssen heute früh in die Oper, du weißt.
Ja, wir haben noch ein bisschen Zeit für Schnitzel und Oper.
Das Vergnügen kommt, aber du musst wissen, Wolfgang, du lebst hier in Deutschland
und für Deutschland gilt...
Deutschland ist ein fleißiges Land, ein Land der Arbeit. Mehr als 46 Millionen
Erwerbstätige stehen jeden Morgen auf und packen an.
So viele übrigens wie noch nie in Deutschland. Ob im Overall,
im Anzug oder im Kittel oder in Uniform.
Oder Anzug.
Mit ihren Leistungen sorgen diese Menschen für den Wohlstand in Deutschland.
Sie halten unser Land am Laufen.
Und sie sorgen mit ihrer Arbeit auch und ihren Beiträgen für die soziale Sicherheit
ihrer Eltern und Großeltern, der 21 Millionen Rentnerinnen und Rentner in Deutschland.
Deutschland ist ein Land der Arbeit. Das heißt, hier wird gearbeitet.
Egal was man anhört, man arbeitet und dafür kriegst du Verlässlichkeit.
Die Menschen, die in Deutschland hart arbeiten, die heute Beiträge zahlen,
müssen sich auch in Zukunft auf die gesetzliche Rente verlassen können.
Sehr richtig.
Blöd, dass du jetzt zu den Jüngeren gehörst, denn das Rentensystem hatte eigentlich zwei Haltelinien.
Das eine war das Rentenniveau. Ich habe es mir extra aufgeschrieben.
Das Rentenniveau heißt Niveauschutzklausel und dann gibt es die zweite Haltelinie,
die Beitragssatzhaltelinie, die also sagt,
von deinem Lohn geht nur so und so viel ab und später bekommst du vom allgemeinen
Lohnniveau so und so viel Rente.
Jetzt hören wir hier mal bei der Aktualisierung dieser Gesetzgebung,
ob vielleicht so eine der beiden Haltelinien unter den Tisch gefallen ist.
Ohne dieses Rentenpaket hätten wir sonst folgendes Szenario.
Das Rentenniveau würde ab 2027 von der Lohnentwicklung abgekoppelt und in den
Folgejahren spürbar senken.
In anderen Worten, die Rentnerinnen und Rentner von heute und morgen würden
im Vergleich zur arbeitenden Bevölkerung ärmer werden. Das werden wir mit der
Sicherung des Rentenniveaus verhindern.
Meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren, zu einer sicheren Rente gehört auch,
dass wir die Beiträge im Blick behalten.
Seit meinem Amtsantritt 2018 ist der Rentenbeitrag in Deutschland stabil bei
18,6 Prozent, also seit mehr als sechs Jahren.
Übrigens davor war er höher. Wir können heute davon ausgehen,
dass er auch in den nächsten Jahren stabil bleibt.
So, Rentenniveau ist gesichert und jetzt per Befehl beim Beitrag,
ja wir können davon ausgehen, dass...
Er hat den im Blick.
Irgendwas. Klingt nicht so nach einer Haltelinie, oder?
Nee.
Es ist irgendwie, hier sind klare Tendenzen heraushörbar.
Zum Ende des Jahrzehnts allerdings wird auch der Beitrag ansteigen.
Das legt insbesondere daran, dass unsere Gesellschaft deutlich älter wird.
Wenn jetzt jemand kommt und sage Beiträge hoch, Beiträge runter, Lindner.
Die Prognosen zu den Beiträgen sind keine feststehende Realität.
Die heutigen Prognosen zu den Beiträgen sind keine feststehende Realität,
sondern unsere Verpflichtung zu erfolgreicher Arbeitsmarktpolitik und zur Fortsetzung
von Reformen der Sozialversicherungssysteme in den nächsten Jahren.
Also das Rentenniveau der Alten, die alte Haltelinie, Realität.
Beitragshöhe, keine Realität. Es wird ganz deutlich gesagt, keine Realität, das ist nur Prognose.
Wir müssen jetzt arbeiten, damit es nicht zu sehr steigt. Also Vorschlag.
Und deshalb treffen wir auch für die Beiträge Vorsorge, vor allen Dingen für
die zweite Hälfte der 30er Jahre,
indem wir ein Generationenkapital schaffen, das den Beitragssatzanstieg in der
zweiten Hälfte der 30er Jahre bremsen soll.
Ja, funktioniert natürlich nicht, denn wir wissen, so wenig wieder jetzt gerade
reingegeben wird bei der durchschnittlichen Entwicklung,
die man so nachvollziehen kann, wenn man sich den MSCI World ansieht,
wissen wir, dass man also nicht mal damit das kompensieren könnte, was fehlt.
Geschweige denn irgendein Mehr daraus ziehen.
Aber wir sehen ja schon mal, die wissen irgendwas, diese Männer da in der Regierung
und die versuchen uns was zu verkaufen.
Das Generationenkapital. Heil sagt später nochmal.
Mit dem Rentenpaket 2 stärken und modernisieren wir die gesetzliche Rente und zwar von zwei Seiten.
Zum einen sorgen wir mit der Haltlinie, Stichwort Rentenniveau,
für Stabilität und zum zweiten entlasten wir Beitragszahlerinnen und Beitragszahler
mit dem Generationenkapital, damit Beiträge nicht zu stark steigen.
Die Botschaft dieser Pressekonferenz zum Rentenpaket 2 2024 ist also,
die Haltelinie Beiträge ist Geschichte.
Hat kein Journalist solch aufgegriffen. Keine Ahnung warum. Vielleicht fehlt
es an demografischer Bildung oder so in Deutschland.
Worauf man so achten muss bei solchen Sachen. Dafür hat man allen das Konfetti
hingeworfen, Generationenkapital.
Also irgendwas ist mit diesen Beiträgen, sie werden wohl steigen.
Meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren, die Grundlage für stabile Renten ist ein starker Arbeitsmarkt.
Je stabiler der Arbeitsmarkt, desto sicherer die Renten und auch dafür haben wir Weichen gestellt.
Ja, was heißt denn stabiler Arbeitsmarkt? Wir haben ja kaum Arbeitslosigkeit.
Ja, und wir haben auch eine Prognose von minus sieben Millionen.
Das nennt er sogar selber.
Das Institut für Arbeitsmarkt und Berufs...
Allerdings müssen wir hier wieder nach vorne springen, in die Fragerunde.
Die Forschung der Bundesagentur für Arbeit hat mal berechnet,
wie viele Arbeitskräfte wir bis 2035 in Deutschland ersetzen müssen.
Aufgrund der demografischen Entwicklung. Und die Zahl ist erstmal schreckend
groß, sieben Millionen.
Und deshalb müssen wir alle Register ziehen, damit das gelingt.
Ich glaube, die kamen einfach letztes Jahr mit den 7 Millionen,
weil sie das in meinem Buchdeckel geschrieben haben und immer wieder Fragen kamen.
Stimmt das denn? Sind 7 Millionen? Hier ist doch irgendwie und so.
Und ich habe das für den Buchdeckel einfach nur ausgerechnet aus der statistischen
Bevölkerungsvorausberechnung. Einfach nur so im großen Ganzen sind 7 Millionen.
Also die 7 Millionen stehen fest. Wir haben ein Defizit von 7 Millionen Arbeitskräften.
Da müssen die Beiträge aber ganz schön angehoben werden.
Ja, sieben Millionen, wenn wir jetzt froh darüber sind, dass wir 35 Millionen
Vollzeit-Sozialversicherungspflichtig Beschäftigte und insgesamt 46 Millionen,
die mindestens eine Woche pro Stunde, eine Stunde pro Woche arbeiten.
Also müssen wir um ein Fünftel steigen.
Dann sind sieben von 35 in Prozent ausgerechnet schon ein ordentlicher Zweistelliger.
Also es ist viel auszugleichen. Und wenn er dann immer noch einsteigt mit,
Grundlage von allem ist ein stabiler Arbeitsmarkt. Dann wissen wir,
schwierig. Das wird wirklich sehr schwierig.
Die wesentliche Schlacht ist am Arbeitsmarkt. Ich will aber eine politische Einordnung dazu sagen.
So, jetzt kommt eine politische Einordnung. Ihr könnt jetzt mal überlegen,
ihr selber mit, keine Ahnung, wenn wir so unsere Spotify-Statistik,
im Schnitt 30-Jährige höre und, sagen wir mal so, 70-Jährige Rentner.
Wie unterschiedlich kann man das jetzt hier hören?
Weil die Kehrseite der Modelle ist die Frage, ob wir zulassen,
dass das Rentenniveau absinkt oder ich würde mal sagen abstürzt.
Und ich glaube, das ist nicht verantwortbar, gerade gegenüber den Leuten,
die heute in Arbeit sind, auch den Jüngeren.
Wenn die Jüngeren von heute einzahlen immer mehr und nichts mehr rausbekommen,
dann brechen wir den Generationenvertrag.
So, also. Den jungen Leuten wird gesagt, wir werden mehr Rentenbeiträge von deinem Lohn wegnehmen.
Den Älteren wird gesagt, euer Rentenniveau wird bleiben.
Aber von dem Rentenniveau werdet ihr ja auch ihr Jüngeren, wenn ihr dann mal
Rentner seid, profitieren.
Was heißt denn das? Ich profitiere dann also, also ich jetzt als 40-Jähriger
in 27 Jahren, das ist ja dann 2023 plus 27, ganz schön weit in der Zukunft.
Kannst dich schon mal drauf freuen.
Genau, jetzt wird uns hier mal eine Zeitmarke gesetzt, bei der wir fragen,
ach, an der soll sich das entscheiden?
Das gesetzliche Rentenniveau ist garantiert bis 2025. Wir wollen es dauerhaft
sichern und haben deshalb im Gesetzentwurf vorgeschlagen, dass wir es bis 2039 gesetzlich absichern.
Es soll aber dauerhaft, auch über 2039 hinaus.
Also es gibt nur eine Garantie bis 2039, was darüber hinaus ist.
Mal gucken, jetzt können wir überlegen. Also ich gehe nicht 2039,
sondern später in Rente. Ich komme ja später in das Alter.
Jeder, der jetzt hier zuhört, überlegt doch mal. 2039 bringt das euch gerade
Sicherheit? Oder eher so diesen heute 50-Jährigen?
Gesichert werden. Wir haben aber seriöserweise
gesagt, wir gucken uns die Entwicklung in den 30er Jahren an.
Und dann wird der Gesetzgeber weitere auch Stellschrauben stellen,
weil wir die reale Entwicklung im Blick haben.
Nun gut, also die Jungen werden hier gerade unterm Bus geworfen,
damit jetzt noch bis 2039 man es nicht plötzlich mit rebellierenden Babyboomern im Rentenalter hat.
Weil das wäre problematisch für Heil.
Dein Vorschlag war ja im Presseclub.
Da kommen wir gleich noch zurück auf die 100 Milliarden pro Jahr.
Können wir gleich mal durchkalkulieren, wenn wir da angekommen sind.
Denn noch muss ja nochmal kurz ausgeschlossen werden, längere Lebensarbeitszeit.
Was glaube ich jetzt klar sein sollte ist, du bist ja nicht hier und sitzt.
Nicht, dass das jemand falsch klippt am Ende und wir sind bei TikTok zu sehen,
bei irgendwelchen Verrückten.
Also du bist nicht dafür, dass man die Rente jetzt in Boden und Boden kürzt.
Die machen wir gleich mal an entsprechender Stelle. Vorher handeln wir noch
kurz die längere Lebensarbeitszeit ab.
Ja, aber nur freiwillig. Also nicht, dass jemand glaubt, naja,
2039 könnte man nicht auch den jetzt bis 2039 in Rente gehenden sagen,
macht ihr doch auch noch mal ein Jahr länger.
Nicht nur die Jüngeren, sondern zahlt ihr doch auch noch mal ein.
So ein bisschen wie, als das Verfassungsgerichtsurteil kam zum Thema,
ihr habt ein Recht auf Zukunft.
Es darf nicht die Klimapolitik alles nach 2035 verhandelt werden.
Nein, das kann man auch vorher ein bisschen machen. Und so hier auch.
Kann man nicht auch ein bisschen was vor 2039 machen?
Naja, Renteneintrittsalter bleibt jedenfalls wie es ist. Da bin ich aber auch total dafür.
Mit dem Rentenpaket stellen wir klar...
Gleichzeitig, es wird keine Rentenkürzung geben und auch keine weitere Erhöhung
des gesetzlichen Renteneintrittsalters.
Und ich will auch sagen, das ist richtig so.
Das ist richtig so, das würde ich auch sagen, schon allein, wenn ich mir die
Demoskopie zum Thema anschaue, man kann sich mit den einen oder anderen anlegen,
aber wenn 85% der Leute der Meinung sind, sie möchten keine längere Lebensarbeitszeit,
dann braucht man kein schweizerisches System,
wo man das erste Mal eine Umfrage gemacht hat, bei der der Sozialstaat ausgebaut
wurde, allerdings nur, weil das erste Mal eine Mehrheit gemerkt hat,
achso, der Sozialstaat, das bin ja ich.
Es ging nicht nur um die wenigen Armen oder die Obdachlosen oder wer auch immer,
sondern es ging wirklich mal um alle und plötzlich, ah ja, Sozialstaat ist ganz gut.
Betrifft ja meine Rente. 100% der Leute kriegen eine Rente, also sagen die natürlich.
Ja, ja, klar, ich will ein 13. 14.
Jahresgehalt von der Rentenkasse haben. Nun gut, wer länger arbeiten will,
kann das ja freiwillig machen.
Ich kenne persönlich auch Leute, die Mitte, Ende 60 sind, die top sind.
Das ist sehr gut. Er kennt persönlich auch Leute, wir haben das eben von Lindner
gehört, nur er Er sagt uns gleich, wen kennt er denn persönlich?
Fit sind, die arbeiten wollen und arbeiten können. Ich denke mal an den Oppositionsführer,
der wird im November 69 Jahre alt. Er will offensichtlich weiter arbeiten.
Davon wird ihn niemand richtig abhalten können. Und das ist auch gut so.
Immer wieder betonen, dass der Oppositionsführer bei der nächsten Wahl 70 ist.
Sehr gut.
Nicht die Chancen liegen lassen, wenn schon über die Alten gesprochen wird.
Das ist immer richtig klemmer. Das traut man ihm gar nicht so zu.
Ja, war so ein kleiner. Für den Rest kann man ja einfach mal,
statt hier Befehle auszusprechen, einfach darüber diskutieren.
Viel wichtiger als eine Debatte über eine starre Erhöhung des gesetzlichen Renteneintrittsalters
ist es dafür zu sorgen, dass Menschen tatsächlich auch länger arbeiten können.
Der durchschnittliche Renteneintritt übrigens heute in Deutschland ist 64 Jahre alt.
So, also kommen wir zum Generationenkapital. Christian Lindner weist nochmal
drauf hin, es ist ja auch heute nicht allein die Rentenversicherung,
die mobilisiert ja nur 250 Milliarden, wir brauchen aber 350 Milliarden,
perspektivisch 450 Milliarden für Rentenzahlung.
Der Bundeshaushalt unterstützt die gesetzliche Rentenversicherung aktuell mit
über 100 Milliarden Euro jährlich.
Das ist fast ein Viertel des gesamten Etats.
Das ist viel und die bisherigen Beiträge kommen natürlich an eine Belastungsgrenze.
Menschen und Betriebe in unserem Land können nicht grenzenlos belastet werden.
Steigerungen der Sozialversicherungsbeiträge haben dort Grenzen,
wo sie negative Folgen für die Wettbewerbsfähigkeit der Wirtschaft haben und
den Druck auf die arbeitende Mitte überziehen.
Ja, also dass ich die ganze Zeit mit Steuergeld das Wohngeld der Vermieter mitbezahle,
bringt mich eigentlich auch an eine Belastungsgrenze, muss ich sagen.
Aber von mir aus, okay, gut. Das ist nicht, was er meint.
Nee, nee.
Er meint nur diese Lohnnebenkosten, die den Arbeitnehmern auch noch,
den Arbeitgebern auf der Tasche liegen. Nun gut, also dieses Generationenkapital.
Was wir heute vorlegen, das ist ein neuer Baustein für die gesetzliche Rentenversicherung.
Damit das Rentensystem Zukunft hat, schaffen wir das Generationenkapital.
Es ist eine dritte Säule für die gesetzliche Rentenversicherung,
neben den Beiträgen und neben dem Zuschuss aus dem Bundeshaushalt.
Wir trauen uns damit einen echten Paradigmenwechsel zu und steigen ein in die
teilweise Kapitaldeckung der gesetzlichen Rente.
Das ist überfällig.
Das ist überfällig, dass wir insgesamt mal die Chancen des Kapitalmarkts bla bla bla.
Es ist überfällig, dass wir die Chancen der Kapitalmärkte auch für die gesetzliche
Rentenversicherung nutzen.
Also um das nochmal klar zu machen, bei dieser Art der Finanzierung jetzt, in der man sagt,
wir brauchen ja nur dazu investieren in die Kapitalmärkte, hat man sich überlegt,
wir externalisieren das, was hier nicht mehr gemacht wird, nämlich gearbeitet,
weil wir zu wenig Leute sind, also sieben Millionen Leute fallen raus,
die arbeiten also nicht mehr, es wird aber noch irgendwo in der Welt ja gearbeitet,
da wird ja erwirtschaftet, da werden Dividenden erwirtschaftet von Menschen,
wir haben die Menschen nicht da, Wir sind jetzt die Idle-Miner, die jetzt sagen, prima,
da können wir ja von dort uns doch ein bisschen was abschöpfen,
indem wir da reingehen, in Aktien investieren.
Also das ist die Sache. Also man externalisiert das,
also man könnte auch sagen, wir versuchen hier mit guten Investitionen in Kinder,
mit Fachkräften die Volkswirtschaft so zu bringen, dass die sieben Millionen
wieder aufgefangen werden, aber nein, man sagt,
wir machen es lieber über ein Handyspiel.
Also wir hören jetzt mal genau, wir schließen genau an diesen Gedanken an.
Wir hören jetzt mal, um welche Beträge es geht und fragen uns,
aber warte mal, 600.000 Needs, die man mobilisieren könnte oder bei 10 Millionen
Frauen, die in Teilzeit arbeiten,
zwei Stunden mehr die Woche Arbeitszeit rausholen, also 500.000 Vollzeitequivalente.
Was machen wir mit welchem Geld?
Wir bauen also einen Kapitalstock auf. Dieser besteht aus jährlichen Darlehen
aus dem Bundeshaushalt.
Für 2024 sind bereits 12 Milliarden Euro eingeplant und diese Zuführungen werden
jährlich mit 3 Prozent, also der prognostizierten Lohnentwicklung, dynamisiert.
Wir nehmen jetzt jedes Jahr 12 Milliarden, investieren die nicht in die Kinder
oder in die Frauen, sondern wir geben das den Bankern halt. Ja.
Damit die das dann für uns anlegen.
Da bin ich ja auch sehr gespannt, was da irgendwann noch so an Verwaltungskosten
kommt, denn es ist ja immer die Sache.
Wie man in irgendwelche Fonds investiert. Ich würde auch sagen.
Also wenn ich hier Anbieter wäre von so einem Fonds, der den Deutschland absichert,
würde ich einfach sagen, das Risiko ist wirklich groß, die müssen eine große
Absicherungskosten hier.
Ja und die Verwaltungsgebühr. Ja, das ist ja so.
Ich muss ja jeden Morgen um 8 antreten, um das Milliarden.
Bei vielen Hausbanken, die da irgendwelche aktiv gemanagten Fonds für zweieinhalb
Prozent Verwaltungsgebühr anbieten, das muss ja schon eine ungeheure Rendite sein.
Also das gibt es ja, diese ganze
Statistik. Also ich verweise nochmal ganz ausdrücklich auf Finanzwende.
Die haben eine Studie vorgestellt zur Riester-Rürup-Rente und ich verweise auch
mal darauf, dass man sich ganz gut informieren kann, jetzt für die private Altersvorsorge,
wenn einem sowas da ansteht,
sich nichts aufschwatzen zu lassen mit irgendeiner Verwaltungsgebühr von zwei
oder drei Prozent. Da stimmt irgendwas.
Weil die wird nämlich garantiert. Auf der anderen Seite des Vertrages.
Nun gut, jetzt kommen wir ins Eingemachte, weshalb ich im Presseclub auch von 100 Milliarden sprach.
Die Renditen, die an den internationalen Kapitalmärkten erzielt werden,
liegen deutlich oberhalb dessen, was wir an Zins für unsere deutsche Staatsanleihen zahlen müssen.
Deutschland hat eine Top-Bonität. Wie Sie wissen, ist es als Finanzminister
ja auch mein Ziel, dass Deutschland bei der Staatsfinanzierung der Goldstandard,
Und das machen wir uns zunutze bei der Anlage des Generationenkapitals.
Nehmen Sie alleine die Rendite der Anlage des Kenfos aus dem Vergangenen.
Nur mal um das jetzt zu verstehen, also wir sollen der Goldstandard bleiben,
das heißt Deutschland macht Austeritätspolitik,
signalisiert damit den Kapitalmärkten, wir stehen auf der Schuldenbremse,
wir sind ganz solide, wir verschwenden unser Geld nicht,
dadurch kann Deutschland so beliebt sein mit seinen Staatsanleihen und weil
man so beliebt ist, kann man dann aber Schulden machen,
indem man in den Kapitalmarkt hineingeht.
Also wir sehen schon, man könnte ja Schulden machen und investiert zum Beispiel
in Kinder und signalisiert so dem Kapitalmarkt, seht her,
wir bauen hier die große grüne Industrie auf, nee, machen wir nicht.
Wir sagen, wir gehen auf die Schuldenbremse, gehen dann in den Kapitalmarkt,
weil der Kapitalmarkt ja weiß, dass wir so vertrauensvoll sind und deswegen
uns die Staatsanleihen abkauft.
Ja, Lindner ist auch zuversichtlich zu Recht, dass der Kapitalmarkt es gutiert,
dass sich Deutschland verschuldet, um dem Kapitalmarkt Geld zu geben.
Ja klar, gutieren die das mit AAA-Ranking.
Also ich meine, das ist doch nun wirklich einfach, Silo.
Die lag bei 11,1 Prozent.
Das merken wir uns mal. 11,1 Prozent Rendite von diesem Institut,
das bisher die Gelder für den Atomausstieg und so weiter verwaltet.
Deutlich oberhalb dessen, was die deutschen Staatsanleihen gekostet hätten oder
was wir zahlen mussten für unsere Staatsverschuldung.
Ich will jetzt nicht die 11,1 bereits zum Benchmark machen, aber ich will veranschaulichen,
dass es ein Klagesrenditedifferenzial erst recht in einer mehrjährigen Anlage gibt. Zu was führt das?
Bereits das Generationenkapital 1.0, wie wir es hier heute vorstellen,
führt zu einer Senkung des Rentenversicherungsbeitrags von 0,3 Prozent. Punkten.
So, von perspektivisch, heute 18, 22, Prozent kommen dann auf 22,3,
also eine Absenkung um 1 Prozent.
Interessant ist ja dieses Renditedifferenzial. Deutschland verschuldet sich,
gibt Staatsanleihen raus für sagen wir mal so 1 Prozent und erwirtschaftet aber
11 Prozent Rendite auf dem freien Anlagemarkt.
Man tauscht also 1% Kosten gegen 10% Rendite, was dann für mich der Anlass war,
weil ich mir vorgenommen habe, ich gehe nicht in den Presseclub und haue da alles in Tonne.
Das können ja dann die Leute, die sich für mich interessieren,
im Fernsehpodcast oder so mit Mick nachschauen, wie ich drei Stunden lang das
hier gar nicht klug fand, sondern ich hole mal das Positivste raus.
Wenn wir uns für dieses System entscheiden,
Warum dann nur mit 12 Milliarden und nicht mit 100?
Ja, ich habe mir diese Frage auch mit Ole in der Speak Easy Bar gestellt und die Sache ist folgende.
Weil natürlich das mit den Kapitalmärkten, ihr vertraut uns,
deswegen sind die Staatsanleihen günstig, wir verschulden uns,
um wieder in die Kapitalmärkte zu gehen, nur bis zu einem gewissen Punkt geht.
Du meinst mit 100 Milliarden im Jahr bringt man da einige Turbulenzen mit?
Ja, denn sonst könnte man das ja grundsätzlich alles nur noch so machen.
Also dann könnten wir auch vielleicht sagen, warum sind wir eigentlich so doof
und arbeiten überhaupt noch in Deutschland?
Warum machen wir nicht, wie Christian Lindner doch sagt, nur noch was wir wollen?
Deutschland könnte den ganzen DAX aufkaufen in den 15 Jahren.
Ja, und wir könnten einfach sagen, wir verschulden uns so stark, nehmen das ganze Geld,
wir verschulden uns, werfen es auf den MSCI World und der hat auch,
glaube ich, im Durchschnitt dann 8,5 Prozent Rendite und dann lassen wir uns
einfach nur noch auszahlen.
Plus Dividende natürlich.
Ja, andere Länder gehen ja stärker da rein, wenn sie zum Beispiel Rohstoff zu verkaufen haben.
Also wir haben das mit Saudi-Arabien, wir haben das mit Norwegen,
da ist das eine andere Sache.
Das kann man gar nicht tun und deswegen hat genau dieser Vorschlag,
der das natürlich auf den Punkt bringt, wie irre dieses System ist,
dann doch ein bisschen schwer an den Kapitalmärkten.
Ja, ich habe mich da so ein bisschen orientiert an The West Wing, dieser alten Serie,
in der die Clinton-Regieringschaft so über den Kläger lobt wurde,
wo dann auch eine Fernsehdebatte zum Thema Migration stattfand und der eine
Kandidat meinte, ich baue eine drei Meter hohe Mauer und dann der demokratische
Kandidat, meine wird fünf Meter.
Und damit einfach Schachmatt. Da ist das Argument gemacht und die Leute,
die darauf anspringen, fallen dann da rein.
Ja, ich würde auch sagen, also ich habe es ja am Ende des Presseclubs nochmal betont mit,
Wenn wir einfach nur abschöpfen könnten, was wir in der deutschen Volkswirtschaft
an Kapitalerträgen, Renditen, Dividenden, Mieten und so weiter haben,
dann hätten wir Budget für Forschung und Entwicklung.
Nämlich für echte Produkte, die die ganze Welt brauchen wird.
Wir sind ja die Pioniere des Alterns.
Also Haushaltsroboter, selbstfahrende Autos, der ganze Kram.
Wir haben ja eigentlich in Grundlast diese Industrie noch da.
Nur jetzt, dass wir uns da von China überholen und so und der ganze Kram.
Die Hidden Champions sind ja da.
Und da müsste man jetzt rein investieren und da hätte man auch genug Zeit.
Wir finden ja jetzt 15 Jahre lang keine Auszahlung statt.
Jedes Jahr verschulden wir uns wieder mit 12 Milliarden plus 3 Prozent mehr,
ohne da jemals was auszuzahlen.
Erst wenn die Babyboomer alle in die Lebenserwartung stoßen,
soll das ausgezahlt werden.
Also es ist ein völlig untauglicher Vorschlag für das, was uns als Problem droht.
Und dieses Geld zahlen wir einfach nur in die Welt, um es einfach gezielt anzuwenden.
Und es ist definitiv einfach ein Kleckerbetrag. Also es ist ja völlig richtig
von dir zu sagen, wir brauchen eigentlich eine viel höhere Summe,
wenn man das schon machen würde.
Aber das ist wahrscheinlich so sein Umfeld.
Ja, das kommen wir jetzt.
Armut. Und das hat nichts damit zu tun, dass die Leute nicht genügend zurückgelegt haben.
Die meisten Leute in Deutschland können nichts Nennenswertes sparen fürs Alter.
Heil sagt hier, wir brauchen eine Generationenkapital, weil wir ansonsten,
das ist die Drohung, die Rentenzahlung vom Niveau der Lohnzahlung entkoppeln.
Wir haben aber die Zahlung der Lohnen, also,
Die Höhe der Löhne entkoppelt von der Produktivität der deutschen Volkswirtschaft.
Das war ein Fehler von vor 30 Jahren. Jetzt machen wir quasi einen ähnlichen
Fehler, indem wir hier einfach so ein System aufbauen.
Und jetzt kommt sozusagen, warum Christian Lindner das, obwohl es nicht die
Aktienrente ist, wie er das meinte, aber es ist halt ein Generationenkapital, okay.
Warum er das trotzdem ganz gut findet. Denn die Leute können ihm schon so ein
bisschen die Wunschlisten schreiben.
Hier dieses kleine Snippet, was er da so noch unterbringt.
Außerdem wird das Generationenkapital auch Vermögenswerte zur Eigenkapitalunterlegung übertragen bekommen.
Bis 2028 planen wir 15 Milliarden Euro.
Ja, wir stellen jetzt fest, hätten wir mal nicht die Wohnung verkauft und sowas
und jetzt die einen oder anderen Vermögenswerte des Staates werden wir noch
zur Eigenkapitalunterfütterung und so darüber schieben.
Das ist natürlich eine Liquidierung.
Die sollen das ja liquidieren, um damit dann auf dem Aktienmarkt tätig zu werden.
Also braucht es dafür Käufer.
So, wer die Käufer sind, wissen wir nicht. Ich unterstelle, das sind Christian
Lindners Buddies, die er in seinen Clubs da so trifft. Was sie demnächst kaufen können?
Tja, hier hören wir nur Gestammel bei Christian Lindner.
Ja, wir planen Bundesbeteiligungen, die nicht im öffentlichen Interesse stehen,
an das Generationenkapital zu übertragen.
Welche das im Einzelnen sind, das ist nicht heute zu entscheiden und im Übrigen
auch nicht öffentlich anzukündigen.
Jedenfalls haben wir da einen Fahrplan uns vorgenommen.
Also vertraut ihr bitte.
Ich habe das hier im Griff. Ich weiß genau, was ich verkaufen werde,
was nicht im öffentlichen Interesse steht.
Achso, das Bahnnetz war doch noch sowas gut und so, ja, irgendwie.
Also es ist wirklich Hanebüchen.
Lindner zeigt sich jetzt ganz froh, dass das relativ intransparent abläuft und
auch keine großen Kontrollen demnächst stattfinden.
Das Generationenkapital wird politikfern, wenn ich das mal so formulieren darf, angelegt.
Zur Verwaltung wird nämlich eine Stiftung öffentlichen Rechts errichtet und
sie entscheidet unabhängig über die Investitionen.
Die Durchführung der Anlage des Stiftungsvermögens soll vorerst durch den Kenfo
im Auftrag der Stiftung Generationen Kapital erfolgen.
Der Kenfo, wie Sie wissen, verwaltet ja bereits heute erfolgreich ein Stiftungsvermögen
von rund 24 Milliarden Euro im Auftrag des Bundes, um die Finanzierung der kerntechnischen
Entsorgung sicherzustellen.
Und es geht ja nicht nur um Aktien, sondern auch illiquide Investitionen sind
möglich. Also Investitionen in Liquides, also möglicherweise investiert man dann in Immobilien.
Und will dann Rendite haben.
Und will Rendite haben. Ja, also wir.
Das ist ja bei der privaten Altersversorgung, wir haben es ja besprochen,
als es die Frau angerufen wurde, die Vonovia verklagt und festgestellt hat,
achso, ich kämpfe hier gerade gegen meine eigene Rendite, weil ja mein eigenes
Geld in Vonovia investiert ist.
Jaja, man sägt am eigenen Ast dann.
Linda geht es aber auch darum, es soll jetzt insgesamt mal ein bisschen mehr
Geld zur Verfügung gestellt werden.
Dass in Deutschland Vermögen auch so ungleich verteilt ist, hängt damit zusammen,
dass viele und zu viele Menschen sich überhaupt gar nicht daran beteiligen.
Die Einführung des Generationenkapitals ist deshalb viel bedeutsamer,
als nur für die 30er Jahre 200 Milliarden Euro anzuhäufen.
Mit Potenzial auch mehr zu tun. Nein, es ist eine Chance, einen gesellschaftlichen
Lerneffekt einzuleiten.
Dass wir im Vergleich zu anderen Gesellschaften zu wenig auf die privaten Kapitalmärkte
vertrauen, das darf nicht fortgesetzt werden.
Ja, wir brauchen hier den großen Mentalitätswandel.
Wir werden in diesem Jahr deshalb auch ein Paket vorlegen zur Reform der betrieblichen
wie der privaten Altersversorgung.
Im Bereich der privaten Altersversorgung geht es darum, die...
Im Bereich der privaten Altersversorgung geht es darum, die Riester-Produkte
attraktiver zu machen und bei neuen, innovativen,
auch risikoorientiertere Vorsorgeformen nachzudenken, wie etwa ein sogenanntes Altersvorsorgedepot.
Ja, hier, also es gab einige Kritik. Es schreiben ja dann immer dieselben Leute
auf Twitter im Sinne von, ey, wenn du so gegen Kapitalerträge wetterst und so.
Sehr viele Leute machen ihre Altersvorsorge am Aktienmarkt. Da würde ich sagen,
wenn man mit dem Staat vereinbart, dass man so und so viel von seinem Lohn selber
abknapst, um das in Kapitalerträge für die eigene Rente zu sichern.
Wenn man einfach einen Auszahlungsplan für sich, ich möchte das als Rente ausgezahlt
haben und nicht von heute auf gleich haue ich das alles auf den Kopf und so weiter.
Okay, dann von mir aus weiter 25% Rentenkapitalertrag oder sowas.
Aber das trifft nun echt mal nicht auf die große Masse der in Deutschland Aktienhabenden
zu, sondern da geht es einfach um Dividende und Rendite und nicht um irgendwie
so einen Sparplan für irgendwas.
Also klar statistisch ist es schon sichtbar, dass auch in Deutschland private
Altersversicherungen am Kapitalmarkt gemacht wird, aber eben nicht in diesem Maße.
Nun gut, wozu das Ganze? Jetzt haben wir ja vorhin schon gehört,
okay, die CDU macht einen Riesenaufschlag beim Thema Totalverweigerung und so,
aber gibt es gar keine. Das sind ganz, ganz kleine Zahlen.
Wir wissen auch nicht, ob das irgendwann mal zu irgendwas führt,
wie viel neue Arbeitskräfte der Arbeitsmarkt jetzt gewinnt.
Wie viel Entlastung der Rentenkasse gewinnen wir jetzt und ab wann?
Bis Mitte der 30er Jahre soll das Generationenkapital damit ein Gesamtvolumen
von 200 Milliarden Euro erreichen und ab dann können erste Ausschüttungen erfolgen.
Wir gehen jetzt von 10 Milliarden Euro im Jahr aus.
Also der Jahrgang 71 geht dann 2037 oder so in Rente, nee, 38 mit 67 Jahren.
Das heißt, zwei Jahre bevor der letzte Babyboomer-Jahrgang in Rente geht,
gibt es dann die ersten Renditen auf Höhe von, wie er sagt, 10 Milliarden pro Jahr.
Bei 400 Milliarden Rente, die wir zahlen.
Und da kommt dann auch die Rechnung, ja, dann ist das ungefähr eine Woche.
Von der ganzen Jahresleistung Rente, die Deutschland mobilisieren muss,
haben wir dann eine Woche finanziert. Super.
Also 2% fit für die Zukunft. 2-3% der Rente haben wir denn damit organisiert.
Also es ist wirklich absurd.
Und naja, hören wir den letzten Clip noch, dass das alles total safe ist hier.
Der Aktienmarkt, immer Spekulation. Nein, es ist alles ganz safe.
Bei allen Punkten, die wir jetzt gesetzlich regeln, kann eine künftige Bundesregierung es ändern.
Bezogen auf das Generationenkapital will ich nur sagen, dass das kein Kapitalstock
ist, der dann für anderes zur Verfügung stünde. Also in den allgemeinen Haushalt
überführt werden könnte.
Deshalb ist er in eine eigene Stiftung überführt und deshalb entsprechend gesichert.
Politik fern. Ja, wir werden sehen, wohin uns das führt, ob uns das rettet. Ich befürchte nein.
Wir wollen noch darauf hinweisen, dass man uns live erleben kann und wir würden
jetzt noch diesen Termin bekannt geben. Und zwar haben wir ihn bislang nur im
Salon verkündet, aber jetzt mal für alle. Am 24.
August sind wir in Frankfurt im Saalbau in Bornheim.
In dem du ja auch kürzlich warst.
Genau, da kann man sehr gut auftreten, da kann man auch von überall gut sehen
und da ist auch einiges zu erleben, denn da ist tatsächlich so die eine der
Partymeilen von Frankfurt schien mir.
Die Bergerstraße ist nicht weit und sowas. Da ist schon was los. Bornheim, die Ecke. Ja.
Und da sind wir am 24. August. Wir verlinken hier unter dem Podcast, wo man Karten bekommt.
Das geht dann über die CASE. Wir sind nicht in das Ticketing in irgendeiner Weise involviert.
Aber man kann dann über den Link dorthin kommen. Genau.
Das sind auch die letzten Karten für dieses Jahr, die es gibt.
Wir haben jetzt 1200 insgesamt verkauft für die CASE und den Saalbau und da
im Saalbau sind es jetzt ungefähr noch 300, die man abgreifen kann.
Und mehr Auftritte machen wir dann nicht in diesem Jahr.
Alles andere klären wir triliteral mit Menschen, die sich in unsere...
Keine Ahnung, Begegnung, einkaufen für hunderttausende von Euro oder so.
Achso, ja so.
Wir müssen jetzt auch mal langsam Business-Ideen.
Willst du so Firmen-Shows machen? Neue 20er für Vorstandsmitglieder von irgendjemandem
oder so. Da könntest du das dann nochmal mit der Rente mitbringen.
Ja, das ist eine schöne neue Geschäftsidee. Wie gesagt, wir lesen im nächsten
Salon dieses eine Leben Glaube jenseits der Religion, Freiheit jenseits des
Kapitalismus von Martin Hecklund,
erschienen bei CH Beck, das ist das Buch, das wir dann ausführlich diskutieren.
Manche, die noch nie vom Salon gehört haben, das ist also das,
Zusatzsegment dieses Podcasts. Das ist auch die einzige Möglichkeit,
wie man den Podcast unterstützen kann, nämlich indem man den Salon abonniert.
Das kann man über Steady tun.
Das ist ganz einfach. Man geht auf die neue 20er-Seite, folgt da dem Button Salon.
Man kann, wenn man den Podcast bei Spotify hört, da auch auf einen Button klicken
und kommt dann zu Steady.
Wenn man schon bei Patreon angemeldet ist, dann kann man das über Patreon tun.
Außerdem für die Apple-Kunden, die es bequem haben wollen und ein bisschen mehr
zahlen wegen der Apple-Gebühr, können das auch über Apple dann direkt buchen,
und wir sagen noch mal hinzu, dass man trotzdem dann egal wie man es gebucht
hat, den Podcast so hören kann, wie man ihn gerne hören möchte.
Das heißt, es gibt einen RSS-Feed und den kann man dann da einpflegen, wie man es gerne hätte.
Kannst du schon etwas sagen, was du im nächsten Salon lesen wirst?
Ich sag mal, was grob auf meiner Liste steht.
Achso, wir müssen das noch für die, die den Salon noch eigentlich nicht kennen.
Also es ist immer so, wir diskutieren ausführlich anderthalb Stunden etwa über
ein Buch, das wir gemeinsam gelesen haben und dann stellt jeder noch Texte vor
oder Bücher vor, die wichtig waren für den Monat.
Yes, da gibt es also keine Clips, sondern nur Texte, die wir besprechen.
Untergekommen ist mir ein Paper von der Europäischen Zentralbank selbst,
Es heißt Shocked, Shocked to the Core, ein neues Modell, um Inflation im Euroraum zu verstehen.
Vielleicht hat man gelernt aus Boris Höfgens Kritik, dass das Inflation und
Preisschock doch zwei verschiedene Sachen sind und wer mehr aus Japan gehört,
sieht man das auch ein bisschen anders. ist.
Andrew Huberman ist in die Kritik geraten. Zumindest gibt es jetzt Porträts
über ihn, die mal dieses ganze,
ich weiß nicht, ob du ihn kennst, das ist ja so ein etwas muskulärerer Typ, der so als Psycho-Doc,
sich in relativ viele Podcasts einladen lässt, um da einfach nochmal wie ist
das jetzt mit den Neuronen, wie viel Licht brauche ich morgens und so weiter,
so in diese Brian Johnson Ecke für alle.
Der Volks-Brian Johnson sozusagen. Außerdem die Zeit, Thüringen,
warum eigentlich immer Thüringen? Das scheint mir auch interessant zu sein.
Mal gucken, ob ich das lese.
Und ja, so in die Richtung wird es gehen.
Ich habe es mir noch sehr offen gehalten.
Gelagert, zwischengespeichert und so weiter. Aber ich halte es mir noch offen
in der Auswahl. Alles weitere dann im Salon.
Wir freuen uns, wenn ihr dort auch hinkommt, wenn wir uns dann dort auch sehen
und ihr uns dann zuhört, wie wir diese Bücher und Texte diskutieren und uns
fragen mit Martin Hecklund,
ob wir auf Glauben angewiesen sind und ob wir den Jenseits der Religion bekommen. kommen. Mal schauen.
Jetzt aber erstmal Frohe Ostern.
Schönes religiöses Osterfest.